Intro
Die ein oder andere Kleinigkeit Ich kann mich erinnern Wir sind im Januar rausgegangen mit und im Februar sieht man ein bisschen eher weil Termine erwartbar Biennale keine Ahnung Mitte des Monats treffen wir uns.
Dann können wir den Januar aufarbeiten zack Februar Thüringen Washington Wuhan.
Alles kommt auf einmal gut hört ihr hier zum einen drüben Wolfgang ihr kennt ihn vielleicht er sieht immer Schmuck aus Das ist aber in ein Podcast egal.
Aber ich bemühe mich trotzdem meinem Gegenüber für mich.
Es ist allein für mich gemacht.
Ich trage heute einen Zweireiher. Mein Name ist Wolfgang im Schritt von Film Analyse und Wirtschaft Wohlstand für alle. Um mir gegenüber nicht im Anzug sondern im T-Shirt sitzt Stefan Schulz Hose. Denn wir sind.
In der Jogginghose denn wir sind hier bei mir zu Hause und ich fühle mich wie zu Hause wenn ich zu Hause bin.
Ja auch zu Hause. Genau genau. Sehr gut. Also es ging um einiges.
Aber du siehst auch zu Hause aus deswegen fühlst du dich ja auch sehr gut so Also es ging um einiges in diesem Februar.
Da war ich erst einmal. Es ist für mich ein Wahnsinn. Aber wir wollen noch mal einfließen.
Es ist ja Wahnsinn aber gut so ist es und wir wollen noch einmal anschließen an Januar denn wir haben ja damit geendet. Fratzscher gegen Friedrich Merz und jetzt ist zurückgetreten.
Wir haben ja mit dem Auto verändert. Razzia gegen Friedrich Merz.
Als CDU-Chefin hat den Weg frei gemacht und hat sich Merz als allererster gedacht.
Die Chefin Weg freigemacht. Merz als allererster gewacht.
Die Leute wollen mich. Ich höre sie rufen also will ich auch.
Til Schweiger will auch.
Ging es auch gestern noch einmal durch die Agenturen. Til Schweiger findet das ganz toll.
Dass Merz antritt.
Friedrich Merz spricht Klartext.
Das hat er auch habe ich das letzte Mal kurz erwähnt. Das hat er auch an Trump so bewundert.
Bei Markus Lanz Trump ist wenigstens ehrlich sagt America first. Alle anderen haben herumgedrückt na gut da haben wir auch solche Kaliber.
Wir hören noch mal kurz rein denn Wolfgang Will doch noch die eine oder andere Anmerkung machen ich finde auch da gibts noch unendlich viele Anmerkungen zu machen aber irgendwie hab ich mir gedacht.
Es sind jetzt zehn Minuten kürzer kriege ich es nicht dann lieber in Länge ohne Kommentar,
zum Einstieg heute Ausklang Januar Februar.
Hören wir doch noch hier rein in dieses Gespräch. Also kleine Erinnerung zum letzten Mal.
Das neue Führungsduo der SPD setzt sich auch für höhere Steuern ein mit Vermögenssteuer Erbschaftsteuerreform Anhebung des Spitzensteuersatzes.
Drehen Sie damit an der Steuerschraube was auch zur Wahrheit dazugehört ist nicht nur dass Unternehmen relativ hohe Steuern zahlen müssen sondern dass es kein anderes Land in der Welt gibt wo Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer mehr Steuern zahlen müssen,
und wo Vermögen und Einkommen auf Vermögen geringer besteuert wird als in Deutschland. Wir haben hier eine große Unwucht.
Welchen Bereich wären Sie denn für höhere Steuern.
Ich wäre für eine stärkere Belastung von passiven vermögen.
Nehmen Sie das Thema Erbschaftssteuer. Wir haben Menschen die weniger als Erstes machen wir weniger als die Hälfte der Deutschen die überhaupt etwas erben.
Die Menschen die zwischen 250 000 550 Euro erben zahlen Durchschnitt 12 Prozent Erbschaftsteuer die die mehr als 20 Millionen Euro erben zahlen im Durchschnitt weniger als zwei Prozent Erbschaftssteuer.
Hier geht das durch. Wir haben ja einen ökonomen der politische Handlung fordert.
Da geht es eigentlich um Steuergerechtigkeit. Wären Sie da dabei ist das nicht so.
Das sind Zahlen die hier in den Raum geworfen werden. Deswegen habe ich dazwischen gerufen.
Das sind zum großen Teil Unternehmen die das Geld in den Unternehmen.
Die gehören dann der nächsten Generation. Wenn Sie die mit 25 Prozent Erbschaftssteuer belasten machen die Unternehmen zu wenn sie mit fünf oder zehn Prozent belasten könnten sie es nicht.
Ich bin nun in drei Erbschaftsteuerreform dabeigewesen.
Ich habe dieses eine endlose Geschichte in Deutschland die letzte Erbschaftsteuerreform ist so gemacht worden dass insbesondere die mittelständischen Eigentümer geführten Unternehmen verschont werden wenn sie die Arbeitsplätze erhalten und nur dann wenn sie die Arbeitsplätze erhalten haben Sie diese Verschonung.
Und ihm gegenübersitzt ein Politiker der sagt nee Politik funktioniert ja nicht. Wir können es nicht machen.
Wir haben schon dreimal versagt.
Und man glaubt ihr dass man indem man keine Erbschaftssteuer für Unternehmen dass man damit die Arbeitsplätze sichert.
Dabei weiß man dass fünf bis zehn Prozent die Fratzscher fordert überhaupt nicht problematisch dass beispielsweise diese Unternehmen enorm profitiert haben von Steuererleichterungen auch durch die rot grüne Regierung,
die nicht weitergegeben wurden zum Beispiel in Investitionen und schon gar nicht für höhere Löhne.
Paradigmatisch dass wir mittlerweile in der ökonomie von Hans-Werner Sinn vertreten wird einen Umbruch erleben,
eigentlich so etwas wie eine politische ökonomie zurückkehrt dass man das ökonomische politisch begreift und der Politik,
einen Politiker.
Das kann man ganz deutlich sagen Kapitalinteressen vertritt die Kapitalinteressen eines passiven Kapitals vertritt,
auf keinen Fall möchte dass solches Vermögen besteuert wird dass Erbschaften besteuert werden.
Das passive Vermögen besteuert wird.
Wir zahlen als Arbeitnehmer sehr hohe Steuern während ich weniger Steuern zahlen müsste wenn ich investieren würde verrückteste Derivatehandel.
Z.b. Also gerade bei Derivaten also Verbriefung von wo man wirklich sehr weit ist vom Materiellen und so virtuell sich das Geld herschiebt.
Wo allerdings die mathematischen Formeln trotzdem funktionieren und deswegen da um mehrere Faktoren plötzlich mehr Geld vorhanden ist obwohl die Wirtschaft oder die Erde gar nicht gewachsen ist.
Im Gegenteil wir haben ja mit Schrumpfung von Ressourcen zu tun.
Es ist erstaunlich dass man in Deutschland den Mertz so da sitzen hat nicht nur mit dem Argument aus dieser,
passiven Geldvermehrung Interessen geleiteten Settings sondern dass er selbst noch aus diesen Blackrock Aufsichtsrat als sozusagen,
Beschäftigter in diese politische Sphäre hineinwirkt mit diesem Argument also mehr Korruption im soziologischen Sinne also Grenzüberschreitungen aus der ökonomie ins Politische ist eigentlich gar nicht vorstellbar.
Bei ihm ist das auf allen Ebenen macht er diesen MUW und wir werden ja nachher noch ausführlich darauf zu sprechen kommen auf die Denker,
vielleicht vergangener Zeiten aber mal gucken die sagen Das Politische ist erst mal grundsätzlich gefährlich und für uns Eigentümer auch böse.
Wir schließen es grundsätzlich aus dass unserem Denken und unserem Handeln gleiches Recht für alle aber bloß nichts Politisches darüber gebaut. Aber.
Aber man braucht eine Politik die genau das umsetzt und dazu wir einen kleinen Schlenker jetzt machen über Thüringen.
Genau,
Ja wir machen jetzt einen Schlenker.
Und da stellt sich dann diese Frage Wie kann das eigentlich sein dass die FDP überhaupt zu so einem Schritt bereit war.
Denn es ist doch eigentlich eine liberale Partei der Freiheit verpflichtet. Was meint denn da eigentlich Freiheit.
Aber.
Wir sind erst einmal den Zeichen und Symbolen. Wenn wir darüber sprechen wenn wir über Thüringen reden Da sind Bilder.
Ganz genau wenn wir in unserem Modus hier die 20er Jahre Chronistenpflicht ich mit Wetten auf den Februar Schaden von dem wir dachten Das wird ein ruhiger Monat und wir können den Januar noch nacharbeiten weil da gab es ja auch noch einiges.
Dann müssen wir doch mal diesen 5. Februar festhalten als nicht nur Ereignis sondern wirklich auch gestenreich am Tag und es war vielleicht nicht nur weil man weiß gestern funktionieren im Fernsehen recht gut.
Sondern es war auch wirklich ein emotionaler Ausbruch sowohl wirklich am gleichen Tag bei Nancy Pelosi der Mehrheitsführer im,
Abgeordnetenhaus im Repräsentantenhaus in Amerika die beide State of the Union hinter Trump steht und sein Manuskript zerreisst.
Eigentlich eine unglaubliche Geste dafür dass man noch vor wenigen Jahren unter Obama dem Vorgänger selbst einen einzelnen,
Ruf aus dem Publikum über Monate diskutiert hat und auch überlegt hat ob man das auch juristisch nochmal einhegen muss.
Mittlerweile wird bei der State of the Julián rum gebrüllt und im Kollektiv gerufen und stehend applaudiert und Wahlkampfslogan Four more years gerufen dass es einem wirklich gruselt was Amerika vor sich geht und dann nur wenige Stunden später,
wirft Susanne Henning Welzow einem deutschen Ministerpräsidenten drei Sekunden nach seiner Wahl den Blumenstrauß einfach vor die Füße verbeugt sich kurz vor dem Amt aber lässt die Person links liegen dreht sich um und geht.
Kein Handschlag nichts.
So etwas haben wir auch selten bis nie gesehen in Deutschland.
Unglaublich eigentlich kann man fast nur dich fragen ob du da noch die Noten vergeben willst doch sehr.
Nancy Pelosi war mir ein bisschen zu sehr geplant. Es wirkte nicht so überzeugend.
Bei solchen Sachen ist das Timing interessant. Ein Schauspieler das richtige Timing um das zu.
Wiederholen aber auf der Bühne geht es darum dass es funktioniert.
Hier hatte ich den Eindruck Trump das Stichwort gegeben.
Jetzt ist Schluss Nancy Pelosi von langer Hand geplant hat sie sich hingelegt haben sie sofort eingreifen kann.
Das fand ich eher eine.
Geste und als solches funktionierte das. Das geistert,
durch die sozialen Netzwerke während ich den Blumenstrauß aus Thüringen wesentlich eindrucksvoller fand weil wir hier wirklich mit einer Situation zu tun,
hatten die die Welt nicht mehr verstanden haben die nicht damit gerechnet dass das passiert.
Hat selbstverständlich damit gerechnet dass eine derartige Rede halten wird.
Er hat ja die Erwartungen übertroffen.
Irgendetwas war erwartungsgemäß kann man sagen was sich in Thüringen abgespielt hat war eine große überraschung.
Und in den Momenten ist es dann die Frage Wie reagiert man überhaupt darauf.
Was kann man tun kann man überhaupt irgendetwas tun.
Sehr sehr wohl gesetzt gewesen.
Ich hoffe dass wir es hier mit einer fast heldenhaften Geste zu tun haben auch deshalb weil sie aus dem Moment heraus entsteht und nicht in irgendeiner Weise geplant sein konnte sondern aus dem Moment heraus entstanden.
Entscheidend sind die Symbolwirkung,
berühmten Texte.
Über das allmähliche,
beim Reden und Entschuldigung von Kleist gibt es diese Idee eine Geste vielleicht ein nervöses ziehen an der Manschette oder so.
Die Revolution auslösen kann.
Inwieweit die entscheidend ist. Ich glaube dass man diesen Blumenstrauß nicht unterschätzen sollte.
Insofern noch einmal deutlich gemacht hat was jetzt hier gerade stattgefunden hat.
Darauf können wir jetzt nicht ordnungsgemäß reagieren sondern können nur so ein Zeichen der Plötzlichkeit setzen dass dadurch noch,
eine politische Wirkung über diese symbolische Wirkung hinaus,
wahrscheinlich bürgerlich in der Mitte befindlichen klar wird irgendetwas was absolut nicht geht,
ist denke ich sehr sehr intelligent dass das so stattgefunden hat. Beeindruckender als Pelosi.
Ja es gab nur überraschungsmomente in Thüringen. Das stimmt.
Die Helling hat wahrscheinlich trotzdem ein bisschen mehr als die von mir angesprochenen drei Sekunden Zeit gehabt war ja auch vom Präsidium also von der Sitzungsleitung im Landtag schon per Kopfschütteln Hinweis gegeben.
Werden die Zahlen vorgelesen macht euch schon mal Gedanken weil das geht hier so aus wie es nicht glauben wollte.
Trotzdem super spontan. Da war mehr Planung dahinter schon allein weil sie auch damit begann die Form zu brechen.
Sie hat nämlich angekündigt als es formal vorgesehen ist.
Üblicherweise ist es die große Ehre der Hauptleitung den Präsidenten zu begrüßen und sie hat aber nur gesagt Liebe Leute hier ist ein Präsident sie hat sozusagen die Ehre erwiesen seines Auftritts.
Das hat Trump dann natürlich auch. Da gab es ja noch diese Gäste mit dem nicht gegebenem Handschlag zu quittiert.
Da kann man natürlich alles zusammenbinden und es gipfelte in diesem zerrissenen Manuskript wobei man nochmal sagen muss über die Situation hinaus wurden da auch noch nochmal Gegenstände einfach benutzt.
Der Blumenstrauß und das Manuskript und das fand ich auch hochinteressant wenn man drüber nachdenkt.
Eigentlich sind wir ja mittlerweile so weit 2020 zu sagen Ja wir haben noch die eine oder andere Zeremonie und da gehört der eine oder andere Gegenstand dazu.
Aber es ist nicht vergleichbar mit diesem britischen Modell das Zepter des Königs liegt auf.
Also liegt im Saal wo wir gerade miteinander reden stellvertretend für ihn haben wir sozusagen die sakrale Herrschaft manifestiert.
Aber eben nur anwesend nicht inhaltlich von Bedeutung und diesem Blumenstrauß zu werfen okay das Manuskript.
Diese Sachen haben eigentlich nicht von Bedeutung es ist eigentlich nur Deko.
Dachten wir bisher Es ist eigentlich ob sie jetzt mitliest oder nicht keine Ahnung wie sie das Manuskript mitlesen.
Irgendwie gucken ob die Worte stimmen. Am Ende gilt dann doch das gesprochene Wort soweit es die Fernsehgesellschaft da was das angeht.
Und dass die beiden Sachen doch mal so aus der Bedeutungslosigkeit geholt wurden um einfach so einen richtigen Zivilisationsbruch im Verfahren zu markieren.
Das fand ich wirklich bemerkenswert weil man auch sagen muss in den deutschen Medien kam von der State of the Union eben wirklich nur an diesen typischen Kurznachrichten im Deutschlandfunk Tagesthemen und so weiter da war,
der Handschlag und das zerrissene Manuskript gut sichtbar das der Spiegel dann nochmal Höpcke auf das Bild gehoben hat auf das Titelbild statt den Blumenstrauß fand ich so ein bisschen.
Die haben noch nicht ganz verstanden.
War ein Fehler war aber wirklich ein redaktioneller Fehler würde ich mal so sagen Hätte man anders machen müssen. Naja.
Aber sehr schön was du sagst es ist ja so dass das,
alltägliche Gegenstände sind oder sie sind nicht aufgeladen das ist ein typischer Blumenstrauß der immer bei solchen Gelegenheiten übergeben wird der nicht vorher gesegnet wurde oder irgendetwas weitergegeben wird der bedeutungslos ist genauso.
Wurde,
ja auch direkt weitergegeben.
Gedrucktes Manuskript wo man sagen kann Da hätte auch sein können dass es auf dem iPad liest.
Nein hatte es noch ausgedruckt und erst durch den Akt des zerreissen bekommt das plötzlich etwas symbolhafte.
Und da stellt sich dann auch die Frage haben wir in Demokratien doch noch solche fast sakralen Gegenstände oder haben wir eben nicht mehr.
Man würde sagen Politologen aus Frankreich der Demokratie die leere Mitte da sitzt eben kein König mehr.
Wie du sagst aber wir haben also offenbar doch diese Gepflogenheiten und diese bieten auch ein Korsett wie eine demokratische Ordnung funktionieren kann und deswegen ist dieser,
Schockeffekt bei Trump so groß nicht wegen seiner einzelnen politischen Maßnahmen nur da könnte man sagen Das unterscheidet sich oft gar nicht so stark von George Bush beispielsweise.
Aber Bush hat die Formen viel stärker noch eingehalten als Trump das tut und hat diese demokratischen ungeschriebenen Gesetze eingehalten und dort gibt man den Leuten die Hand macht dies und das,
macht genau das nicht mehr und dadurch ist diese,
Konstruktion.
Das Sakrale innerhalb einer Demokratie.
Das wird eigentlich mit Füßen getreten durch Trump oder andere dieser Art und damit haben auch sehr viele auch gerade so aus einem liberal demokratischen Spektrum. Ein großes Problem.
Ja da kommt man nachher ganz ausführlich drauf denn du hast uns hier Carl Schmitt mitgebracht und ich bin sehr gespannt wie man die beiden überhaupt zusammen in einen Raum ohne dass sie sich sofort erstechen gegenseitig auslöschen.
Es funktioniert prima.
Ja das ist eben auch eine überraschung. Bin wie gesagt wir schließen jetzt um Thüring zu behandeln und dann eben auch dieses Impeachment.
In unserer Neujahrsansprache Wir haben das letzte Mal eine Stunde verbracht mit Neujahrsansprache gucken wir dachten so gut launiger Einstieg Keine Ahnung ich habe das einfach mal so mitgebracht und du hast es ertragen dankenswerterweise vielleicht aber auch nicht allzu viele meinem Rat gefolgt und die Kapitel mag ich gleich bemüht aber wenn wir uns jetzt erinnern,
an die Protagonisten kamen da eben alle vor Markus Söder Wir haben uns ein bisschen lustig gemacht aber auch sehr souverän empfunden in seiner Spielerei die er so gemacht hat.
Bodo Ramelow besorgt aber trotzdem auch irgendwie so neugierig erregt hat uns noch mal erklärt wie Demokratie eigentlich funktioniert vielleicht auch sich selbst.
Vielleicht war das auch eine versteckte Botschaft an die anderen im Parlament hört euch mal meine Neujahrsansprache an und beachtet das auch was ich sage dann Reiner Haseloff dem wir ja sehr staatstragend nichtssagend und ein bisschen lustig gemacht über seinen Berichterstatter Tuma.
Und Reiner Haseloff steht nun auch mit auf der Protagonisten Liste weil 2021 dort gewählt wird.
Und irgendwo das war eigentlich zu erwarten. In den 20er Jahren jetzt irgendwo bricht die AfD mal durch und bindet Nähe zur Macht an sich.
In Thüringen hat sich jetzt über diese Königsmacher Rolle geschafft. Sie war sozusagen ohne ihre Stimmen ginge das nicht.
Was käme dann auch entsprechend ins anbrachte und auch goutiert mit seiner Annahme der Wahl und auch der Ablegung des Eises.
In Sachsen-Anhalt sitzt die AfD jetzt schon mit 24 Prozent jetzt schon höher als die AfD in Thüringen und da wird 21 gewählt.
Man muss halt echt sagen es war zu erwarten im Sinne von irgendein ostdeutsches Land wird da kippen denn das habe ich jetzt für Rentner Republik auch nochmal beim Recherchieren das es ist wirklich so gruselig.
Das Institut der deutschen Wirtschaft also eigentlich ein sehr neoliberales,
Institut auf Höhe der deutschen Wirtschaftspolitik sozusagen,
hat schon mal vorausberechnet 2035 also nicht allzu weit entfernt sind sieben Prozent aller Ostdeutschen in Pflege also wirklich Pflegefälle diagnostizierte Pflegefälle 7 Prozent.
Da hängt also ein riesen rattenschwanz an Menschen die gar nicht mehr arbeiten können die aus Erwerbsarbeit rausfallen Menschen die sich um die kümmern müssen und deswegen aus der Erwerbsarbeit rausfallen Menschen die es dann nicht mehr aushalten und wegziehen bevor sie in Erwerbsarbeit reinkommen.
Wir haben es dort wirklich mit Renten Republique im Sinne von stagnierender Gesellschaft Verarmung Alterung und so weiter zu tun und es ist nun mal dieses Petrischalen Becken für so eine Partei wie die AfD die da kommen darauf zurück doch den großen Rückschritt irgendwie machen will.
Und jetzt ist es eben nicht Sachsen-Anhalt gewesen sondern Thüringen. Und es gibt trotzdem diesen einen erschreckenden Klepp Denn Sachsen-Anhalt warf jetzt auch schon seine Schatten voraus Wir hören hier den CDU,
Vizefraktionschef aus Sachsen-Anhalt.
Unter Eindruck der Vorgänge in Thüringen.
Eine Minderheitsregierung eine CDU Minderheitsregierung ist absolut denkbar natürlich auch wenn sie von der AfD toleriert wird,
von wem sie dann toleriert wird weiß ich ja in dem Moment nicht sagt der stellvertretende Fraktionschef im Landtag.
Nächstes Jahr wird in Sachsen-Anhalt.
Das Schlimme daran ist ja nicht nur wie unbedarft dieser Mensch ist zumindest so unbedarft und sagt Naja irgendjemand muss irgendwie Wir wissen ja,
es ist ja nicht nur das Problem dass eine gewisse machtgeil egal von wem man ins Amt gehoben wird sondern man kann davon ausgehen.
So wie das schon formuliert ist überhaupt keine Ahnung davon hat welche Auffassung von Demokratie,
hat und warum sie das machen würde warum sie ihn unterstützen würde warum sie unterstützt,
und gerade auch der völkische nationale Flügel von Höcke begreift ja Demokratie als ein Werkzeug um an die Macht zu kommen.
Sie sind nicht einfach demokratiefeindlich indem sie sagen Wir lehnen die Demokratie ab dann würden sie sich gar nicht als Partei konstituieren.
Einfach nur so auf einen Putsch aus sondern sie missbrauchen die Demokratie für ihre Zwecke benutzen sie als Werkzeug und da gibt es Strategen im Hintergrund.
Das ist zum Beispiel beim Fall Höcke Götz Kubitschek und seinen aus dem Ruder Verlag die solche Ideen haben wie man die Demokratie auch dadurch vollkommen aushöhlen kann indem man solche Spielchen macht.
Es wäre durchaus auch möglich dass die AfD sagt Wir unterstützen ganz schnell ein grünes Anliegen um das Ganze ad absurdum zu führen.
Gauland hat ja auch schon mal angedeutet Ramelow unterstützen würden.
Hier sieht man aber hier wird die Demokratie überhaupt nicht ernst genommen sondern als ein strategisches Spiel begriffen.
Die hätten also gar keine Probleme auch diesen von der CDU irgendwie mal kurz ins Amt zu heben um dort andere Ziele zu verfolgen.
Es geht nicht hier um das klassische paktieren von Parteien das man im Hinterzimmer sich mal ein bisschen trifft und sagt Passt auf wir von der FDP Wir wählen euch jetzt.
Dann müsst ihr aber auch mal so eine schöne Steuerreform machen für die Hoteliers dass man sich da irgendwo einig wird.
Nein es ist eine ganz andere Strategie die auch sehr langfristig ist was wir eines nicht vergessen dürfen.
Wir haben hier Akteure sowohl in der AfD als auch Leute die ihnen intellektuell und strategisch zuspielen die seit Jahren zum Teil Jahrzehnten an einem rechten Projekt arbeiten.
Man sieht hier wie lang der Atem dieser Leute ist bis die das erreichen.
Das heißt Die denken nicht bis zur nächsten Landtagswahl die denken tatsächlich 2035 das ist ein interessanter Hinweis Wenn die alle in der Pflege sind.
Was könnte man jetzt schon vorausdenken was 2035 bei uns machtpolitisch interessant ist.
Hier ist jemand der Denke von heute auf morgen der sagt Na ja wenn die mich.
Über Jahrzehnte angelegt. Die ganzen rechten Vordenker die aus Frankreich,
schreibt seit den 60er Jahren und immer noch aktiv und beeinflusst immer noch auch das rechte Denken.
2035 Man kann auch sagen,
Vielleicht gehen wir einfach ins Panorama und sehen Demokratie 700 Jahre ok. Warum eigentlich. Wieso kam es eigentlich dazu.
Klar heute haben wir das alles so normativ aufgeladen Wir finden Demokratie gut wir wissen aber gar nicht genau warum.
Die denken natürlich anders. Die reduzieren erst mal Demokratie auf diesen Mechanismus den sie rein mathematisch dann sehen wenn wir eine Parlamentsmehrheit haben und dann ist halt Arbeit bis dahin aber wenn wir sie haben dann kann man die Demokratie abschaffen.
Und da steckt dann doch so ein Denken drin. Wenn die Claudi blicken zurück,
auf die Geschichte des politischen Denkens das angelegt ist dann sehen die 2035 und fragen sich,
welche ängste werden die Menschen denn dann haben zu dieser Zeit Sie sehen meine Kinder sind irgendwo weit in der Welt verstreut und ich muss mich hier um meine Eltern und vielleicht sogar noch um die Schwiegereltern kümmern und die sind dement und erkennt mich gar nicht mehr wieder.
Warum pflege ich die eigentlich so welche ängste werden diese Menschen haben und nach welchen Schutzherr,
werden sie eigentlich suchen und dann haben die einfach parat ihren Carl Schmitt und so weiter und gehen die Argumentation mal durch und entwerfen dann einen Plan und das dann so ein CDU Hanseln einfach dasteht und,
an Morgen denkt wo er vielleicht in der Chance ist mal des Ministerpräsidenten Auto zu fahren.
Das ist wirklich krass das einfach so zu sehen und wenn man sich Eindruck mit welcher Selbstherrlichkeit auch so unter dem Eindruck Thüringern dann in so eine Fernsehkamera sagt hat dieser Clip auch eine gewisse Runde gemacht.
Sein Büro hat die Bürogemeinschaft mit jemanden der aus den Niederlanden stammt und die wurde dann auch gleich mal aufgekündigt Kees de Vries gibts auch sehr lustige Clips wie er nämlich kaum verständlich auf deutsch.
Niederländischen Einschlag noch so stark ist.
Dann mal erklärt dass er jetzt mit ihm nicht mehr an einer Bürogemeinschaft aber das ist die größte Konsequenz die man bisher öffentlich gesehen hat nicht wirklich gruselig.
Man muss sich wirklich fragen jetzt in Thüringen Was ist da passiert. Denn es war eben nicht nur dass die AfD diese Königsmacher keine Rolle gekommen ist sondern dass wir grundsätzlich auch bei der FDP und der CDU,
so eine Idee von Demokratie das Reduzieren wir mal auf das Ergebnis einer mathematischen Gleichungen.
Wenn wir eine Mehrheit haben dann akzeptieren wir jetzt mal AfD dann akzeptieren wir sogar dass ein 5% Abgeordneter Ministerpräsident ist das ist unerhört schon für sich.
So darf man Demokratie normativ gesprochen. so darf man Demokratie nicht herunterbrechen auf ein mathematisches Resultat.
Das geht einfach nicht da fehlt das eine oder andere wie sehr die AfD aber jetzt darauf besteht zu sagen Wir sind die besten Demokraten.
Und uns reicht das Resultat einer mathematischen Gleichung.
Das konnte man dann sehen als sie in der Aktuellen Stunde des Bundestags anberaumen von den Grünen glaube ich darauf zu sprechen kamen und wir hören ja mal zwei Ausschnitte von Gauland und diesen Jala oder wie er heißt.
Es wurde in einem deutschen Parlament ein demokratischer Abgeordneter von anderen Demokraten zum Ministerpräsidenten gewählt. Das ist,
die natürlichste und demokratischste Sache der Welt.
Wir wissen heute dass das Misstrauensvotum gegen Willy Brandt im Jahr 1972 an einer vom MfS gekauften Stimme gescheitert ist.
Niemand ist damals und später auf die Idee gekommen die erfolgreichen Brandt Jahre als illegitim zu betrachten.
Sie haben vor aller Welt das Vertrauen in die deutsche Demokratie erschüttert.
Und damit haben sie dem Ansehen Deutschlands erheblichen Schaden zugefügt.
Seit dieser Woche wissen wir hier wollen massive Kräfte das letztlich nicht mehr Wähler und Parlamente entscheiden. Diese Herrschaften und ihre medialen Steigbügelhalter reden gerne und viel von Demokratie.
Aber wenn die Demokratie zu Ergebnissen führt die nicht in den Kram passen dann weisen sie auf den Wert der demokratischen Selbstbestimmung.
Dann treten sie den Parlamentarismus mit Füßen.
Die stellen sich jetzt als die tollen Demokraten hin weil sie ja,
nach den Formeln der Mathematik nach den Gesetzen der Mathematik die sind ja nun ja maßgeblich die Doktrin der Verfassung von Mehrheit gesprochen,
haben sehen wir doch hier im Recht wieso haben Sie da was dagegen und sie beschädigen Deutschlands Ansehen in der Welt und da muss man sagen Zum Glück stimmt das nicht alle Welt guckt erschrocken.
Frankreich österreich alle Länder die das Problem eben auch haben.
Der Schweizer der österreichische Korrespondent der ZEIT hat in seinem Podcast erzählt Wir gucken nach Deutschland und ehrlich gesagt Wir finden es auch ein bisschen lustig denn die deutsche überheblichkeit beim Blick nach österreich Frankreich Schweiz SVP,
wurde jetzt hier ein bisschen eingefangen Ihr seid auch nicht davor gewarnt dass so etwas passiert.
Da muss man sagen Ja warum nicht auch.
Es führt jetzt auch ein bisschen ehrlichere Debatte unter anderem bei Annalena Bernburg die ja gestern heute am Montag gestern bei Anne Will und hat dann nochmal gesagt Es war die Zivilgesellschaft die dieses Problem überhaupt erst einmal markiert hat.
Sechs Stunden später kam dann Söder und noch eine Stunde später kam dann,
der CDU-Generalsekretär aber es war zuallererst mal eine Reaktion der Zivilgesellschaft nehme in Berlin vor die FDP-Zentrale zu gehen und in Erfurt auf die Straße gehen und sagen Wir haben es erkannt was hier passiert ist dass es nicht einfach nur,
im Sinne einer Stadtratswahl in,
roten Stein oder so.
Da wäre das einfach durchgegangen. Da gäbe es keine mediale öffentlichkeit.
Auch Unionsleute die man gleich gratuliert haben Doro Bär hat ja auch dann mal schnell getwittert.
Z.B diese Tweets zurückgenommen und sich auch dafür entschuldigt. Das war ein Fehler.
Aber es gab da sehr viele die das einfach mitgespielt haben.
Man kann ja heute sagen Die FDP hat ein Experiment versucht und bei manchen hat es tatsächlich funktioniert.
Bei anderen dann nicht. Die anderen waren vor allem Zivilgesellschaft bis die parlamentarischen Kräfte wenn auch stark spät kam hat sie eine Weile gedauert.
Christoph Matschie war in der Aussprache noch ein besonderer Typ weil er in Thüringen die SPD geführt hat lange also als ich noch Thüringen gelebt hat war er immer der Ministerpräsident ein Kandidat kam aber damals schon vor 15 20 Jahren immer nur auf,
14 Prozent mal 13 also die SPD war da immer abgeschlagen.
Und während er redet gabs ein Zwischenruf den wir nicht hören von der AfD auf den er aber reagiert und dann verstehen wir auch was die AfD da wieder rein gerufen hat.
Diese Partei hat aus der Geschichte nichts gelernt und darf deshalb nicht Bestandteil des demokratischen Konsenses werden.
Die Wähler werden das am Ende auch entscheiden da bin ich sicher.
So ja die Wähler werden das entscheiden da bin ich am Ende sicher.
Er hat also den Zwischenruf bekommen lassen sie doch den Wähler entscheiden lassen sie doch die Demokratie als Mathematik gewähren dann hören Sie auf mit ihrem inhaltlichen und so weiter und so fort.
So jetzt kann man sich ja die Frage stellen. Februar 2020 Was wäre wenn die AfD recht hat.
Was wäre wenn sich die ACA hingestellt hätte und gesagt hätte nach meiner Rechnung gabs da 45 Stimmen für Cameron.
Das ist die Mehrheit in diesem dritten Wahlgang hat keiner gewonnen Ich gratuliere ihm herzlich.
Wenn die SPD und die Grünen jetzt wirklich glauben hier protestieren zu müssen 2001 eine Bundestagswahl bitte etwas Geduld der Wähler wird dann schon entscheiden.
Hätte ja durchaus sein können. Wer sagt uns wie weit sind wir von diesem Szenario weg.
Die CDU ist jetzt in Bedrängnis sie könnte genauso zerbröseln wie die SPD und sagen wir jetzt eine Neuwahl machen liegt ein Drittel unserer Fraktion raus.
Also retten wir uns lieber ins nächste Jahr und sagen jetzt hier es ist halt wie es ist.
Es ist ja kein FDP-Kandidat. Das wäre noch so ein Argument das man bringt. Wenn ich die AfD gewählt uns gewählt. Die Wahl war geheim wir halten uns hier raus.
Unter diesem Eindruck von Thüringen kann man erkennen wie erschreckend das ist was in Amerika tatsächlich vorgefallen ist.
Wir hören jetzt mal die abschloß Statement Worte von Trumps Anwalt im Senat Er steht wirklich an institutionell höchster Stelle,
als privater Anwalt des Präsidenten im Senat ist gar kein Senator und so weiter wo man denkt ein bisschen Ehrfurcht wäre doch angebracht und er redet ja zu den Senatoren die verpflichtet sind ihm zuzuhören die dürfen nicht reden Die müssen da sitzen die sind so als die verwandelt in dem Moment hinter ihm,
hinter dem Anwalt jetzt spricht sitzt noch der höchste Richter Amerikas und leitet die Sitzung.
Und es ist unglaublich was als Argumentation dort durchgehen.
Testa.
Failed States.
So die Verteidigungsstrategie von Trump war Wir sind die echten Demokraten.
Wir lassen nämlich den Wähler entscheiden und wenn sie Senatoren die sich anmaßen Trump des Amtes zu entheben dann vergehen sie sich an der Gründungsidee des Staates,
und sie greifen hier illegitim in eine Wahl ein.
Das kann man sich eigentlich nicht vorstellen dass das tatsächlich die abschloß Argumentation in Amerika war.
Aber man sieht hier wie schwach ein demokratisches System an sich ist wenn man es so interpretiert und es gibt ja sehr verschiedene Auffassungen von Demokratie.
Wenn man in dieser Logik bleibt. Absolut richtig ist Logik muss man sagen.
Wir müssen aber auch daran erinnern dass Hitler gewählt wurde.
Er ist entsprechend demokratisch getragen worden.
Für Ernst Jünger nach 45 ganz klar war das was da geschehen war mit Hitler nie mehr Demokratie.
Das war so eine Idee von Ernst Jünger. Das war ja quasi eine Art der Demokratie und der Demokratie sehr skeptisch gegenüber eingestellt.
Die Frage ist Demokratie.
Ist eine demokratische Wahl eine demokratische Wahl.
Wenn jemand die meisten Stimmen hat oder die Idee so etwas wie die volonté,
ist ja nicht unbedingt darauf ausgelegt dass man Befragungen macht das kann auch anders interpretiert werden kann er beispielsweise auch von wenigen oder nur von einem vertreten werden.
Es gibt auch positive Beispiele von Charles de Gaulle in der Résistance. Er sagte Ich bin das wahre Frankreich.
Das sind ganz heikle Fragen und wir sehen hier ganz klar dass die parlamentarische Demokratie und darum geht es ja hier sehr sehr schwach und auch nur,
gut funktioniert wenn es ein Grundverständnis oder eine Einverständnis gibt wie das hier läuft.
Ist zwar gewisse Gegnerschaft innerhalb des Parlaments gibt aber,
eine Gegnerschaft im Parlament sitzt die eigentlich gegen diese Art des Parlamentarismus ist dann wird es sehr sehr gefährlich für alle anderen die dort sind und die müssen ja auch strategisch weil.
Konservative Werte und so auch gesprochen wird.
Eigentlich ist es strategisch geboten einen größtmöglichen Abstand zur AfD zu halten weil die nicht,
darauf ausgelegt ist irgendwann einmal eine friedliche Koalition mit FDP oder CDU zu machen.
Junior oder Senior Position sondern das langfristige Ziel der AfD bzw.
Dieses völkischen Flügels ist selbstverständlich nicht innerhalb dieser parlamentarischen Demokratie.
Deswegen ist es einfach strategisch geboten Abstand davon zu halten.
Denn sonst kommt man eben in solche Argumentationen auch irgendwann rein und kann sich dann immer auf die Wähler berufen.
Im Fall von Thüringen ganz verrückt ist wenn man jetzt sieht wie das Ganze gelaufen ist man als Ministerpräsidenten.
Wenn du die volonté générale reinbringt aber eben nicht als mathematisches Konzept sondern nur die Frage wer interpretierten eigentlich den Volkswillen so wie generiere den eigentlich Wir sehen dann Annalena Bernburg die eben das Eingeständnis macht.
Das Parlament hat hier versagt und wir sehen aber eine Zivilgesellschaft also Volkes Wille sozusagen.
Dann ist sie im Grunde gar nicht so weit weg von seinem Anwalt wie von Trump sagt das Parlament versagt hier dem kann man die Aufgabe gar nicht zutrauen,
denn wir wissen hier es Freunde und Feinde des Präsidenten und wenn man die durchzählen wissen wir ja das geht halt entlang der Parteilinien belassen mal das Volk entscheiden.
Das ist eigentlich erschreckend das Annalena Bernburg in einer Pro Argumentation,
Anti Parlamentarismus argumentiert und sagt Es gibt einen Volkswillen und nach dem sollte sich der Thüringer Landtag mal richten unabhängig davon welche Mehrheitsverhältnisse dort eigentlich gerade,
wirklich ausgezählt wurden sie ist ja nicht nur eine Meinungsumfrage gewesen sondern mehr als 45 Stimmen anderen mit dem Eindruck 10000 Demonstranten in einem 80 Millionen Volk.
Das sollten wir mal registrieren und beachten Das kann sie nur machen weil das in ihrem Sinne war. Inhaltlich.
Wenn da 10000 Nazis demonstriert hätten und gesagt hätten Kameralinse unser König dann hätte sie nicht gesagt die Zivilgesellschaft und Beatbox beruft sich auf die Zivilgesellschaft wie auch Trumps Anwalt.
Wie schön die Zivilgesellschaft auf der Straße.
Zivilgesellschaft.
Da wird es wirklich gefährlich wenn man sich mal überlegt in welche Richtung das so geht. Würde gefährlich werden.
Gefährlich wird würde gefährlich werden. In der üblichen deutschen Talkshow zu reden das würde gar nicht begriffen werden.
Wir sind eigentlich ganz großen Fragen angekommen.
Eben dieser Interpretation von Demokratie von Mehrheiten von Zivilgesellschaft.
Und wir sehen eigentlich dass im politischen Raum eigentlich ein permanenter Kampf herrscht der auch polemisch geführt wird.
Denn auch wenn wir das erst einmal gut finden und die Zivilgesellschaft auf der Straße haben sich versammelt.
CDU und FDP zentrale müssen wir sagen ist das eine polemische Argumentation denn du weißt zu Recht darauf hin.
80 Millionen sind zu Hause geblieben haben nicht demonstriert.
Könnten schon morgen anders demonstrieren.
Vielleicht hatten 38 Millionen auch gar kein Problem damit oder so.
Das ist sehr schön hier zu sehen und wenn man sich dessen gewahr wird dann muss man sagen so funktioniert das nicht komplett gleichgeschaltet sind. Aber wir haben.
Wenn man sich.
Dann.
Ein sehr sehr aufregendes Verhältnis zur Demokratie das auch von den entsprechenden Leuten so interpretiert wird wie alle politischen Begriffe sind polemische.
Ganz genau gleich übertrieben. Romney ist ja eine der interessanten Figuren weil er eben gesagt hat Ich gehöre zwar zu den Republikanern aber in Sachen Amtsmissbrauch dem ersten Artikel für den Trump der angeklagt wurde.
Da spreche ich ihn schuldig.
War natürlich so eine Sache bei der klar ist da muss er sich rechtfertigen das kann er nicht einfach so machen kann er nicht einfach der einreichten im Senat und sagen Ich gebe meine Stimme ab sondern das ist Erklärung,
bedürftig und er hat es interessanterweise bei Fox News erklärt hier bei Chris Wallace der ihm aufgeschlossen ist.
Es gibt Fox News und dann gibts einen Fox News der immer mal nochdie ein bisschen Vernunft walten lässt er hat Romney besucht und Romney rechtfertigt hier mal warum er trotz der Argumentation des Anwalts gegen Trump entscheidet.
Donald Trump Re Americans schon in den neuen Manes Carla seine,
Pippo erhielt er.
An der Kasse zwischen der Kasse erst drei,
Sempé Ballhaus des Bäckers Instinkt dienstags das aus Paulis wurde Termine Gürtel wenigstens eine Nacht.
Er sei schäkert.
Er spielt den Ball zurück. Das Volk droht anhand von Gefällt mir Gefällt mir nicht mag ich im Fernsehen mag ich nicht.
Ich bewundere ich nicht bin ich fürchte ich oder so. Und es sind die Profis im Senat die aufgrund von Verfassungstext,
sagen müssen was Sache ist dass der Senat mittlerweile so loyal ist das ist eben eine andere Geschichte.
Ob er so loyal ist zeigt sich ja gerade.
Beispielsweise hat man ja die Befugnisse die militärischen Befugnisse in Sachen Iran jetzt erst mal eingeschränkt auch mit republikanischen Stimmen weil man gesehen hat wenn die Leute weg drohen.
Aber diese Idee von Romney hier nochmal den Senat als zwischen dem Monarchen und man hat sich damals gegen die Krone entschieden aber nicht gegen die Idee von Herrschaft im Sinne von,
der amerikanische Präsident hat,
sofort gleichrangig oder mehr Rechte bekommen als der britische König dem man damals ging dem man sich gestellt hat.
Oberster Befehlshaber hat ganz viele um das Präsidentenamt kann ja wie Dick Cheney ja immer gerne formulierte ganz anders noch ausgeweitet werden.
War damals auch nicht Amtszeit befristet Beispiel. Man sagt eigentlich finden wir so ein Herrscher schon cool aber soll ja nicht der sein sondern unser eigener.
Eigentlich ja nicht unser eigener.
Und dann gibt's auf der anderen Seite den Pöbel und dazwischen gab es aber aus Gründen einen Senat.
Gab es aber auch daran erinnert Verantwortung.
Und daran hat Romney nochmal erinnert Es gibt eine spezifische Verantwortung und der werde ich hier gerecht ich.
Gerecht was auch eine traurige Aussage ist der wir aber auch sicherlich nicht widersprechen können.
Das so komplexe Verfahrens Dinge nicht zur Abstimmung gebracht werden können im Volk also beispielsweise dürfte jetzt das Volk Beim Impeachment Verfahren entscheiden.
Beispielsweise durfte jetzt bei mir entscheiden dann kann man das ja.
Dann kann man davon ausgehen dass die die da abstimmen zu 90 Prozent vielleicht zu 95 Prozent überhaupt nicht wissen worum es da eigentlich geht.
Sehen. Es geht um die Person dann mag man sie wieder mal Martinek Man kauft das Kino Ticket um nie zu sehen oder nicht.
Es ist eine ganz einfache Entscheidung eigentlich rein nach Werturteilen in dem Fall.
Und deswegen erinnern wir nochmal und es ist wirklich interessant und man kann es übersehen wenn man einfach nur auf YouTube so ein bisschen herumschlägt aber die Eröffnung dieses Verfahrens in dem Verlies schon am 18. 12.
Im Repräsentantenhaus in dem Falle hat Nancy Pelosi nochmal an den Amtseid erinnert.
Und während sie ihn in ihre Rede einbaut hat sie ihn gleich noch einmal abgelegt. Wirkt so ein bisschen.
Diskutieren über das Fundament. Und wenn dieses Fundament missachtet wird dann löst sich eigentlich alles auf. Weil sie uns hier sagen.
Mit mit der amerikanischen Unabhängigkeit kam der Präsident also ein Herrscher aus dem eigenen Volk,
und nicht entsandt über sozusagen auf der anderen Seite des Universums indem er einfach über den Ozean geschippert und eine Verfassung.
Der Präsident kam nicht alleine es kam nicht allein. Nur ein Herrscher einen amerikanischen sonderndie hat noch eine Verfassung mitgegeben gekriegt die gleichzeitig das eine oder andere Verfahren regelt beispielsweise wie man ihn wählt und abwählen.
Es ist ja alles von Anfang an reingeschrieben und Mitt Romney erklärt nochmal warum er.
Ja stimmt bei Trump hat sein Amt missbraucht. Aber bei dem zweiten Obstruktion auf Kongress also bei der Einmischung in die Verfahren des Kongresses warum man da,
nicht mitgestimmt hat mit den Demokraten sondern sagt Nee da bleibe ich jetzt beim Text Verfassung Das sehe ich dann anders.
Das von der New York Times da besucht deswegen spricht ein bisschen drauf. Eigentlich schade dass Romney so sprechen lässt aber man hört nochmal deutlich.
Romney sagt bei dem zweiten Fall haben die Demokraten im Kongress obwohl sie die Mehrheit hatten die Hoheit über das Verfahren den Rechtsweg nicht ausgenutzt haben also die Möglichkeiten die Verfassung bietet nicht genutzt.
Es ist selten so eine kongruent Argumentation in zwei Entscheidungen.
Eigentlich gehört von der Person die sagt hört mir zu Wir haben ja eine Verfassung.
Der Präsident muss sich dran halten der Kongress aber auch und wenn da mehr Möglichkeiten drin stehen als genutzt werden dann ist das ein Fehler im Verfahren der Demokraten da können Sie jetzt nicht einfach mich fragen ob ich da irgendwie dem Präsidenten ans Bein pinkeln.
Aber der Präsident muss sich eben auch an die Verfassung halten und wenn er seine Grenzen überschreitet dann sage ich Es sind einfach Grenzen der Verfassung.
Es ist eine sehr konsistente selten so konsistente Argumentation gehört in diesem schwierigen Fall ja wirklich auch ein bisschen beeindruckend.
Wir wissen ja unter welchem Druck er steht das haben wir auch gleich nochmal.
Denn jetzt ist nämlich die Frage Nancy Pelosi hat nicht nur erinnert an die Verfassung sondern auch noch einmal und das hat sie dann zur Eröffnung gemacht dieses Verfahrens.
Sie erinnert nochmal an diesen Gründungs Moment. Worin liegt eigentlich die Leistung überhaupt diese Unabhängigkeit damals so erklärt zu haben zu sagen Wir bleiben bei diesem Herrschafts Modell.
Der Staat wird hierarchisch geordnet in der Verwaltung und oben steht ein König aber.
Trotzdem bekommt er eine Verfassung mit.
We can,
Kiepert.
Fayence.
Da kann man natürlich ganz normativ hören. Sie ist erregt sie findet das blöd wieder abläuft aber sie macht doch mal dieses Argument.
Was unterscheidet Monarchie und Republik.
Franklin Benjamin Franklin kommt da raus aus der Unterschriften Zeremonie der Verfassungsgeber.
Dann steht das Volk kann man es fast bildlich vorstellen wie sie das so meint. Da steht das Volk vor der Tür gefragt Was ist jetzt entschieden.
Wir sind eine Republik keine Monarchie aber trotzdem Monarchen an der Spitze wie passt das zusammen. Eine Monarchie kommt immer mit Dynastie einher.
Also wir trennen jetzt Amt und Amtsträger das ist eigentlich diese Errungenschaft auf die sie hier auch deutlicher machen können aber das steckt in dieser Unterscheidung.
Gewaltenteilung.
Das wird dann auch so Andeutung machen dass der Präsident die.
Den chinesischen Präsidenten,
dass er,
es geschafft hat.
Es geschafft hat dass er es geschafft hat ähnlich.
Dann ist der nächste Schritt her dass man überlegt ob man noch beerben kann dann ist man wieder bei der Dynastie wird mal wieder unrecht.
Ist der nächste Schritt dass man überlegt ob man,
der Dynastie einer modernen Monarchie alte Familientradition beruft sondern.
Etwas was man.
Losläßt.
Trump wissen wir ja. Er hat zwei Fetische in der Besetzung Militär Familie.
Geht es zurück die am Anfang begleitet hat als Kommunikations chefin oder Mitarbeiterin von der er ja auch als Tochter spricht.
Es ist total verrückt eigentlich die Rekrutierung Mechanismen so ablaufen.
Mitt Romney hatte hier zum Thema Monarchie zur Trennung Person und Amt sich noch geäußert.
Merkel die auch begeistert Woher kam das Fernweh.
Für mich war es schon mal,
Grandke als Ballast Hans,
W.
Substantieller sein. Dann ist.
Und da muss man doch mal drüber nachdenken denn diese Trennung von Amt und Amtsträger die Trump aufheben möchte für sich weil er gerade in einer Position ist wo es für ihn lohnt.
Die gilt nun auch nicht mehr für Mitt Romney denn er ist nicht als Amtsträger da rein marschiert im Senat hat gesagt Ich stimme gegen den Präsidenten.
Plötzlich war das eine persönliche Angelegenheit und seine ganze Familie inklusive aller 24 Enkel und Enkelinnen die er hat sieht er jetzt plötzlich in der Gefahr da Inkonsequenz zu stehen.
Mit denen jetzt übel mitgespielt wird und da muss ich sagen Ich bin jetzt auf allen Ebenen so Sippenhaft und didaktisches denken wieder einzieht und er hier so eine Angst formuliert.
Dann ist es auch wirklich braucht so ein bisschen in Amerika hört man jedenfalls echt nicht gerne.
Trumps Anwalt Er hat ja mehrere gehabt. Ein bekannter als der Abschlussnote wir gerade gehört haben ist Alan Dershowitz renommierter Harvard Anwalt und so weiter.
Und der geht ja jetzt in Trennung von Amt und Mandat von Amt und Person.
Da kann er gar nichts abgewinnen Diese Argumentation hier im,
an der gleichen Stelle wie der andere Anwalt von einem im Senat während ihm die Senatoren zuhören müssen und hinter ihm der oberste Richter Amerikas sitzt das ist wirklich erschreckend.
Ein.
Impeachment.
Give me.
So
Wenn also der Präsident etwas tut bei dem er glaubt das hilft mir dass ich gewählt werde.
Genau das werde,
ist das kein persönliches Anliegen sondern ein Anliegen das an das Amt geknüpft ist.
Es ist ja im nationalen Interesse dass ich Präsident bleibe und hier wurde die Linie einfach überschritten. Das ist monarchische denken.
Das hat mit Republik nichts zu tun.
Diesen Anspruch könnte ja auch jeder Kandidat formulieren. Und dann ist man ja wirklich in Bedrängnis wenn man sich schon im nationalen Interesse zum Präsidenten ausrufen kann bevor man gewählt ist.
Also ein Anspruch auf das Amt formuliert nur aufgrund der eigenen Person oder des Vorhabens der Wünsche der eigenen privaten Wünsche.
Dann passt das nicht zusammen. Das kriegt man gar nicht hin gebogen das ist sozusagen Argumentation unter einem ganz bestimmten in einer ganz schlimmen Situation nämlich wissend,
dass man eigentlich inhaltlich diesen Fall verloren hat und trotzdem noch irgendwie argumentieren muss weil man weiß Egal was wir hier vorschlagen. Wir haben eine Mehrheit auf unserer Seite.
Man lässt die Katze in den Schwanz beißen indem man sagt ja dann,
ist das ja auch richtig gewesen. Das ist eine Argumentation die findet man in einem Stück.
Wir sind jetzt angekommen und dort gibt es einen Machthaber der an die Macht kommt durch Kriminalität räumt da jemanden aus dem Weg und so weiter.
Und dann gibt's aber die Argumentation die Verbrechen die der Krone gelten verzeiht der Himmel wenn sie gelingen.
Wir haben hier eine übertragung. Wenn der Wähler einen dann wählt,
dann ist auch das andere absolut in Ordnung. Denn dann hat man ja,
als Herrscher getan und nicht in irgendeiner Weise noch als Privatperson oder so.
Denn dann ist alles vermischt sich hier und hier wird eigentlich dieses monarchistische Paradigma auf die Demokratie übertragen und damit wird die Demokratie unterminiert. Das ist,
exakt so in der frühen Neuzeit findet.
Die ganze Idee von Calvinismus im Sinne von Wir sind auserwählt. Gott wollte das so.
Es ist halt wie es ist. Wir brauchen erst gar nicht überlegen ob er dagegen argumentiert.
Die Welt wurde hergestellt und das begegnet einem ja immer wieder.
So eine Art neo Calvinismus gerade in der westlichen Welt.
Uns geht's gut wir können gar nicht die schlechten sein. Sonst hätte uns Gott noch bestraft wenn wir im Luxus leben sind wir die Guten Uns geht's gut wir sind die Guten.
Und das schlägt sich hier wieder so nieder und das Stück was du jetzt nannte ist dieser Calvinismus im Rahmen seiner Zeit kann man das immer erklären da macht diese Argumentation voll Sinn,
wenn wir einen Staat haben der nicht säkular ist sondern einfach sich auf so eine sakral Herrschaft beruht dann ist halt der Kopf des.
Herrschers über dem Band also im Himmel und nur der Körper hat die weltlichen Bezüge.
Aber wir sind 2020 so eine Argumentation zu erinnern ist völlig absurd.
Und es gelingt eben nur wenn man vorher die Demokratie runter dampft auf reine Mehrheits Mathematik und dann sagt Ich habe eine Mehrheit egal was ich jetzt sage ich muss nur irgendwie die Zeit totschlagen,
weil die Demokraten meinten es geht ja 30 Stunden zu argumentieren und dann kommt halt so was bei rum,
und Adam Schiff und das ist wirklich erschreckend.
Sozusagen der Gegenrede also der mandatiert die Gegenstimme sozusagen allerdings nicht auf privater Rechnung schreibt eine Rechnung an den Präsidenten sondern er kommt eben als Mehrheitsführer oder.
Der Mehrheitsführer im Repräsentantenhaus der Chef von den Demokraten und er sitzt dann steht eben an gleicher Stelle und argumentiert dagegen Er geht jetzt direkt auf den Dershowitz und argumentiert Das ist wie schon alle anderen Kleb Ja es ist einfach erschreckend.
Den Beginn der Fans.
Hey Watch.
Me
If
You Make.
Me.
Diese Argumentation hat niemand danach widersprochen. Schiff sagt ihr macht das doch hier nur wissend dass DRAM schuldig ist deswegen wollte er keine Zeugen hören und das Verfahren schnell rumkriegen ihr wisst dass er schuldig ist.
Erstaunlicherweise sind danach republikanische Senatoren ins Fernsehen gegangen und haben gesagt Wozu zeugen.
Wir wissen doch was der Fall ist. Wir finden halt nicht dass das machbar ist. Es reicht nicht aus aber den Sachverhalt bestreiten wir gar nicht.
Das ist wirklich erschreckend war ja auch nochmal. Es geht ja im Grunde um dieses quid pro quo darf Trump an einer Entscheidung.
Des Kongresses nämlich der Ukraine 400 Millionen Dollar zu bezahlen damit sie sich gegen Russland wehren darf er diese Entscheidung widersprechen und das Geld eben erst freigeben wenn quid pro quo dafür die Gegenleistung bekommt.
Wahlkampf Unterstützung ist ein persönliches Anliegen.
Und jetzt hat er dem Chef dieses Mal eingebracht. Und das eigentliche quid pro quo.
Was hier drin steckt ist ihr haut mich jetzt hier raus im Wahlkampfjahr.
Also vier Senatoren der Republikanischen Partei dafür unterstütze ich euch in euren Wahlkämpfen die ja auch anstehen.
Zur selben Zeit und wir versuchen im Senat die Mehrheit zu halten und im Repräsentantenhaus die Mehrheit wiederzuerlangen.
Das kann man mittlerweile auch nachlesen bei Axiomen und so. Aber das ganz gut dokumentiert wie die versprächen mittlerweile laufen wie Trumps Wahlkampf Kalender aussieht. Das einzige Problem was sie noch haben ist.
Die Republikaner brauchen in manchen Orten Unterstützung wo es keine großen Stadien gibt weshalb Trump Sie wissen noch nicht genau wie sie Trump dazu überreden auch dort Stopp zu machen wo er nicht vor 20 000 Leuten gleichzeitig sprechen kann weil er möchte nicht in diese kleinen Hallen.
Das ist das Anliegen der Demokraten da irgendwie Theater zu machen Wahlkampf aber das ist das eigentliche quid pro quo Wir hauen dich jetzt hier raus in der Angelegenheit dafür hilfst du es bei unseren Wahlkämpfen so dass hier für alle einfach die Mathematik aufgeht und wir unsere Mehrheiten erhalten.
Das ist entsprechend und hart ist wieder wenn man dann Mitt Romney hört der hier nochmal das.
Eigentlich zur Debatte stehende Amtsmissbrauchs Amtsmissbrauchs Angelegenheit thematisiert denn ist es jetzt einfach nicht im Picabia also ist es eine Sache bei der man sagen kann Ja kam vor aber reicht nicht um den,
Präsidenten des Amtes zu entheben oder kann man nicht auf der anderen Seite des Spektrums argumentieren.
Gregors.
Dieser Amtsmissbrauch den man da gesehen hat Das ist nun mal das Schlimmste der schlimmste Verfassungsbruch.
Das ist nicht irgendeiner oder so. Sondern es ist der schlimmste Verfassungsbruch. Die Verfassung war eigentlich nur da um die Macht des Präsidenten zu organisieren und es eben nicht monarchisch zu machen.
Und genau dem genau diese Fähigkeit der Verfassung hat er widersprochen und sein Amt missbraucht. Seine Amtszeit missbraucht um die Verfassung zu beschneiden.
Es ist eben nicht einfach nur irgendwo muss man aber nicht beachten dass ist eigentlich das Verfahren allererster Güte gelten jetzt gar keine Gesetze mehr gilt und das ist jetzt auch wieder erschreckend. Ich habe mal reingehört in diesen neuen Podcast von Steve Bananen.
Der hat nämlich den Warnruf eröffnet.
Das ist ein absurder rechtslastige wirklich gruseliger Podcast.
Alle drei Tage zusammensitzen und meinen Crooner werden wir alle betrogen und habt alle Angst und hier das typische republikanische Programm.
Und sie kam hier nochmal auf diese Geste von Pelosi darf man die State of the Union als Manuskript im Senat zerreißen.
Und jetzt haben wir ja schon gelernt. Die meinen für Präsident Trump gelten gar keine Regeln keine Gesetze nichts für Pelosi.
Nancy Pelosi heißt.
Speak Cyber-Abwehrzentrum Bayreuths.
Bringt selbst einen Satz in Sotschi,
reziproke.
Also für Pelosi gilt plötzlich die Hausordnung während für Trump nicht mal die Verfassung gelten muss sich Pelosi doch bitte an die Hausordnung halten darf da nicht irgendwie unerotisch über das Gremium.
Doppelstandards in der Argumentation haben wir ja.
Generell gerne mit Doppelstandards.
Gegen den Bundestagspräsidenten.
Worüber hier eigentlich diskutiert wird.
Bei Facebook zu Hause die.
Demokratie mit Füßen getreten wird in Thüringen zeigt sich ja dadurch dass man einen Blumenstrauß.
Deswegen.
Muss man sehr vorsichtig sein ich halte den Blumenstrauß für sehr sehr richtig und gut als Symbol.
Was für eine Demokratie.
Na ja ich bin für Leute wie Steve Benson.
Die finden sowas gut weil die daran entzündet sich der Streit der Kalbsschnitzel Bürgerkrieg.
Klar man braucht halt die Feinde und da werden sie markiert das ist groß im Fernsehen.
Warum nicht. So tragen wir es jetzt aus und am Ende machen wir mal die Mehrheiten durch und dann rufen wir den Präsidenten aus und die andere Seite wird ihn hassen und das wissen wir auch und das ist ja alles mittlerweile erwartbar wie es abläuft.
Trump jedenfalls hat eine große Zeremonie veranstaltet. Er wusste selber nicht genau was mache ich eigentlich gerade Ich stehe im Weißen Haus vor mir sitzen meine Leute und ich rede einfach mal Stunde.
Es ist keine Pressekonferenz ist auch keine Rede. Es ist einfach irgendwas explizit gesagt er weiß nicht genau was er gerade macht.
Aber er hatte eben das eine oder andere zu zeigen und deswegen und das ist jetzt für uns besonders interessant denn Redaktionsschluss und Rentner. Jetzt fällt alles zusammen.
Und die Argumentation von eben. Und wir gucken uns und erklären danach mal was wir hier sehen.
Erhält jetzt ausgerechnet die Washington Post mit Trump quittiert Trump freigesprochen und zeigt sich stolz rum. Das ist jetzt sein,
Leben Blumenstrauss und Manuskript.
Bla blablabla. Recht Verfassung irgendwas. Das ist eine politische Angelegenheit was hier passiert ist. Und dann muss man eben auch nochmal Macchia.
Trump hat Mark Zuckerberg innerhalb der dreieinhalb Jahre die jetzt im Amt ist zum reichsten Menschen der Welt gemacht Facebook ist im Börsenwert hat sich mehr als verdoppelt.
Seit der Amtseinführung von Trump und wir wissen jetzt schon mit Mike Bloomberg der jetzt schon 400 Millionen investiert hat und Trump der jetzt zugestanden hat lieber Senatoren lieber Republikaner ich bezahl euch hier eure Wahlkämpfe,
euch da fließt jetzt unglaublich viel Geld.
Das ganze Geld etwas früher ins Fernsehen ging und das Fernsehen am Leben gehalten hat das fließt jetzt ins Internet und gleichzeitig steht dieser Trump da und hält eine Zeitung hoch um nochmal zu zeigen und eure Gesellschaft regiere ich damit.
Ich bin der König von Facebook Ich bin König durch Facebook. So müsste man.
Und selbst die investigative Washington Post muss jetzt so eine Schlagzeile produzieren.
Ja noch auf Basars gehört und da kommt alles zusammen.
Genau das war für ihn besser als jede Medaille die man ihm Olympiasieger umhängen kann. Die Washington Post.
Und er macht es gerade in diesem improvisierten wieder erstaunlich gut Performances.
So wie man es aus den großen hollywood blockbustern kennt so macht er seine Art zu sprechen zu gestikulieren Er ist eine Figur die man sofort reinsetzen könnte in entsprechende Blockbuster.
Auch das alte Amerika das sieht man hier nicht nur an der Washington Post dass das für ihn jetzt noch einmal für seine Generation wichtig ist dass er dort mal was Gutes,
hat die jungen Leute die ihn unterstützen die nur noch bei Facebook oder Instagram oder sonst wo haben überhaupt keinen Bezug mehr zur Washington Post.
Das macht er auch noch nochmal für ältere Wähler und das macht er selbstverständlich auch für die Klientel die eigentlich die Washington Post rezipiert mit,
dieser Zeitung kann er noch mal eine Ohrfeige verpassen,
sehr sehr sehr klug gewählt.
Er hat dann noch mehrere Zeitungen dabeigehabt. Aber die Washington Post hat er gleich als allererstes und dann im Anschluss ja keine juristische Angelegenheit Wir haben hier wir sind durch die Hölle gegangen es ist aufgegangen unser Plan.
Und hier.
Haben wir auch nochmal einen Bezug zu Carl Schmitt Carl Schmitt Podcast.
Ich vermute aber dass wir uns gerade in Zeiten wo man mit diesen,
Ideen sehr gut die Gegenwart erklären kann und was wir hier gerade erleben indem er sagt Das hat nichts mit Recht zu tun oder Verfassung das ist Politik.
Es gibt von Carl Schmitt und das ist der schlimmste Text von Carl Schmitt ein Text nach dem Putsch von Hitler 33 schreibt,
Der Führer schützt das Recht der Führer steht über dem Recht und er weiß am Ende zu entscheiden er ist der politische in die Tat umsetzt und fragt sich nicht mehr was das Parlament davon hält oder was die Gerichte dazu sagen.
Eine solche Argumentation an den Tag gelegt.
Entsprechend hat sich auch die New York Times auf ihrer Seite noch einmal gefragt.
Im Falle Jamel Buy fand ich einen sehr guten Text mit der überschrift Wir werden daran erinnert dass sich Geschichte nicht immer nur vorwärts bewegt.
Man kann natürlich den technischen Fortschritt irgendwie nehmen oder auch die Fortentwicklung rechts Fortbildung durch Amerikaner.
Aber diese politische Geschichte die Frage Wie legitimieren wir.
Da geht es nicht immer nur vorwärts sondern da hat ja Obama damals auch gesagt drei Schritte nach vorne ein Schritt zurück Man kommt im großen Ganzen und im Klein-Klein,
nicht vorwärts wie man es aus anderen modernen Entwicklungen kennt und das ist eben auch nochmal ein Brückenschlag zu einem sehr wichtigen Romney Zitat,
Romney saß also hier mit der New York Times zusammen zurückgezogen keine Kamera auf ihn gerichtet nur das Mikrofon und er erklärt hier noch mal wie er sich gegenüber rechtfertigt Verfassung,
Verfassungstext alleine das kann irgendwie nicht reichen da muss noch mehr dazukommen.
Bevor.
Justus.
Der Amtseid in Amerika wie auch in Deutschland ist ein besonderer denn er ist zweischneidig Man beruft sich auf die Verfassung und schwört sie hochzuhalten und zu verteidigen und so weiter.
Und wenn man möchte Amerika ist es nicht ganz so freiwillig kann man Gottes Hilfe dazu ziehen.
Schröder hat.
Der erste CDUler machen es immer alle auch wenn ich als Minister vereidigt werden immer Das ist Pflichtprogramm.
Die Grünen natürlich mehrheitlich nicht bei der SPD. Halbe halbe oder so.
Aber dieser Amtseid der auch 2020 immer noch so wichtig ist kommt ohne diesen Gottesbezug nicht aus.
Also klar säkularer Staat muss sich muss seine Souveränität anders rechtfertigen anders legitimieren.
Aber am Ende haben wir es mit Gewissensfragen zu tun so steht es in der Verfassung und diese Gewissensfragen sind Glaubensfragen und Glaubensfragen sind nun mal religiöse Sachen Man kann den Glauben auch aus anderen Sachen schöpfen.
Aber es ist Man kommt nicht drum rum.
Da kann man eben diesen Bogen schlagen. Emmerich.
Ich lese nun die Artikel 71 der Verfassung des Freistaats Thüringen vorgeschriebener Eidesformel und bitte Sie diese Eidesformel zu sprechen.
Sie können den Eid anschließen mit den Worten So wahr mir Gott helfe bekräftigen,
die Eidesformel lautet Ich schwöre ich schwöre dass ich meine Kraft dem Wohle des Volkes widmen werde ich meine Kraft dem Wohle des Volkes widmen.
Verfassung und Gesetze waren Verfassungen und Gesetze waren,
meine Pflichten gewissenhaft erfüllen meine Pflichten gewissenhaft erfüllen und Gerechtigkeit gegen jedermann üben werde und Gerechtigkeit gegen jedermann üben werde. So wahr mir Gott helfe.
Er hat diesen religiösen Bezug nochmal. Man hört ganz deutlich Sie sagt auch am Anfang.
Ich sage es nicht vor wenn sie sich auf Gott berufen wollen müssen sie selber machen es dann ihre private Angelegenheit.
Eine Bekräftigung dass es nicht notwendig ist.
Es ist nur eine Bekräftigung genau in der Verfassung steht es nicht drin.
Sie können aber wenn sie wollen wir räumen ihnen hier diese Gelegenheit ein und das was gemacht hat kann man natürlich als na ja gut. Man muss sich halt entscheiden macht es oder macht es nicht.
Das was gemacht hat gut machen das nicht. Heute wissen wir Der liebe Herrgott hat ihm nicht geholfen.
Aber auch in diesem ganzen Kontext. Bei Romney,
muss man sagen Da muss man es echt ernst nehmen so er als Mormone und so weiter kommt da aus Utah und auch diese ganze Idee große Familien zu gründen das funktioniert dann wahrscheinlich auch nur wenn man dann wirklich Gottes Beistand und so weiter da irgendwie.
Das ist ja alles tief einprogrammiert aber ich fand es bei Cameron auch nicht ganz unbedeutend dass er eben auch noch einmal gesagt hat wohl wissend was hier vorgefallen ist.
Und klar über kann man jetzt alles sagen und das bei vollem Bewusstsein gemacht haben sich noch einmal Gottes Hilfe herbei zu holen.
Und jetzt müssen wir uns eine Frage stellen. Wir machen ja hier den Zwanziger Podcast und da ist aber die Frage 1990 oder 2020 Wie groß ist der Bogen jetzt oder ist 1029 eigentlich gestern oder vielleicht sogar Morgen und es gab ein Forum in dem,
Diskutanten wie sie es immer so sehr gut machen miteinander sprachen über Fragen die eigentlich gar nicht so richtig aktuell sind aber trotzdem interessant,
da hören wir hier mal Sabina Becker von der Uni Freiburg.
Sie ist entweder Literatur oder Geschichte keine Ahnung wer danach noch Ute Daniel.
Beide jedenfalls sehr bewandert ist am Ende. Egal ob es Literatur oder Geschichte ist.
Oder wird sie wahrscheinlich irgendwie politisch und Geschichte sein. Sabine Becker Literatur aber wie auch immer.
Literaturfest.
Man kann es frei zuordnen denn inhaltlich interessant was Sie hier sagen.
Sie vergleichen nämlich mal die Weimarer Republik also da wo wir sozusagen diesen amerikanischen Fall Mehrheit entscheidet darüber wer ein Amt bekleidet und wer nicht.
Egal unter welchen Umständen diese Thüringer Verknüpfung.
Darf man das mit Hilfe machen wohl wissend dass es das schon mal gab in Thüringen an gleicher Stelle ja schon mal so eine Duldung ausgesprochen wurde und die Machtübernahme dann eben genauso passierte kann man sich auf Verfassungen berufen oder gehört zwingend mehr dazu.
Und diese zwei Ausschnitte verdeutlichen das sehr gut und woran hat es bei der Weimarer Verfassung eigentlich gemangelt damals.
Ich bin der Meinung dass es hätte gelingen können wenn die ökonomische Krise nicht so fatal gewirkt hätte.
Aus genannten Gründen Wir haben darüber geredet und b wenn zum richtigen Zeitpunkt besseres politisches Personal an entsprechender Stelle gehandelt.
Politisches Personal. Spielt hier auch eine Rolle bei ihr.
Ist schwer zu beurteilen finde ich. Zehn Jahre später war das politische Personal.
Es gab,
ja eine ganz interessante Studie über das antidemokratische Denken in der Weimarer Republik von Kurt Sontheimer aus den 60er Jahren.
Exzellent ist die antidemokratischen Strömungen in dieser Studie ist das Fazit eigentlich dass es so einen Minimalkonsens den die Demokratie braucht,
flächendeckend in Deutschland nicht gegeben.
Das sei der Grund gewesen warum.
Weimarer Republik in der Diktatur.
So stark antidemokratische verschiedenen Richtungen die Demokratie zu missbrauchen um zur Diktatur zu monarchistische Strömungen.
Es entspricht nicht dem deutschen Wesen das Thomas Mann in den Betrachtungen eines Unpolitischen so.
Sehr verschiedene Strömungen.
Linksradikale Strömungen die mit einem Parlamentarismus wenig anfangen können dazu führen dass die Demokratie.
Man kann 1029 sagt nicht einfach alles was wir heute wissen mit reinbringen denn wir 2020 sagen dann müssen wir einfach mit in diese Rechnung einbringen.
Holocaust auf der einen Seite und ein unglaubliches.
Wie soll man sagen entstehen eines Paradieses auf deutschem Boden in den siebziger Jahren.
Und wenn man das beides mit in die Gleichung einwirft und sagt Tradition und Geschichte ist auch mitentscheidend für das Denken über Politik und so weiter dann kann man 2020 sagen,
Es reicht nicht einfach nur sich auf eine Verfassung und einen Text zu berufen und mathematisch zu zählen sondern man muss hier das eine oder andere die geschichtliche Erfahrung irgendwie mit reinbringen.
Entsprechend ist dann eben auch die Gefahr wenn man auf Verfassungstext reduziert.
Dann kann man auch gleich alles aus der Gleichung rausnehmen sind sich hier beide Frauen einig.
Ein Argument aber in einem überschwang an übereinstimmung.
Die Weimarer Republik ist nicht an ihrer Verfassung gescheitert wäre. Sie wäre auch mit dem Grundgesetz gescheitert und umgekehrt die Bundesrepublik hätte mit der Weimarer Verfassung genau zudem werden können was sie heute ist.
Ein sehr schönes Argument.
Ja
Paulskirche Verfassungspatriotismus haben.
Sicherlich.
Wenn wir.
Minimalkonsens für Demokratie.
Jetzt.
Der Weimarer Republik und nicht an der Verfassung.
Schon verglichen am Holocaust und die Entstehung dieses Paradieses aufgrund der Verfassung der anderen Verfassung sagen die eine Verfassung hat es nicht gelegen.
Man könnte ja sagen 2020 Wer sich jetzt wirklich auf Parlaments Mathematik beruft und sagt Das reicht der kann es auch gleich sein lassen weil dann ist es egal.
Dieser Verfassungstext der vorschreibt Mehrheit ist dann im dritten Wahlgang so im ersten Wahlgang so wichtig ist das sozusagen.
Wir haben ja diese Neujahrsansprache aus österreich gehört. Wo diese Reduktion stattfand.
Zum Glück haben die Sterne und wir wissen Morgen kommt auch wieder.
Dann ist im Grunde schon vorbei. Wir sind jetzt ganz schön knapp dran vorbeigeschrammt in Erfurt und wir müssen mal gucken wie das in Sachsen-Anhalt nächstes Jahr ausgeht wenn,
die AfD droht eben anders einzulaufen und entsprechend zum Abschluss dieses Bogens ist es mir nicht ganz unwichtig,
Obama ein bisschen zu rehabilitieren denn wir haben uns sehr beschwert über Obama Obama als er im Amt war.
Wissen wie er ins Amt kam Hope und Change so war er im Amt und plötzlich hat er aufgehört zu twittern und war nur noch für die Eliten zuständig und hat sich breitschlagen lassen.
Die rauszuhauen hat den Terror Tuesday eingeführt und für unglaublich viel Leid in Afghanistan und so weiter gesorgt.
Pakistan wo die Drohnen geflogen sind in Somalia.
Wir wissen heute Trump bombardiert fünfmal so viel wie Obama.
Obamas aus dem Amt gegangen und bis jetzt hat sich die Anzahl also beispielsweise die Anzahl der Bomben die auf Afghanistan gefallen sind hat sich verfünffacht und wir wissen Die Bomben sind noch größer geworden.
Es ist beispielsweise die größte Atombombe die überhaupt gebaut wurde da auf dieses Land gefallen.
Entsprechend gucken wir jetzt nochmal trotz allem wohlwollend auf zwei kleine Ausschnitte von Obama zurück der nehme ich tatsächlich Recht hatte damals wie ich jetzt einfach sagen würde.
Zum einen ein Ausschnitt. Kurz vor Amtsübergabe an Trump.
Man kann ein bisschen an seinem Gesicht ablesen Er hat Angst und er ruft nochmal auf zu was eigentlich.
Wie wir jetzt gehört haben die Verfassung nicht ganz reicht.
Die Zivilgesellschaft ist vielleicht wichtiger als einfach nur das Stück Verfassung das Stück Verfassung ist ganz gut aber man muss es mit Leben füllen. Ohne Zivilgesellschaft ist die Verfassung nichts wert.
Stattgefunden hat,
sie entweder nicht ernst zu nehmen oder ganz anders interpretieren.
Und.
In irgendeiner Weise.
Konservativen oder Rechten Parteien ein unglaubliches Bedürfnis nach Ideologie um gewählt zu werden.
Das aber nicht funktionieren kann für einen dauerhaften.
Die Dauerhaftigkeit ist auch das zentrale Problem. Klar man kann der Mehrheit mal auszählen.
Dann weiß man aber auch die Verliererseite wird sich damit nicht zufrieden geben der Wahlkampf beginnt sofort Politik ist gar nicht möglich und wir wissen auch so eine Wahl hat sie jetzt ausgehalten so zu machen zwei Wahlen bei drei schon bei ihr hat keiner mehr Bock drauf und dann noch mal Bürgerkrieg.
Das ist da alles recht nah gestrickt und wenige Monate vorher beim Nominierungsparteitag für Hillary Clinton als noch nicht klar war dass Trump verliert aber schon als Nominierter und damit als Bedrohung am Horizont stand.
Da wirkte auch Obama noch ein bisschen fröhlicher. Das ist wirklich erschreckend zu sehen in wirklich angsterfüllt hat er auch schon die ersten Gespräche mit Trump geführt und er weiß genau was da kommt.
Das war dann ein paar Monate vorher eben noch anders aber die Botschaft war im Grunde dieselbe und sie ist auch sehr aktuell.
Originales.
Sanaç der musste nur wenige Minuten vorher. Das hat man in seinem Gesicht noch angesehen zurückziehen. Wohl wissend dass es auch hätte eskalieren können in dem Moment weil die Zivilgesellschaft für ihn war da er trotzdem zurückgesteckt.
Vielleicht fordert das jetzt ein bisschen ein dass man auch ihm entgegenkommt.
Der Wahlkampf läuft ja nun sehr auf ihn zu. Und.
Überraschend.
Ich finde es sehr überraschend dass man die Kräfte gegen ihn sind einfach groß.
Muss man einfach sagen Das ist unglaublich wie man jetzt schon wieder versucht.
Aber man will nicht zum Verschwörungstheoretiker sein aber wenn man sieht wie groß der Widerstand ist.
Es ist schon sehr eindeutig. Man sieht ja auch wie Medienberichterstattung darüber stattfindet und dass man lieber verkündet wer der Zweite geworden ist.
Ja das ist absurd.
Es ist sehr absurd und man sieht aber dass er offenbar auf der richtigen Seite ist.
Obama wird sich vielleicht ärgern. Ich spekuliere nur dass man.
Man erkennt seine Freunde an ihren Feinden,
Man erkennt sehr gut ob jemand.
Ja das stimmt genau. Und vielleicht wird sich Obama ärgern dass es nicht 2016 schon dazu kam.
Bernie heranzulassen denn die Chance wäre wirklich da gewesen Trump zu schlagen.
Es ist unglaublich mittlerweile welche Dynamik dieser Wahlkampf wenn man einfach nur fernsehen kriegt man nichts mehr von dem was da wirklich gerade passiert.
Sowohl bei den Republikanern im Repräsentantenhaus die zurückhaben wollen und Trump bringt sich auch finanziell als auch. Insgesamt aber wir schließen mal diesen Punkt mit Was droht eigentlich.
Und Jimmy Kimmel der nochmal die State of the Union so zusammengefasst hat wie wir sie im Grunde hören.
Ja dürften so alle Titel von Achtzigerjahre Schalkern sein die man in der Mediothek erhalten konnte weil sie nicht mehr im Kino liefen.
In welchem Modus er die Zivilgesellschaft so anspricht weil er weiß in welchem Modus er sie braucht.
Das Programm.
So wie man in den Wald hineinruft kriegt man halt seinen Wahlkampf zurück. Sicht gefährlich gefährlich aber gute.
Weiter,
gefährdet werden und zugleich macht man eine wahnsinnig neoliberale Wirtschaftspolitik.
Für uns mal über.
Aber man kann ja oft von so einem Mikrokosmos Ausgehen ins globale wechseln.
Es ist ja erstaunlich dass die FDP eine wirtschaftsliberale Partei sagt wir lassen uns von dem wählen. Das macht uns nichts aus und ich schwöre.
Da fragt man sich ja wie passt das denn eigentlich mit einem wirtschaftsliberalen Flügel zusammen der ja auch liberale Werte immer zumindest vorgibt hochzuhalten.
Denn Liberalismus Freiheit würden wir ja als etwas begreifen das im,
absoluten Gegensatz steht zu faschistischen Tendenzen zu einem Staat der autoritär ist weil man ja sagt Nein der Staat soll sich doch nicht so stark einmischen Der Staat,
soll sich doch auch zurücknehmen Der Staat soll nicht überall immer bei den Steuern sondern ein bisschen mehr.
Freiheit oder führers eigentlich die Entscheidungen nicht beides.
Freiheit. Wir werden aber wenn wir uns ein bisschen in die Geschichte des Neoliberalismus vertiefen erkennen dass das sehr wohl gut zusammenpasst und dass man von so etwas sprechen kann wie dem autoritären Liberalismus,
ist sehr viel älter als wir denken und keineswegs in Thüringen auch nicht in den 70ern begonnen sondern sie geht noch weiter zurück und ich würde zum Einstieg,
ein marxistischer Philosoph aus den USA der.
Neoliberalismus und Status wo er heute angekommen ist denn wir hatten ja so etwas wie die Finanzkrise 2007/2008 hat der Neoliberalismus eigentlich darauf reagiert.
Die These ist Wenn der Neoliberalismus oder der Neoliberalismus braucht um weiterhin existieren zu können Autoritarismus hat seine Legitimation durch die Finanzkrise verloren.
Wenn die freien Märkte einmal für uns alle gut dann geht es nur bergauf.
Das hat sich durch die Finanzkrise gezeigt bzw. musste der Staat eingreifen um Banken zu retten.
Um das neoliberale Regime weiterzuführen. Stärker verknüpfen mit einem Autoritarismus bei,
Reagan die neoliberale Politik eingeführt später wurde das dann auch adaptiert von Tony Blair,
fortgesetzt hat mit Rot-Grün mit Gerhard Schröder und Joschka Fischer,
zwar auch so eine Rückkehr des starken Staates.
Sozialausgaben auch die Polizei verstärkte Aufrüstung.
All diese Dinge haben wir zwar gesehen aber noch nicht in einer solch wie,
in Brasilien gerade erleben ist,
ein sehr interessanter Artikel auf den ich nur hinweisen will den will ich jetzt nicht ausführlich zitieren.
Nachzulesen ist Roberta Silva bei Jakobiner erschienen auf Neoliberalismus.
Da geht es darum dass sich,
jemand zu den sogenannten Chicago Boys gehört.
Die Chicago Boys waren Wirtschaftswissenschaftler die im Umfeld von Freedman studiert und,
Chile gegangen sind als,
Pinochet ins Amt geputscht wurde auch mit Unterstützung der USA.
Sie haben sich dort gewisse Verdienste erworben dadurch dass sie mit diesem faschistischen Regime.
Neoliberale Reformen eingeführt haben.
Nämlich dass der Neoliberalismus Freiheit verspricht aber diese Freiheit,
eine Freiheit wie wir sie jetzt verstehen also eine Freiheit vom Faschismus oder so sondern Freiheit ist in erster Linie Wirtschaftsfreiheit gemeint.
Diese Freiheit für die Wirtschaft die von einem starken Staat ermöglicht werden.
Damit kommen wir noch einmal zu Carl Schmitt.
Berühmte Rede sondern eine Rede die jetzt wieder stärker rezipiert wurde nämlich eine Rede die Carl Schmitt 932 vor einem industriellen Verband gehalten hat.
Starker Staat und gesunde Wirtschaft.
Wer jetzt gleich in die Buchhandlungen den Band kaufen will.
Der kostet 118 Euro. Man findet ihn aber auch in der Bibliothek.
Es sieht sehr teuer aus.
Gibt's das nicht als E-Book.
Ich glaube nein und Carl Schmitt hält nun diese Rede und sagt Wir haben zu viel Politik.
Wir haben überall Politik und man denkt wie das ist doch jetzt der Denker des Politischen der sagt dass politische Unterscheidung zwischen Freund und Feind.
Wie kann er sagen Wir haben zuviel Politik. Was Carl Schmitt meint.
Er sagt über alles Politik Wir würden ja politisiert über alles Mögliche nachdenken und er will eigentlich eine unpolitische Gesellschaft haben aber mit einem enormen politischen Staat der dann auch für die Wirtschaft vieles ermöglicht.
Und da heißt es Wie kann man das Ziel einer Unterscheidung von Staat und Wirtschaft heute verwirklichen.
Immer wieder zeigt sich dasselbe nur ein starker Staat kann entpolitisieren,
nur ein starker Staat kann offen und wirksam anordnen dass gewisse Angelegenheiten wie Verkehr oder Rundfunk,
sein Regal sind und von ihm als solche verwaltet werden dass andere Angelegenheiten der eben genannten wirtschaftlichen Selbstverwaltung zu gehören und alles übrige der Sphäre der freien Wirtschaft überlassen wird.
Ein Staat der eine solche Neuordnung bewirken könnte müsste wie gesagt außerordentlich stark sein und der Akt der Entpolitisierung ist in besonders intensiver Weise ein politischer Akt.
Wie kann man nur den starken Staat gewinnen der einer solchen Kraft Leistung fähig werde.
Hier liegt es heute nahe dem Staat der ja heute nur noch Stoß und momentweise Staat ist durch neue Einrichtungen und Institutionen gewisse solide Grundlagen zu verschaffen.
32 sagt er das 33 wird er Hitler rechtfertigen mit dem schon erwähnten Aufsatz Der Führer schützt das Recht.
Was hier gesagt wird ist Wir brauchen einen autoritären Staat der,
notfalls mit allen Mitteln eben auch der Gewalt diesen Akt der Entpolitisierung leistet das heißt wir haben einen Staat mit einer extrem starken Polizei mit einem extrem starken Militär wo der Parlamentarismus beschnitten oder abgeschafft wird.
Und dann entsteht ein Wirtschaftsraum in dem die freie Wirtschaft sich entfalten darf und wo sie nicht vom Staat irgendwie gegängelt.
Da kommt ja das ist ja hochaktuell bei dieser Wahl weil dieses Argument immer im Raum stand. Hier regiert jetzt wieder die Mitte.
Wir können ja nicht der Politik dem linken oder dem rechten Spektrum überlassen hier muss ja jetzt die Mitte wieder arbeiten.
Dieser Verweis auf die Mitte war deutlich und er ist genauso verlogen weil es,
dieses Aufzeigen von Orten in der politischen Sphäre und dann irgendwie ein Hufeisen RheinMain oder sonstige,
Astrologie als würde man so Sternbild da sehe ich ein Hufeisen irgendwie im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten und es gibt gerade jetzt bei Hick-Hack eine absolute Verlogenheit in diesem Widerspruch.
Freiheit und Führerschaft sozusagen. Der Führer wirkt Zwang aus Das wollen wir nicht. Entscheiden wir uns Wir wählen die Freiheit.
Das kann man eine historisch immer irgendwie einordnen das muss man natürlich auch weil es fehlte damals eine Ideologie,
gegen den Sozialismus da aufkam wie heute das neue chinesische Modell Man weiß nicht genau wie verteidigen wir eigentlich unsere Demokratie dagegen oder unsere Wirtschaftsform in dem Sinne.
Und dann kam es eben zu diesem was die Verfassung der Freiheit der Freiheit.
Das ist nun wirklich kein Grundbegriff. Ich kenne keine Soziologie in der Freiheit ein Grundbegriff Es ist ein rein normativer Begriff genauso ein.
Das ist ein philosophischer Begriff. Heidegger ist die Freiheit ganz entscheidend.
Philosophisches Nachdenken Spiel.
Aber Freiheit meint nicht Demokratie unbedingt.
Genau das ist nämlich der Punkt,
Hayek geht von diesem Freiheitsdrang aus. Ich sage jetzt mal ganz salopp jetztigen Freiheit.
Das Einzige der einzige Autor den ich noch kenne im Sinne von Arbeiten zum Thema Freiheit ist,
Joachim Gauck nach seiner Präsidentschaft da und Hayek verbindet eben diese Freiheit Freiheit Freiheit Freiheit dieses Dogma Freiheit mit Nützlichkeit.
Er spielt ja dem Individuum nicht so die Hände das er sagt und darüber hinaus gibts nichts.
Es gibt gar keine Gesellschaft es gibt nur einfach freie Kräfte auf individueller Ebene sondern er stellt ja einen freien Individuum eine Allgemeinheit gegenüber dem er dann wieder die Freiheit gewährt solange eine Nützlichkeit für diese Allgemeinheit gewährt ist.
Diese Freiheit ist gar nicht so frei wie man glaubt sondern sie ist dieser Nützlichkeit Nützlichkeit Paradigma untergeordnet.
Jetzt kann man natürlich fragen Wer ist denn frei. Bei Hayek und eben auch in der FDP und in dieser modernen Welt wo wir einfach sagen Wir wollen keinen wie Obama sagte wieder Wir wollen uns selbst Gouvernanten.
Wir wollen selbst entscheiden. Also freie Geister entscheiden selbst irgendwie.
Es gibt aber eine Allgemeinheit aus der kommt man nicht raus.
Und was sie ist ist immer salopp sozusagen. Hayek hat da was übersehen.
Aber dieses Prinzip Marktwirtschaften liberale Marktwirtschaft Freiheit des Einzelnen geht natürlich nur so lange bis man den Arbeitsvertrag unterschreibt.
Und dann ist man mittendrin im nicht freien Getriebe wo man einem Zwang unterworfen wird und sanktioniert ist und so weiter und das geht so weit dass Google heute kommt und sagt Wenn Sie bei uns einen Arbeitsvertrag unterschrieben haben dann ist uns ganz egal wo sie ihre Software schreiben die gehört dann immer uns.
Im Sinne von Ach Sie sind auch Eltern. In einer Schule wurde.
Was ich hab gebraucht wird und sie helfen der Schule dabei die App zu schreiben.
Wenn Sie diese App schreiben während sie uns einen Arbeitsvertrag haben dann gehört dieser Code.
Dann können wir den benutzen auch beschränken wie sie den verwenden.
Das galt früher auch für Journalisten Ich habe mal eine ältere.
Regionalzeitung,
sagte sie.
Schreiben Sie. Sie dürfen nicht einmal Tagebuch schreiben.
Und sonst nichts.
Ganz genau. Da gibt's Einwände. Ich würde sagen es ist eine politische Verlogenheit weil die Leute waren klug genug um das zu sehen. Hajek und so weiter.
In der Soziologie ist es völlig normal zu sagen Ja es gibt das Individuum Es gibt die Gesellschaft aber dazwischen ein großer Fragen.
Was wollen wir alles dazwischen haben Gruppen Familien Organisationen Institutionen wie auch immer Man muss aber bei dem Hickhack ganz deutlich sagen und das schlägt sich dann eben verlogen in der Politik der FDP nieder.
Die Freiheit des Unternehmers besteht darin selbst Führer seiner Arbeitnehmer zu sein und die gerade nicht diesem,
diesen Weg der Freiheit zu ermöglichen die können eben nicht selbstbestimmt auf dem Arbeitsmarkt auftreten sondern dann wieder Silicon Valley.
Alles was sie herstellen gehört uns egal in welchem Kontext. Wenn Sie bei uns kündigen haben sie erst mal zwei Jahre Berufssparte und auch ein Ende.
Sie dürfen nicht mal mit jemandem darüber reden was hier passiert ist absoluter Zwang.
Da wird sozusagen sowie die frei. des Unternehmers gewährt wird wird sozusagen der Zwang dieses freien Unternehmers auf seine Arbeitnehmer weitergegeben.
Und diese Ebene die natürlich auch im Kalten Krieg präsent ist während Amerika sein Wirtschaftswachstum aufbaut,
und diese Organisation noch staatlich fördert denn das Silicon Valley ist nun mal eine militärische Gründungsidee gewesen dass es überhaupt dazu kommt und alle Techniken die wir in unseren Smartphones haben die übrigens von Organisationen verkauft werden und nicht von freien Unternehmern.
Das wird einfach völlig ausgeblendet. Damals natürlich zu dieser Autoren Zeit unter dem Eindruck Wir brauchen hier eine Ideologie gegen das sozialistische Modell von dem wir noch nicht wissen ob es erfolgreich ist aber die sind schon mal im Weltraum geflogen.
Wir haben jetzt Angst deswegen historisch gesehen alles akzeptiert aber 2020.
Dass ich bei der FDP immer noch so niederschlägt bis hin zu Wir haben eine Hufeisen Theorie und die sagt Es gibt von rechts und links Bedrohung einer Führerschaft.
Deswegen gehen wir jetzt in die Mitte und stellen da jemanden hin der sozusagen frei für alle das gleiche Recht herstellt ohne Ansinnen der rechten oder linken Gesinnung die ein politisches Anliegen hat in der Wählerschaft.
Man kann davon ausgehen wenn jemand sagt er ist nicht rechts oder links und ist ja immer eher rechts.
Das ist grundsätzlich so wenn ich.
Gegen den,
Ideologie produziert werden muss auch eine Theorie aufgestellt wird bei den Neoliberalen.
Aber schon bei Ludwig von Mises bei dem er sich auf den italienischen Faschismus bezieht die Passage wo er sagt Der Faschismus konnte auf Dauer nicht funktionieren.
Aber er hat schon eine historische Notwendigkeit gehabt.
Ich bringe jetzt ein Zitat Friedman Friedman hat,
eine Rede gehalten und danach gab es Fragen die er beantwortet hat von Studenten.
Da wird er gefragt wie das Verhältnis zu Pinochet war denn es gab eben den Vorwurf dass Friedman direkt Pinochet,
unterstützt und beraten hat aber es waren eben seine Leute da etwas sehr Erstaunliches darüber was er,
in Chile erlebt hat und er spricht von einem Wunder.
Hola.
Getrübte.
Das begegnet einem immer wieder dass man so praktisch überrascht ist davon weil man das Militär die Hierarchie von oben nach unten und die ermöglichen dann sozusagen weil sie diese Freiheit einräumen können.
Dieses bottom up Modell und so weiter.
Das ist in Chile sowieso virulent sozusagen hat man ja einige Experimente gemacht.
Ich habe mal mit Dirk Becker den Soziologen für die FAZ ein Interview geführt wo er plötzlich von Cytosin sprach. Ich habe das nie gehört Cyber-Sicherheit.
Google stellt sich raus. In Chile hat man in den Jahren 1971 damals war Allende dort der Regentschaft hat man so eine Brücke gebaut.
Die Steuerzentrale die wirklich aussieht wie die Brücke von Captain Picard und da sollte dann der Herrscher sitzen.
Und er hat dann Cybersex. Der Name kybernetische Synergie das ist das Wort zusammengebraut Cybersex kybernetische.
Man hat sozusagen Datenfülle nach Chile ausgestreckt und hat dann die Feedbacks genutzt um dann computergenerierte Entscheidungen zu treffen die in den Computer einzugeben und wieder rauszugehen hat natürlich nicht funktioniert.
Man wollte so die Produktionsstraße eine Planwirtschaft machen es gibt einen Roman darüber von Sascha Reh dem man ganz nett zu lesen und er beschreibt das halt auf 300 Seiten.
Genau,
so beschrieben.
Man hat mit dieser Idee die ja jetzt in China wieder aufkommt und so weiter wenn wir nur genug Daten haben und so weiter dann können wir das irgendwie steuern.
Wieder aufkommt uns nur Produktdaten.
Klar vor 40 Jahren war das irgendwie aber deswegen auch dieser Bogen zum Grundsätzlichen.
Aber auch der Bogen grundsätzlich.
Die Chicago Boys stellen das ja irgendwie so dar das dann versuchen sie weiter in diese Chicagoer Soziologie,
Talcott Parsons oder so als Vorreiter der Systemtheorie bevor dann zu Luhmann kam war ja.
Das.
War ja.
So wie soll man sagen Reißbrett Abartigkeit Ja man hat so viele Felder Tafeln da trägt man irgendwelche Eigenschaften ein und dann guckt man sich das so an als würde man es durchrechnen können bis dann eben Luhmann man und mehr in die Biologie eingeordnet hat.
Eigentlich will man nicht warten bis man,
eingeordnet werden dann aber auch.
Zur Autopreise und so. Und dann auch gesagt hat Na ja es gibt ja Systeme haben Grenzen.
Grenzen.
Und wenn wir sagen Wir haben ein Militär dann haben wir da vor allem Organisationen miteinander verschränkt und in der Wirtschaft eben auch das Unternehmen.
Haben Organisationen miteinander in der Wirtschaft.
Dass er das so schön zeigt das kommt ja die Wirtschaft kommt von unten und ist Hierarchie. Du hast es angesprochen ein Unternehmen ist hierarchisch aufgebaut.
Da kann man auch lange drum herumreden und da kann man Sit ins veranstalten in der Mittagspause ist bleibt hierarchisch aufgebaut.
Deswegen funktioniert das sehr gut und wenn man jetzt sich Carl Schmitt in Erinnerung ruft dann ist das überhaupt kein Mary-Kate was da stattgefunden hat sondern dass es,
Teil einer neoliberalen Strategie dass man sagt gerade mit so einem autoritären Staat kann man das ja auch viel besser sofort umsetzen und es gibt.
Bevor die Chicago Boys irgendwie auf die Idee kamen so war es in Deutschland als in der deutschen Soziologie schon völlig normal weiß ich genau welcher Robert Musil oder wer auch immer damals die SPD da untersucht hat.
Ich kenne den Autoren Namen nicht aber das Argument ist völlig einprägsam wenn man eine Demokratie hat also einen gesellschaftlichen Demokratie.
Hat individuell ganz viele Demokraten.
Da braucht man dazwischen Parteien Organisationen die allerdings muss man wieder Armée aufstellen sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Also eine demokratische Partei die in der Demokraten Demokratie herstellen wollen müssen sie sich selbst organisieren wie eine Armee.
Das ist ein eigentlich völlig leicht verständliches Argument denn jammern muss beschlussfähig sein.
Man muss fähig sein man darf nicht die ganze Gesellschaft mit so einer Komplexität überfordern.
Es ist klar Die Nachrichten dauern fünf Minuten und da muss dann auch noch rausfallen von Relevanz ist und so weiter.
Und das muss organisiert werden und diese Organisation wird immer ausgeblendet bei Hajek bei Carl Schmitt hat man ja sowieso nur so ein großes philosophisches Denken wie man dazu einer praktischen Relevanz wie sie der Bürgerkrieg jetzt.
Kann man sich ja durchaus mal fragen und kriegt man keine Antwort. Und hier hat man es auch wieder.
Klar kann man jetzt immer dieses große Bild. Die Hierarchie ist ab und so weiter.
Aber das sind alles so Denkmodelle an denen man sich immer so begeistern kann.
Da gibt es unendlich viele Youtube Filme aber es gibt auch Organisationen zur Soziologie guckt euch das doch mal an das wird seit hundert Jahren gemacht und die überraschung die drin stecken wenn man das nicht beachtet die sind gar nicht so groß wie man immer glaubt.
Selbst eine Familie hat ne Hierarchie wenn man sich diesem Denken hingeben will ja und klar da dürfen die Kinder auch mitentscheiden aber diese ganze Idee von Paradigma Setzung Freiheit ist wie gesagt historisch verständlich.
Aber das ist wirklich unzureichendes denken würde ich so schlussfolgern.
Gerade jetzt 2020 Sachen weil man sieht was daraus erwächst wenn man die Leute.
Verbindet mit Ideologie und.
Denkweisen zu verbinden. In Thüringen.
Haben,
unser Land kaputt gemacht.
Hat der Neoliberalismus dafür gesorgt dass.
Kulturell wichtig war sich aufgelöst hat die Neoliberalen wieder,
Marxismus.
Noch ein Beispiel für dieses Verständnis von Demokratie Demokratie.
981.
Aber eine Diktatur kann während einer übergangszeit ein notwendiges System sein.
Es ist manchmal notwendig für ein Land für eine gewisse Zeit über eine Form diktatorischer Macht zu verfügen wie sie es einem Diktator möglich liberal zu regieren.
Ebenso möglich ist dass eine Demokratie mit einem völligen Mangel an Liberalismus regiert.
Persönlich ziehe ich einen liberalen Diktator einer demokratischen Regierung ohne Liberalismus vor.
Und dann wird er nochmal gefragt Was bedeutet das für übergangszeiten starke und diktatorische Regierungen befürworten.
Hajek sagt unter solchen Umständen ist es praktisch unvermeidlich,
dass jemand über nahezu absolute Vollmachten verfügt absolute Vollmachten die er genau zu dem Zweck einsetzen müsste jede absolute Macht in der Zukunft zu vermeiden und zu beschränken.
Was er aber eigentlich möchte ist dass durch diesen autoritären Staat der etabliert wird es möglich ist Gesetze zu machen die dem Kapital so sehr zugute kommen dass das,
nicht mehr zu revidieren ist wenn man dann wieder übergeht in eine liberale Demokratie.
Ich habe dieses Interview zitiert aus einem Buch das kürzlich erschienen ist dass ich jedem ans Herz legen kann dass auch wesentlich günstiger ist unregierbar eine Gesellschaft eine Genealogie des autoritären Liberalismus.
Dieser Autor erzählt hier eine Geschichte des Neoliberalismus wie man sie noch nicht gelesen hat weil er diese großen Bezüge,
herstellt global betrachtet und ganz stark auch auf Amerika gedacht wird wie es Bestrebungen beispielsweise in Verfassungen festzuschreiben dass,
bestimmte Steuern nicht erhoben werden dürfen.
Dass der Kapitalismus zum Gesetz wird und dass man dadurch dafür sorgt dass auch danach wenn die Verfassung erst einmal geändert wird ist sehr schwierig hat hat man dann eine Mitte links Regierung die irgendwelche Steuern erheben will.
Es gab ja auch in Deutschland diese Diskussion darüber darf man mehr als 50 Prozent Einkommenssteuer erheben.
Diese Idee ist nicht rechtens da hat man sich von konservativer Seite sehr eingesetzt dass das nicht passiert.
Aber es gibt eben diesen autoritären Liberalismus der dafür sorgen will dass diese Kapitalinteressen dauerhaft verteidigt werden.
Und um das durchzusetzen ist man auch bereit mit Faschisten einen Pakt einzugehen und man macht das eine Weile und wenn immer Leute kommen und sagen Na ja aber die setzen sich ja dann doch für die Freiheit des Marktes ein.
Da muss man fragen welche Freiheit ist denn dort eigentlich gemeint Du hast schon die Hierarchie in Betrieben angesprochen man kann aber auch auf die Kartelle und Monopole verweisen.
Da wird,
eben darauf angesprochen auf den freien Markt und auf den neoliberalen Vordenker und ein bisschen was zu.
Sie.
Stecken.
Die.
Karten.
Das noch ein bisschen aus dass es auch ein Markt ist der auf Gewalt aufbaut aufgebaut ist.
Jansky ist leider immer sehr normativ bei dieser Angelegenheit. Was nur aus deutscher Sicht auffällt weil in Amerika ist das.
Da redet man so alles rein funktionale Argumente warum man,
oder mit denen man Hayek Friedman einfach verurteilen kann im Sinne von Ja es ist halt die Ideologie der Mächtigen grundsätzlich und die haben dann halt das Interesse und wollen dann irgendwie ihre Besitzstände wahren,
auf Ideen wie das macht der Hayek ganz explizit Bürger den Bürger Begriff selbst mal wieder neu.
Also wir unterscheiden einfach ganz klar zwischen Bürgern und Bürgerinnen Bürger dürfen sich politisch beteiligen und alle anderen eben nicht.
Und dann hat man so ein antikes denken wo man nur die ökonomische Dimension wieder rein indem man sagt.
Die Nützlichkeit der Allgemeinheit zusteuern beispielsweise durch sie in der Lage Steuern zu zahlen oder nehmen keine Sozialleistungen Anspruch das sind halt Bürger die dürfen ja auch politisch mitmachen und die anderen nicht.
Das widerspricht nun echt fundamental der demokratischen Idee dass grundsätzlich erst einmal jeder,
im Grunde wird ja gerade auch diskutiert ob man es vielleicht sogar ausweitet und nicht nur jeder Staatsbürger sondern jeder Anwesende auf einem Staatsgebiet sich einfach beteiligen darf sei es durch eine Stimmabgabe aber sei es auch durch,
die Möglichkeit Bürgerinitiativen zu werden oder auch nicht.
Und wenn man jetzt diese Frage mal so Ich bin immer beeindruckt wie groß diese Fridman Hayek Widerstand zu Keynes Keynes wird Keynes gesprochen,
Wie groß immer noch dieses Vortragender Haie Gesellschaft.
Und so weiter hätte man dieses Mega virulent als wären wir immer noch in diesem Mega Streit Sozialismus gegen Kapitalismus.
Der Russe bedroht die Sowjetunion und wir müssen uns hier behaupten der amerikanische Präsident wir sind alle loyal.
Denn wenn man es einfach funktional betrachtet ist es ja super einfach zu sagen,
Wir haben es halt grundsätzlich mit handelnden Menschen zu tun die in ökonomische Asymmetrien rein laufen weil einfach mehr äpfel geerntet als der andere also wenn man das irgendwie ausgleichen wie man es aus.
Juristischen Rahmen man versucht eine ökonomische Asymmetrie durch Juristerei zu begradigen.
Jetzt ist die Frage warum sollte man sich an irgendwelche juristischen Gesetze halten nur weil sie da sind.
Sie brauchen also einen Ursprung und dieser Ursprung macht sie immer angreifbar denn sakral Herrschaft Gottesgnadentum und so weiter da fallen die Widersprüche schwer.
Aber auch das war ja dann möglich. Es hat ja nicht lange gedauert.
Also bestand irgendwann die Möglichkeit Legitimation herbeizuführen für eine juristische Einhegung ökonomische Asymmetrien also hat man die juristischen selbst nochmal zur Disposition gestellt sowie die juristischen die ökonomischen Asymmetrien zur Disposition.
Das machen wir jetzt politisch und dann ist die Frage Wie stellen wir jetzt diese politische Souveränität her in einem säkularen Staat also wenn der Gott sozusagen als Ursprung ausfällt.
Kriegt man das selber hin und dann hat Luhmann dieses super einfache Argument Das ist die Legitimation durch Verfahren denn jedes Mal wenn man sich den amerikanischen Wahlkampf anguckt und denkt,
ist doch erst 2017 wie jetzt schon 2020 Präsident werden wollen ja man braucht dieses Verfahren Es muss diese Geschichte aufgearbeitet werden.
Es ist jetzt hochinteressant zu sehen wie Michael Bloomberg ohne Vorgeschichte in diesen Wahlkampf eingreift.
Diese Debatten Geschichte noch nicht mitgebracht hat diese ganze Bernie Sanders Mobilisierung nicht als Rucksack dabei hat sondern einfach sagt Ich habe 400 Millionen Euro.
Hillary Clinton auch ganz gut.
Genau und findet Hillary Clinton gut. Weil irgendwie ausgezählt hat.
Die hat ja immer noch ein paar Punkte und da kann man jetzt in Amerika wieder sehen inwieweit meine Legitimation durch Verfahren aufbrechen kann durch neoliberales einfach Geld.
Wir nutzen jetzt einfach wieder eine ökonomische Asymmetrie um die durchzurechnen durch die juristische durch was die denn sie hat gesagt bei der Debatte darf nur teilnehmen werden sie die Voraussetzung erfüllt streichen wir jetzt mal wer hier so viel Geld im Spiel. Wir müssen auch Blumberg Neiddebatten Bühne bieten.
Ökonomisch.
Wie.
Da hat man das einfach aufgehoben hat man die eigenen juristischen Regelungen einfach aufgehoben um zu sagen Der darf jetzt auch mit auf die Bühne.
Das ökonomische schlägt sich wieder voll durch.
Ökologisch. Und wir können uns in geringerem Maße ausmalen wie das,
wäre wenn jetzt ein Friedrich Merz Kanzlerkandidat würde der erst einmal selbst ein bisschen Geld im Rücken hat aber entscheidend sind die Leute zu denen er Kontakt hat und man sieht ja gerade wie die konservativen Medien,
jetzt eigentlich schon zum Kanzler erklären wollen auf jeder Titelseite und mit Merz kann es ja durchaus dann kommen dass wir einen autoritären Liberalismus einer ganz neuen Art erleben,
da er zum einen einen Rechtsruck vollziehen wird in,
der Flüchtlingsfrage aber auch in der Sozialpolitik.
Man kann sich gut vorstellen dass es mit ihm dann irgendwann keine Krankenkassen mehr gibt man kann auch das Wahlrecht ja einschränken für,
beispielsweise Hartz-IV-Empfänger oder solche Dinge kann man durchbringen und man hat noch eine neue Legitimation die wir nicht außer Acht lassen dürfen.
Beim letzten Mal auf den Black Rock verwiesen wer sich sagt wir müssen jetzt also ökologisch denken die Unternehmen und so weiter.
Die ökologische Frage wird auch für Friedrich Merz in irgendeiner Weise eine Rolle spielen.
Nun ist er sicherlich niemand der Verbote bringen will da würde er wieder sagen Ich bin ja ein Liberaler.
Aber er könnte diese ökologische Frage mit der wirtschaftlichen Frage so eng verquicken dass er sagt Das ist jetzt hier unser Gebot der Stunde.
Hier brauchen wir jetzt auch so etwas wie einen Ausnahmezustand.
Deswegen ermöglichen wir Unternehmen die sich ökologisch engagieren erstmal gar keine Steuern zahlen müssen.
Die sollen jetzt die werden jetzt komplett befreit davon. Und mir fällt eine Partei ein die da wahrscheinlich mitmachen würde es gab ja schon früher mal in der ersten Reihe nicht einer evangelischen Kirche gerade war.
Katrin Göring-Eckardt die sich da schon so äußerte Naja wir wollen da jetzt mal nichts ausschließen.
Und ich könnte mir durchaus einen autoritären Liberalismus vorstellen mit einem grünen Deckmäntelchen.
Das ist so eine kleine Prognose hier an dieser Stelle und ich hoffe dass ich nicht Recht habe.
Sieht aber so aus als würden die Grünen das war ja auch eine der ersten Sprachregelung wenn Merz gewählt wird sind wir dabei das können wir uns durchaus vorstellen es ist eine Frage Wer wird Kanzler können ja auch wir als Grüne.
Aber die Koalition selbst steht wegen sowas nicht in Frage.
Das soll eben auch mein letzter Gedanke sein. Diese ganze Heikki Idee da haben wir ja bei. Auch noch nochmal erinnert an Fratzscher gegen Merz.
Diese ganze Heikki Idee dass sie immer noch lebt finde ich skandalös Ehrlich gesagt weil sie nur darin besteht zu sagen Wir haben ökonomische Asymmetrien und die politische Aufgabe ist es sich da rauszuhalten.
So wie Merz einfach da sitzt und sagt Ich definiere jetzt mal das Politische.
Sozusagen Hayek und alle da irgendwie im Kopf. Und dann sitzt da dem ökonomen gegenüber und sagt ihm eine Steuerreform.
Aber ich habe schon drei mitgemacht die sind alle gescheitert. Wir halten uns da mal raus.
Das einzige was wir machen würden ist vielleicht ein CO2-Preis festlegen aber aus dem Rest halten wir uns raus. Es gibt hier keine politische Dimension über die wir diskutieren wollen.
Und das ist durchaus eine Gefahr für die Grünen nun mit einem ökologischen Anliegen hast.
Und denen wieder ein Weg geboten wird es möglichst unpolitisch zu machen.
Wir haben von Merkel jetzt gelernt der unpolitische weg ist der beste Weg eine Regierung sich raushalten.
Dann kann es durchaus sein dass wir 2021 einfach so ein schwarz grünes aber nicht großer Streit wie in österreich sondern ein ganz Gediegenes.
Wir halten uns hier aus allem raus und wenn Ansprüche kommen kann man ja noch mal in der Uni diskutieren oder so.
Aber nicht im Parlament. Diese Gefahr besteht durchaus.
Argumentieren dass man Sozialabgaben streicht weil man jetzt das Geld erst einmal für das Wichtigste nämlich für die Rettung des Klimas ausgeben muss. Man findet die Argumentation,
und.
Es ist ja so dass jetzt aber das Argument der Hauspostille.
Argumentation.
Wir brauchen eine starke Naturwissenschaftler Verschwindenlassen an den Universitäten.
Wir brauchen eine starke Polizei Wir müssen endlich diese Kulturwissenschaftler verschwinden lassen an den Universitäten die zerstören unsere Gesellschaft.
Das spüren unsere Gesellschaften.
Aber dass da einer recht.
Das ist eine Rechtfertigung die funktioniert in Brasilien die würde hier so nicht funktionieren zumindest nicht für eine große Mehrheit. Aber mit dieser Klimageschichte kann man auch eine Politik machen.
Nicht.
Aber man kann auch.
Schon Wahlkampf ist wissen wir in Amerika und wir haben das letzte Mal Bill neben Steve Bennett gehört.
Da hat er sich besonders deswegen herausgehoben nach dreieinhalb Stunden Interview durchgerungen zu sagen was Elizabeth Warren da macht das mag ich.
Gleichzeitig fiel aber auch auf Bernie sagt er nichts da hält er sich raus und wir dachten so er aus Gründen müsste Werner Börni ansprechen schon in seinen großen Jubel verfallen.
Wenn einer den Bürgerkrieg fordert dann ist das ja wohl Börni mit seiner Revolution.
Und jetzt gab es wie bestellt eigentlich ja im Fernsehen die Situation dass Steve Banat bei Bill Maher Omar zu Gast war der ihn in seinem Muehl Tag wie es da nun noch häufiger passiert.
Interessant Bill Maher macht wahrscheinlich gerade die interessanteste Sendung für sich ein bisschen unter Druck gesetzt fühlte.
Und plötzlich ploppt es aus den Beinen heraus und nicht nur wird hier Bernie Sanders angesprochen sondern auch nochmal die modernen Monetary Theory und die ein oder andere Idee die Trump damit Trump damit verbindet.
Gleichzeitig aber den Demokraten vorwirft diese eine Minute 44 Fernsehen sind hier wirklich hochinteressant.
Pence.
Der Moderator vollkommen recht. Trump macht eine moderne Monetary von rechts und.
Ja genau.
Ich selten so eine Ecke nie so eine Ecke gedrängt gesehen. Also wirklich gut.
Geistig ist Wahnsinn.
Dieses Defizit sagen diese Defizit Politik zu sagen Wir gehen einfach unglaublich viel Geld aus und das Wachstum wird ja dann zu entsprechenden mehr an Steuereinnahmen führen und das wieder auffangen.
Diese Losung die jetzt seit drei Jahren fährt wissen wir Die geht nicht auf.
Ich lese mal Forster entsetzt das ja nun auch nicht ganz so kritisch begleitet wie die deutschen Medien.
Nach drei Jahren Trump ist folgende Bilanz zu ziehen die US Staatsschulden sind von neun und zehn komma acht Billionen im ersten Quartal 2017 auf drei und zwanzig komma zwei Billionen per Ende Januar 2020 gestiegen,
also eine Billion pro Jahr ungefähr in diesen drei Jahren.
Statt um drei Prozent oder mehr jährlich ist die US-Wirtschaft unter Trump durchschnittlich um 2,5 Prozent gewachsen was macht das Weiße Haus angesichts dieser Realität.
Es tut als ob nichts wäre für das laufende Jahr werden im neuen Budget 2,8 Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum eingesetzt ein halber Prozentpunkt mehr als von der Zentralbank Fed und vom unabhängigen Budget Büro CBO veranschlagt.
Trump rechnet sich selbst das Wirtschaftswachstum schön im Weißen Haus bekommt aber die Bundesregierung macht sowas ja auch.
Dann kommt es eben die Wirtschaftsweisen stellen dann einfach eine andere Zahl in den Raum und so weiter und diese Idee von Wir haben jetzt einfach eine Billion im Jahr als Steuererleichterung raus und zwar nur an die Top ein Prozent weil.
Die Freien Alle anderen müssen dann über den Arbeitsvertrag hoffen dass sie davon partizipieren funktioniert nicht.
Also wir sehen jetzt hier schon wieder im Anmarsch was die Großen Kennziffern angeht.
So eine 2008 Situation.
Mich amüsiert das denn er bringt sich auf die sonst gar nicht so kritisch gegenüber gestanden.
Trump gar nicht hat aber null doch und Austeritätspolitik.
Aber die schwarze Null und Austeritätspolitik gut und sagen Wir brauchen einen Staat auf soliden Füßen und das darf kein Staat sein der zu hoch verschuldet ist der ist nicht stabil.
Da wird auch ein Plat für das hoch verschuldete.
Und dass Trump das jetzt einfach macht leider nicht zum Wohle des Volkes sondern eben für das eine Prozent.
Das BAMF das jetzt einfach macht das Wohl des Volkes besser.
Das ist das Traurige dabei aber auch das dass diese Leute ab und an aber zugleich Porky wenn man befolgen würde.
Das Traurige dabei aber auch das Schöne dass er jetzt diese Leute gegen sich aufbringt und man aber zugleich auch sieht,
wenn man die Moderne monetarisieren befolgen würde kann man sagen es ist auch gar nicht schlimm dass das über Steuereinnahmen nicht mehr reinkommt.
Auch wenn das das Boyer Genau.
Man könnte ja einfach sagen wir streichen es. Die Neuen werden gestrichen.
Man könnte ja einfach sagen Ja.
Solange die Inflation im Zaum ist und das haben wir erst mal mit Nullen im Buch der Effekt kein Problem mehr.
Ja Ja.
Genau.
Genau deswegen will ich auch sagen man könnte daraus ein Programm stricken die Frage ist noch.
Man könnte daraus.
Wie öffentlich kann man es machen denn wir haben ja schon beim letzten Mal gehört für ihn ist ja die moderne monetäre Theorie gleich ein Bail out des kleinen Mannes erwachsen ganz schnell Anforderungen Ansprüche.
Etwas machen denn beim letzten Mal gehört es ja nicht gleich ein Bail out.
Alles ganz schnell Anfeuerung Ansprüche aus der breite Schicht wenn sie denn überhaupt würde.
Aus der breiteren Wählerschicht wenn sie denn darüber aufgeklärt würde was da geschieht.
So ein Grundeinkommen für alle Idee ist da gar nicht so weit von Propeller Geld Helikoptergeld wird entfernt.
Ein Grundeinkommen für alle es da gar nicht.
Aspekte aufgreifen. Beim letzten Mal durchgehen lassen da hast du nämlich auch gesagt ja Bernie Sanders ist ein Populist.
Ich mag den Bernie Sanders nicht weil er ein Sozialist ist sondern weil er ein Populist ist.
Warum ist Sanders ein Populist. Ich verstehe das nicht.
Er hat ein sehr populäres auftreten und seine Videos funktionieren gut aber er vertritt ja ganz seriöse Standpunkte Das ist eine ganz seriöse Politik.
Es ist ja nicht jemand der das Blaue vom Himmel verspricht denn Populismus ist ja eine sehr eigenartige Geschichte.
Ich würde sagen Angela Merkel tritt zum Teil viel populistischer auf nicht in dem Sinne dass sie die Massen mitreißt aber indem sie Dinge von sich gibt die reiner Populismus sind.
Während ich eigentlich eine sehr solide Argumentationsweise finde was Bernie Sanders so von sich gibt.
Der Populismus Begriff ist in Deutschland sehr eng geknüpft an ein Werturteil über ein Auftreten.
Man sieht jemanden im Modus sprechen und dann sagt man Das ist aber populistisch.
Man könnte ihnen genauso gut einen Anzug anziehen ihnen langsam reden lassen die Hände unten und dann wäre Bernie Sanders plötzlich kein Populist mehr sondern normaler Sozialdemokrat.
Bei Steve Benson hat Carl Schmitt gelesen steckt einfach dahinter Wenn wir als politische Denken dann doch eher an Krieg als an Frieden.
Selbst wenn das ein Bürgerkrieg ist denn die Hauptsache es werden hier immer wieder Identitäten geklärt.
Der Staat der den den den göttlichen Bezug verliert als Rückhalt und Legitimation braucht hat eine neue Legitimationskrise. Also sucht er sich eine.
Und das ist dann erst mal der Große. Das Austragen eines großen Satzes der Bürgerkrieg und sei es erst mal nur um die Frontlinien zu klären und so weiter.
Und in diesem Maße ist Bernie Sanders einer der die eigentlichen Konfliktlinien im Publikum aufgreift und sichtbar macht und sich grundsätzlich gegen das Establishment stellt.
Und in diesem Sinne ist ein Populist. Er lässt dem alten Establishment nicht mehr durchgehen was man immer durchgehen lassen,
sondern er möchte mit Volkes Unterstützung so wie Trump auch einfach in Washington einschreiten und sagen So und so ist jetzt die Sachlage ohne deren Sicht passt das ganz gut ins Bild.
Und er hat eine Historie hinter sich des American Populismus der um 1900 schon mal aufblühte,
wo sich Landwirte einfache Landwirte zusammengetan haben und versucht haben zu agitieren gegen die Landwirtschaft.
Da haben wir schon eine Struktur die sehr viel Produktionsmittel in der Hand haben die Entscheider sind bzw. beeinflusst.
In Washington tun sich diese Leute aus dem Volk zusammen um dagegen zu agitieren und versuchen ihre Rechte ihre demokratischen Rechte geltend zu machen und zu sagen wir als kleine Unternehmer.
Unterstützung bekommen wir dürfen nicht an die Kandare genommen werden von diesen Großkonzerne.
Eine Entwicklung die jetzt 120 Jahre zurückliegt.
Populismus auch deswegen habe ich.
Eher positiven Populismus.
Der positiven Seite von Sanders benannt hat das letzte Mal in dieser Fernsehdokumentation diesem Interview aufgeschlüsselt.
Es geht jetzt nicht mehr um die Frage Republikaner gegen Demokraten oder so sondern es geht jetzt um die Frage nationaler Populismus gegen sozialistischem Populismus.
Die Republikaner haben sich auf diesen nationalen Identität über die Amerikaner America first und so weiter,
völkisch im Grunde und der sozialistische Populismus von Bernie Sanders schließt wieder an das Schicksal des Einzelnen an und versucht darüber zu mobilisieren und so weiter.
Und ich finde es überraschend wie sehr Steve benannter sagt.
Hauptsache Populismus und ich sage Ihnen hier sogar wenn auch in die Ecke gedrängt Bernie ist eigentlich ein cooler Typ er hat im Grunde die Reichweite und umso mehr darauf besteht dass macht Trump auch zu sagen kommt die Wahl wird schon wieder manipuliert.
Die letzte Umfrage vor der Europawahl wurde gar nicht veröffentlicht durch technischen Fehler und dann gab es zu diesen Auszählungen Schwierigkeiten.
Die nutzen das natürlich extrem um grundsätzlich so ein Argument zu machen. Diese Wahl wird gerade manipuliert.
Vielleicht ist Bill Maher in seiner allerletzten Sendung Diese Woche hat er diese große Angst geschürt was ist wenn Trump abgewählt ist.
Aber sagt die Wahl erkenne ich nicht an weil gab es ja Manipulation und so weiter.
Ganz ernsthaft durchdiskutiert da muss seine Gäste ein bisschen ab.
Das Militär ist ehrenvoll und die werden das dann schon regeln. Aber da steht halt im Raum.
Aber es ist im Grunde dieser große neue Gegensatz Populismus gegen Populismus in der Hoffnung dass es irgendwie aufgeht vielleicht kann man sagen völkischer Populismus gegen bürgerlichen.
Ein reines Einwanderungsland ist.
Es gibt diese wunderbare Passage aus,
Des Teufels General von Carl Zuckmayer.
Gemacht.
Getrieben über die Jahrhunderte hindurch zu dem gemacht was wir heute sind,
mit einer Identität zu tun die geleugnet wird aber noch stärker.
Aber das hat Trump egal.
Auf Einwanderung basiert.
Wahrscheinlich mit nationalistisch am besten zu fassen wenngleich Nationalismus.
Wird.
In Amerika aufgewachsen.
Im Grunde auch nationalistisch sagen Ich finde nur den Gegensatz bürgerlich und völkisch einmal das Kollektiv denken dann einmal das Individuum so bezeichnen.
Vielleicht hat Amerika schon genug eigene Historie jetzt über 244 Jahre aufgebaut um zu sagen Wir können uns ja auch,
aber man muss auch immer wieder darauf hinweisen Es ist nicht die United People of America sondern die United States.
Man kann diese Dimensionen aber nicht ganz herausrechnen.
Kommen wir doch mal in drei kleinen Clips in den aktuellen Wahlkampf denn nun stehen ja die Vorwahlen an. Die ist dann auch ein bisschen entscheidend. Super Tuesday und so weiter.
Worauf hat Börni nach Iowa und New Hampshire bei der letzten Debatte wert gelegt.
Hier.
Grassers.
Hearing der Paine.
Papiere weltweit 6000 Bosporus muss signifikant Fujian Kreke wurde.
Nein.
Trump.
Interessante Mobilisierung obwohl die Wahlbeteiligung niedriger war als bei der Abwahl von George W.
Bush aber das war auch die zweite Amtszeit für Obama 2008.
Obwohl die niedrige Wahlbeteiligung von diesem Rekordniveau war waren mehr Jüngere da von denen er noch glaubt sie haben ihn alle unterstützt.
Das muss man dann nochmal überprüfen denn in New Hampshire war das nämlich ein bisschen anders.
In New Hampshire hat man tatsächlich den 2008 Tatbeteiligung Rekord gebrochen da man wahrscheinlich durch Iowa doch so viele mobilisieren konnte mal zu dieser Wahl hin.
Zwei Drittel der Wähler in New Hampshire waren über 55 und entschieden sich zwischen Bodycheck und klobiger zu zwei Dritteln.
Da fiel also ab einer gewissen Altersgrenze nach oben fällt für dieses populistische Revolutionäre denken gar nicht so viel ab sondern da will man irgendwie auf Nummer sicher gehen,
und das ist eben besonders bei Bodycheck so interessant weil erst ein 38 jähriger Bürgermeister im Grunde und er wird jetzt aber gewählt von Leuten die zu 90 Prozent und es ist bei ihnen der höchste Wert zu 90 Prozent sagen Ist mir egal wen ich wähle Hauptsache gegen Trump.
Mittlerweile ist das gegen Trump Argument das stärkste überhaupt und die Frage ist Wer kann es auf sich Münzen.
Wirklich beeindruckend und in New Hampshire war es so dass 13 Prozent der Wähler Erstwähler waren es ist eine sehr gute Quote wenn auch nicht Rekorde mäßig schon mal mehr bei den Jugendlichen mobilisiert es kann auch 15 16 Prozent sein es waren 13 Prozent.
Man hat auch mit 29 Prozent die meisten Stimmen geholt.
Dieses Argument Hauptsache gegen Trump und vielleicht doch lieber weniger Experimente scheint so ein bisschen ein Einfallswinkel für Blumberger zu sein.
Was die reine Zahlen angeht Es gibt jedenfalls großes große Lagerbildung im Sinne von,
nicht Bürgerkrieg aber schon großen Gegensatz in der Demokratischen Partei nämlich entweder man macht jetzt in Börni oder halt Hauptsache nicht Trump aber dann ist auch fast egal wer als Nächstes kommt.
Das war tatsächlich das allererste Thema was sie mit ihm. Er war der erste Redner an der Debatte und das hat man als Erstes mit ihm geklärt.
Elizabeth Warren steigt dann eben auch solche Zahlen in ihrem ersten Statement voll ein.
Berlin.
Naja bla bla bla. Inhaltlich macht sie ihre Argumente gar nicht mehr ist mir aufgefallen.
Also 4 2 prozent Spitzensteuersatz Abschöpfungen neuerdings und so insgesamt sondern jetzt geht es um diese Einigkeit der Partei.
Ein bisschen hat sich da zumindest der Sprache sehr gemäßigt und irgendwie funktioniere das irgendwie mit weniger als 10 Prozent eingefahren spielte also gar keine Rolle mehr.
Erstaunlich was hätten wir jetzt vor einem halben Jahr nicht gedacht.
Da lag ich bei 23 Prozent.
Einfach nicht mithalten kann eine Herzattacke hatte ich dann doch noch mal raus gerettet weil man ja so medizinisch nochmal durch.
Vielleicht einfach zu früh gestartet da Bernie mit seinem kleinen Herzattacken hat ihn dann doch noch mal raus gerettet weil man doch gesehen hat naja so medizinisch nochmal richtig durchgecheckt und zusammengenäht kommt man doch fitter raus als wenn man sich so durch schleppt und es hat ihm wirklich den Arsch gerettet.
Dann kommt man doch wieder raus und.
Ich finde das ja ganz wunderbar.
Dass sie bald in Ruhestand gehen und Zeitungskrise,
die so unglaublich aufgeregt haben dass man als Hoffnungsträger gesehen wird wie viele junge Leute die den.
Keineswegs antiquiert sind. Bei diesen Leuten.
Zum alten Eisen gehört hatten sie großes Problem damit sie akzeptieren müssen,
denn sie sehen so könnte ich ja eigentlich auch sein.
Aber ich bin ja nicht so dynamisch umgeben von Dreißigjährigen die mich beraten.
38 ist schon viel seriöser als der alte Bernie Sanders,
wird nie müde werden zu betonen dass man diese Kategorisierungen damit verbindet sich irgendeine Ideologie vollkommen über Bord werfen sollten.
Bei aller Kritik die ich so viel interessanter als das meiste was wir an politischen Personal.
Man kennt vielleicht gar niemanden. Bei Bernie Sanders.
Reproduzieren.
Man versucht sich,
vom Leib zu halten.
Das ist der eigentliche Punkt. Denn wenn du sagst in meinem Buch Republik werden die Renten eine Rolle spielen sei nur die halbe Wahrheit denn es geht ja um den Gemütszustand der gesamten Gesellschaft wenn so viele alte Leute alt sind und das sieht man eben bei ZG am besten.
Und es ist noch kein Rentner Republik in Amerika aber man sieht ja schon viele fühlen sich schon wie eine Räterepublik.
Es gibt Orte in Amerika die so separiert sind von dem eigentlich modernen urbanen Leben sondern wo sich Leute wirklich zurückziehen um da allzu werden. Und da schlägt er voll durch.
Da hat er Zustimmungswerte 90 95 prozent. Da will man auch keine Frau wie Clochard. Da geht man in beiden machts nicht.
Da gibt es ganz einfache Dichotomie. In Ostdeutschland haben wir das ja auch in Berlin und Brandenburg.
So eine schöne Migrationsbewegung dass die ganzen jungen Leute nach Berlin ziehen und die Alten aber mehrheitlich wieder zurück. Also auch Brandenburg wächst.
Aber es sind eben die. Es ist die Generation 55 plus die 200000 ungefähr im Jahr aus den urbanen Zentren raus.
Und dann ist man so vor dem Brandenburger Tor und da macht man sich im Speckgürtel Berlin irgendwie breit schaffts noch zum Theater zu fahren mit der S-Bahn irgendwie diese Anbindung wären jetzt alle gebaut aber man zieht sich halt zurück und diese Separierung nach alter,
schlägt sich in so einem Gemütszustand nieder und wenn man dann demokratisch einfach durchzählen dann sieht man solche Effekte.
Das könnte auch noch Jens Spahn zugute kommen wenn der noch in irgendeiner Weise spielen darf.
Absolut noch.
Spätestens in fünf sechs Jahren ist der.
Auf jeden Fall jemand der im übrigen ganz ähnlich aufgebaut ist ebenso abgekapselt.
Na ja er hat ja jetzt dieses Interview in Zeit gegeben wo dieser eine Ausschnitt publik wurde wo er gefragt wurde ist die CDU bereit für einen schwulen Chef hat er gesagt.
Also ich komme in Münster aus dem kleinen örtchen mit 3600 Einwohnern und jedes Mal 50 Prozent.
Also nicht mal da stellt sich diese Frage und sie kommen mit dieser Frage aus welcher Zeit kommen sie eigentlich genau dieses Schwulsein ist so weit akzeptiert.
Der Daily kriegt man immer mal wieder Anekdoten die Leute werden aufgeklärt und Journalisten der ist aber schwul. Ach so. Das wusste ich nicht.
Aber im Grunde spielt es keine Rolle mehr. Ein kleiner Moment aber dann will man doch diesen Typen wählen.
Leider rausgefallen ist Anthocyane jung und wir hören noch mal da wir das letzte Mal ja auch besprochen haben mit seiner Neuerfindung nicht nur von Politik sondern auch von politischen Kennziffern auf die man so hinarbeitet.
Diese Idee ist auch wieder sein allererster Aufschlag in dieser Debatte.
Diese Idee ist leider ersatzlos raus aus diesem Wahlkampf und es ist sehr sehr schade.
Die körperlos Academy ist eine werkte Talking dieser Genomik Manos Technologie.
Auf tausend Humans,
wackeln Cope Pfarrfest aber Piber heißt es.
Ich hatte die Marke Walking ins DDV GDP in Kruppe Kafitz of the crew,
Metallring den Brownies packen sie mental Freedom vom saubersten Training,
Hauer Kindsein Diving,
NY Schulminister Kapperl.
Hives.
Ja leider einfach ersatzlos gestrichen mit einem Prozent in New Hampshire.
Diesen technischen Aspekt.
Des politischen ökonomischen und.
Aber wir haben.
Technische Veränderungen uns viel mehr als politische Dinge.
Das hat der.
Wie das aussehen soll gesünder.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich bin skeptisch.
Im Grunde die gleiche Argumentation wie bei diesem grünen Deal diesen grünen Wandel Man zieht einfach neue Preise ein.
Neue Steuern und neue Kennziffern an die man sich dann auch halten muss man kann ja nicht nur über Preis,
Gestaltung im Sinne von Steuern Abschöpfungen und Subventionen eingreifen sondern auch wirklich über gesetzliche Regelungen die Ernährungs Ampel und so weiter die ja nun überall in Europa Erfolg hat außer in Deutschland wo sie erfolgreich raus lobbyiert wurde kann man ja einfach einführen.
Es gäbe schon Angriffspunkte und man darf halt nicht unterschätzen so sehr wie wir jetzt schon über sakral Herrschaft gesprochen haben weil nur Harari davor warnen,
rausgenommen und als nächstes kommt die Daten wieder rein und Demokratie wird nur eine kleine Episode von 200 Jahren Happiness sein aber auch kein großes Ding.
Dieses CDP Bruttoinlandsprodukt das wir so als Maßstab.
Aber das kann alles zur Disposition gestellt werden ist ja schon als Harari dabei,
damals noch beim IWF Lagarde saß und meinte sie erzählt nur Geschichten die alle glauben aber ökonomen sind halt trotzdem nur Geschichtenerzähler.
Diese Abkehr vom CDP wäre echt mal was gewesen. Allerdings nicht ob dafür jemals die Zeit ist dass man das überhaupt mal in so einer Debatte diskutiert.
Ein Thema ausgewählt das wirklich toll dass wir hier in der Stunde diskutieren könnten aber das funktioniert ja in diesem Modus überhaupt nicht.
Das Publikum hat nach jedem zweiten Satz.
Technik beeinflusst.
Erstaunlich dass er versucht in die Debatte rein zu bekommen das wäre,
bei der nächsten Runde Sahra Wagenknecht mal Marx Engels der Hoffnung dass es beim Zuschauer klick macht.
Aber wir wissen ja Wenn der Präsident erst mal gewählt ist und wahrscheinlich vielleicht ist es Neuer. Dann geht die große Sichtung los in unser Kabinett.
Solche Typen sind natürlich auch irgendwie finde ich. Warum gibt es da den einen oder anderen Posten zum amerikanischen Wahlkampf.
Ja wir haben es besprochen und dabei hat sich Bill Maher für eine ganz besondere Verabschiedung an Steve Bennett entschieden.
Andererseits sehe.
Ich wünschte wir hätten jemand so böse wie dich einen ordentlichen Wahlkampf macht und er hat es ein bisschen durchgespielt.
Es war nicht nur so eine Floskel sondern Bill Maher hat es ja mal durchgespielt und wir gucken wir uns kurz an denn es ist wirklich nicht schlecht Zum einen stellt sich ja die Frage Brauchen Demokraten nicht wirklich einfach mal schmutzigen Wahlkampf.
Um zu zeigen was er meinte hat er ein Werbeclip produziert. Wir kennen ja diese Werbung wo man den anderen einfach nur diffamiert die ganze Zeit.
Und jetzt hat er hier beispielhaft ein Werbeclip gegen Trump über Trump gemacht.
Brookes.
Nicht einmal besonders aufwendig produziert oder so sondern einfach nur manipulierte Zusammenschnitt mit schwarzen Bildern und so.
Aber ansonsten im Grunde gar nicht so schwer zu machen. Das fand ich auch interessant. Er hat.
Hat er Probleme mit seiner Prothese vielleicht kann es daran liegen,
dass er versucht etwas nach oben zu drücken aber er wird keine Prothese haben oder Zahnprothese. Es klingt so ein bisschen.
Keine Ahnung. Also keine Ahnung haben herausgerutscht in der Debatte. Es kann durchaus sein.
Ein bisschen nachlässt und dann wird es immer nach oben gedrückt. Man fragt sich aber bei diesen Gehaltsklasse sind da nicht eher Implantate im Spiel wo das gar keine Rolle spielt.
Das glaube ich mich auch. Es gab mal vom Spiegel ein Foto wie sie Trump so mit seinem Hund bei sich ein bisschen Trump abfotografiert haben.
Das ist beeindruckende Zähne einfach in Reih und Glied und ich glaube auch dass ist wenn man ordentlich rein geschraubten so da ist nichts irgendwie mit rein geklebt und abends muss das raus.
Naja zwei Sachen jedenfalls. Zum einen nämlich das war State of the Union und wir wissen ja dass es eigentlich eine sehr sakrale Angelegenheit und so weiter. Diesmal haben wir schon ein bisschen abweichend gesehen.
Aber was könnte man eigentlich machen bei so Gelegenheiten beispielsweise wenn Debatten anstehen.
Und er kommt hier auf macht eine kleine Erinnerung und sagt Das könnte man doch auch mal umdrehen.
Urins.
Warum nicht ehrlich gesagt.
Aber dieser Wahlkampf wäre dann sicherlich sehr amüsant.
Wäre dann,
sehr.
Und das wäre dann großes Entertainment aber das ist ja auch eine Aushöhlung der Demokratie im höchsten Maße. Wenn wir jetzt sagen dann können wir sie auch alle ins Dschungelcamp stecken und wir lassen die Zuschauer einfach mal anrufen und gucken was passiert.
Könnte sie mir das,
nicht ganz Es wäre noch im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten es gibt eine Debatte anberaumt wie die Alten aber man nutzt eben die Tickets die man hat für die eigene Zuschauerschaft anders als bisher.
Ja ja.
Das könnte man machen.
Wäre es nicht ein großer einfacher 20 Frauen da sitzen deren Geschichte dann auch sofort erzählt wird.
Ich glaube nicht dass Donald Trump das was ausmacht Nein ich glaube immer von unseren Maßstäben unangenehm.
Nein sagt sie.
Ich halte das für gut möglich dass er darüber hinweggeht.
Hier war allerdings dann prophetisch.
Präsident.
Obama.
Hier war ich ein bisschen überrascht dann ehrlich gesagt so wie du meintest ne sollte man nicht die Haltung wahren und so weiter. Das war ja vorher der State of the Jungle. Ich dachte sie werden wieder alle da sitzen.
Aber das ist eine Frage die man sich stellen kann ist jetzt das linke Spektrum nenne ich mal,
eines das für Ordnung und Höflichkeit einsteht denn wir wissen ja auch beispielsweise aus der Kunst oder auch von politischem Aktivismus der von links kam.
Das ist ja durchaus das Rebellische.
Sie sind ein Arschloch Herr Präsident all diese Geschichten überschreitungen von links die damals antibürgerliche waren,
die sich immer noch gern mal als Mitte oder bürgerlich beschreiben oft selbst sehr antibürgerliche äußerungen die äußerst unhöflich sind.
Ob wir jetzt in dieser Zeit eben genau das Gegenteil machen müssen für eine Höflichkeit,
verbietet sich so etwas. Oder müssen wir sagen,
dann müssen wir auch entsprechend aufrüsten und müssen das tun.
Das würde aber dann auch dazu führen dass man beispielsweise diskutiert Wie geht man dann mit den sozialen Medien um Wir hatten in den letzten Jahren eigentlich so eine Debatte wie,
schlimm was da so alles im Netz geschrieben wird wer da beleidigt wird und da muss man doch viel besser vorgehen können.
Ich kann dann aber wenn ich diese Argumentation übernehme auch fragen Brauchen wir vielleicht sogar mehr Hass im Netz aber jetzt von der anderen Seite kann man mir fragen.
Darauf werden wir gleich noch einmal zu sprechen kommen bei Mark Zuckerberg ist mehr. Besser kann mehr besser sein.
Also wenn du glaubst würde ich einfach mal deine Frage aufgreifen nämlich zu den Stielen und die 55 Sekunden dein eigenes Argument eins deine Argumente aus der Politik Analyse vorspielen.
Wenn du glaubst würde ich einfach mal auf.
Dein eigenes Argument eins deine Argumente.
Dem ich nämlich widersprechen würde.
Sprechen. So gespannt.
Also Wir hören hier das ist glaube ich die erste Jahr oder so kommt es nochmal genau zu Seibert.
Zur Bundespressekonferenz.
Auf Seibert zu sprechen und das Wort alternativlos fällt und wird wie gesagt anders sehen.
Das Schöne bei der Bundespressekonferenz ist ihr starres Korsett.
Es gibt also viele Normen und Regeln und die minimale Abweichung ist hier schon ein Ereignis,
wo wir ja außerhalb der Bundespressekonferenz einen politischen Diskurs erleben der immer mehr auf Provokation und überschreitung setzt.
Die formelle Sprache erlaubt es Seibert in der Rolle bleiben zu können.
Zwar bringt jeder Pressesprecher auch ein bisschen eigene Persönlichkeit mit hinein.
Aber als Mensch muss er eigentlich verschwinden was er persönlich denkt ist unerheblich.
Würde er das formelle sprechen verlassen dann hätte er ein großes Problem Er müsste so etwas sagen wie Ja ich weiß momentan auch nicht weiter. Ich habe auch schon gedacht Was macht die Merkel gerade.
Wahrscheinlich wird er das man sich mal denken. Aber er kann das nicht sagen weil das nicht seine Rolle ist.
Es gibt keine Alternative zu diesem sprechen.
Ich würde sagen doch es gibt eine Alternative.
Wie würde die aussehen.
Es dachten lange viele es gibt keine Alternative zu. Keine Ahnung wie sich Söder jetzt zum Beispiel drumrum arbeitet.
Eigentlich will ich schon Kanzler werden ich kann es aber nicht sagen aber was ich sagen kann ist die Rolle des CSU-Chefs und des Kanzlerkandidaten muss nicht in einer Person sein.
Dann werde ich ja ausgeschlossen. Ich kann nicht CDU-Chef werden ohne Rücksicht.
Eigentlich weiß man genau um was es hier geht. Und die Rolle des Regierungssprecher ist in diesem Falle genauso eine politische und die Alternative zu Seibert.
Ich mach einfach mal so einen Sprechakt und stellt sie damit zufrieden weil ich weiß es hat bisher immer funktioniert.
Ist ja nicht dass er dann plötzlich sagt dann weiß ich jetzt auch nicht weiter sondern er verheimlicht auch wirklich viel von dem was er weiß,
und es macht er ja aus Gründen weil er zum Beispiel nicht genau weiß zu welchen Konsequenzen das führt wenn er beispielsweise über die Rolle hinaus Sachen erklärt von denen er weiß Die führen zu Konsequenzen.
Und eigentlich ist das dann schon Merkels Aufgabe das zu machen damit ihr damit das Feedback zu ihr kommt und nicht zu ihm sondern er würde sich sozusagen anmaßen nicht nur für das Amt zu sprechen sondern das Amt zu sein und so weiter und so fort.
Aber trotzdem wenn man nicht so eine Format starre sehe wie bei ihm,
durch eine Format Starre wie bei Steffen Seibert bei LeFloid dem Politik YouTuber bei Ingo Zamperoni in den Tagesthemen und so weiter.
Dann glaube ich immer das ist Format starre aus Angst.
Nein da muss ich bei Zamperoni bei all diesen anderen Formaten gebe ich dir vollkommen recht.
Man kann auch sagen das Format gefällt mir.
Ich bin ja auch jemand der ein Der Film analysiert.
Das ist etwas anderes Wir haben hier einen Bürger der politische Ansichten hat,
jemand der ein Amt ausführt und der dieses Amt nicht mit seinen eigenen politischen Ansichten füllen darf.
Es gibt ja beispielsweise auch ganz viele Redenschreiber die sind in einer anderen Partei Ich kannte zum Beispiel einen Redenschreiber der SPD geschrieben ist selbst in der CDU.
Problemlos kann man seine eigenen politischen Ansichten selbstverständlich nicht reinbringen hat oft genug gedacht Was ist das für ein Idiot für den ich da gerade eine Rede Schreibe aber er wird gut bezahlt.
Merkel an sich gut sonst würde es nicht so lange machen. Das hat er ja auch immer wieder gesagt er findet das schon gut was er da macht aber er kann in diesem Amt nicht raus.
Er kann nicht anders darüber sprechen als in der Funktion.
Er ist eigentlich ganz arm dran.
Er würde vielleicht gerne oder er würde auch viel launiger reagieren würde unwirsch reagieren wollen.
Ich verstehe die Welt nicht mehr ich kann das auch nicht begreifen. Wir haben vor zwei Monaten noch gesagt Aber wissen Sie ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal von Merkel gesagt bekommen Du sagst das jetzt so und zwar nicht anders und mehr Infos gibst du nicht raus.
Das heißt er ist darin gefangen weil es sonst seinen Job kosten würde und weil er sich verpflichtet hat.
Er muss das so machen. Zugleich aber wissen wir alle.
Darin besteht die Chance Man kann ihn so wie das ja auch Hans bei der Bundespressekonferenz tun kitzeln.
Man kann versuchen dass er Dinge dann doch irgendwie sagen muss die er sich fest vorgenommen hat nicht zu sagen.
Wir erkennen aber auch an seinem Schweigen ob es wirklich nichts mehr dazu zu sagen gibt ob er es wirklich nicht weiß oder ob er doch noch was zu sagen hat.
Deswegen sehe ich eine sehr große Chance.
Ich will noch mal bei Angela Merkel zu sagen Angela Merkel ist Bundeskanzlerin.
Ist aber auch persönlich eine politische Bürgerin. Und sie hat auch noch einmal persönliche Ansichten.
Ich will zwei kurze Episoden nennen Merkel vor Publikum.
Es gab einmal eine Talkrunde da wurde sie auf die Ehe für alle angesprochen bevor die damals beschlossen wurde und dann sagte sie so etwas wie Ihr Bauchgefühl sagt dass das nicht gut ist.
Da hat sie nicht erkannt dass sie als Bundeskanzlerin spricht da hat sie irgendwie als persönliche Bürgerin gesprochen da kann man persönlich sagen Ich habe ja irgendwie ein schlechtes Bauchgefühl wenn zwei Männer heiraten oder,
aber als Kanzlerin muss sie eine Argumentation finden die einer Kanzlerin entsprechend ist und die hat sie in dem Moment nicht gefunden.
Dann gab es einen anderen Fall und zwar den mit dem Flüchtlingsmädchen Du erinnerst dich diese Runde wo das Mädchen gesagt hat Ja es könnte sein dass ich abgeschoben werde.
Und hier hatte Merkel ein sehr heikel Entfall denn sie war einmal als die Bundeskanzlerin da eine gewisse Art der Politik betreibt.
Ich will das jetzt gar nicht bewerten an dieser Stelle aber kann sie sagen dass die Politik die wir betreiben sieht vor dass in solchen Fällen auch Leute zurückgeführt werden in ihre Herkunftsländer.
Zugleich aber ist sie als Person dort gewesen als auch persönlich in irgendeiner Weise emotional involvierte die dann sagte ich will dich mal streicheln.
Das heißt sie hat sie persönlich reagiert und sie kann aber jetzt ganz schwer sagen.
Wissen Sie eigentlich wie der König im Mittelalter zwei Körper der eine ist mein politischer mein Amt und der andere ist mein persönlicher.
Ich persönlich finde das so schade dass du vielleicht nicht hier sein kann.
Aber als Kanzlerin setze ich diese Grenze durch. Das einzige Möglichkeit um diese Mätzchen zu helfen wäre gewesen.
Ja ich denke gerade noch einmal neu darüber nach und ich glaube wir müssen die Politik ändern dass alle Leute so wie du jetzt gerade so süß sind und weinend vor mir sitzen oder nicht bleiben dürfen. Das wäre was anderes.
Aber sie können weil sonst müsste sie sagen Ja die Politik bleibt aber hier. Das geht auch nicht.
Ja trotzdem finde ich Der Seibert nutzten sehr engen Spielraum den er sich selbst gegeben hat.
Zugegeben.
Und wir haben immer alle gedacht so ein amerikanischer Präsident da gelten ganz eigene Regeln schon bei jeder einzelne Anschlag irgendwie die Börsenkurse bewegt.
Und Trump hat ja nicht nur festgestellt dass es gar nicht so schlimm ist über die Stränge zu schlagen sondern dass man es auch noch instrumentell nutzen kann.
Eine doppelte sich noch selbst verstärkende Lernerfahrung da drin und ich würde grundsätzlich unterstellen die solche ämter haben wie Seibert oder so dass das immer geht.
Dass es da keine Alternativlosigkeit gibt sondern dass man allenfalls mit der,
Unwissenheit über die Konsequenzen eine gewisse Unsicherheit bedeutet dass man vermeiden möchte dass es da eine Vermeidungsstrategien gibt das würde ich jedem zugestehen.
Man segelt lieber einfach durch den Alltag statt abends nochmal mit hoffentlich morgen früh da hat man Angst vorm Termin weil man muss sich dann so erklären.
Aber ich glaube Trump hat allen gelernt dass es ein großes Instrumentalist Potenzial anderen politischen Sprechens gibt und auch andere Möglichkeiten Wahlvolk zu mobilisieren.
Also ich glaube da steckt eine sehr große Lernerfahrung und.
Bei einem Regierungssprecher war bei Politikern auf jeden Fall.
Ich bin mal gespannt wenn die tatsächlich mal einen grünen Kanzler bekommen kriegen wir auch eine andere Ansprache von aus solchen Gremien Es wird dann einfach anders.
Ich finde ich finde ja offizielle Ansprachen sehr angenehm weil ich sofort weiß wo der potenzielle Gegner sitzt.
Genau aber das macht es eben auch langweilig.
Ich stelle ja aber ich stelle mir jetzt vor Ich habe dort jemanden sitzen wie aus diesem Einhorn unternehmen. So lustig flockig mit mir da reden und dann gehts.
Da kommt ja noch Inkompetenz dazu.
Aber dann geht es trotzdem um Drogenpolitik. Das finde ich viel schwieriger als wenn da jemand mit bitterer Miene zur Drogenpolitik habe ich mich hinreichend geäußert. Herr Jung.
Ja es ist schon Gefahr der Offenbarung von Inkompetenz dabei.
Wir haben in der Soziologie dieses Argument so sprechen wie Seibert Das ist im Grunde kompetente kompetent das Verbergen von Inkompetenz Inkompetenz Compensation Kompetenz so wird es dann genannt.
Im Grunde versucht man semantisch die eine oder andere strukturelle Lücke zu überdecken indem man einfach so ein Satz baut in dem die Substantive der Frage nicht nochmal vorkommen damit es nicht zitierfähig ist und dann auch,
nach 30 Sekunden Antwort zu zum Punkt zu kommen und das auch anzuzeigen,
sich alles aus der Nase ziehen zu lassen aber man könnte auch instrumentell und anders damit umgehen und ich bin mal gespannt.
Ich glaube in Deutschland ist man so ein bisschen eingeschlafen über 15 Jahre Merkel und man wird sehr überrascht sein wenn Leute die sich professionell mit so einem sprechend beschäftigen noch einmal andere Möglichkeiten finden und auch nutzen.
Ich glaube es wird große überraschungen geben.
Schon allein Merz Ja. Merz als Bundeskanzler.
Ich glaube das wird ein bisschen anders ablaufen auch was die Sprache angeht Ich bin bei sowas.
Ich glaube man darf nicht Merkel dazu sehr auf den Leim gehen.
Merkel ist da viel mehr zu kritisieren weil sie eben nicht alternativlos ist. Das ist vielleicht der eigentliche Punkt.
Das würde ich ganz klar unterstreichen. Sie kann nicht als Privatperson sprechen oder sollte sie nicht tun.
Da gibt es eben diesen Konflikt. Aber es gibt auch ein anderes sprechen.
Aber wenn ich überleiten da.
Nämlich dann wenn im Bundestag über das debattiert wird was abends in der Tagesschau stattfinden wird was vielleicht mal stattfinden wird.
Die Debatten in Deutschland beherrschen wird was nicht dazu führt dass die Talkshows nur noch darüber reden was keinen Brennpunkt produziert sondern wenn es grundsätzlich,
eine Debatte herausgesucht zusammengeschnitten im Bundestag am 31.
Januar ging es darum dass es einen Antrag gab den Grünen und Linken es ging um die ächtung von sogenannten Robotern also automatisierten Waffensystemen.
An dieser Debatte,
bezieht sich jetzt nicht einfach die Bundeskanzlerin gesagt.
Man braucht auch noch andere Autoritäten sein Argument zu unterstreichen.
Nochmal ein. Es ist eine Debatte die auf eine Entscheidung hinführt oder eine Aktuelle Stunde oder.
Dass es dafür eine Mehrheit gab wenngleich man sich in irgendeiner Weise einig darüber ist dass das eine große Gefahr sein könnte.
Dazu müssen wir erst mal in diese Debatte rein und ich habe immer nur ein kurzes Stück Wir machen aber auch zwischendurch Pause.
Die Aussprache und erteile als erste Rednerin der Kollegin Katja Keul Bündnis 90 Die Grünen das Wort.
Aufgrund der hohen Geschwindigkeit dieser automatisierten Abläufe können Konfliktsituationen unnötig eskalieren wenn keine ausreichende menschliche Kontrolle existiert.
Denn auch die sogenannte künstliche Intelligenz macht Fehler das Militär verliert immer mehr Entscheidungsmacht an Private IT-Konzerne und letztlich verstößt es gegen die Menschenwürde,
wenn ein Menschenleben zum Objekt einer maschinellen Entscheidung wird die Risiken.
Die Risiken liegen also auf dem Tisch und 28 Staaten haben sich inzwischen für förmliche Vertragsverhandlungen und eine völkerrechtlich bindende Konvention ausgesprochen.
Leider gehört dazu nicht die Bundesregierung obwohl die ächtung voll autonomer Waffensysteme sogar im Koalitionsvertrag steht.
Der Spielraum für sinnvolle Regeln schwindet zunehmend das erforderliche Maß an menschlicher Kontrolle muss definiert sein bevor ein Waffensystem überhaupt Design.
War die Abgeordnete der Grünen die nochmal darauf hinweist dass viele Länder eigentlich auch im Koalitionsvertrag steht aber die große Koalition.
IT-Konzerne immer mehr Macht bekommen und deren Algorithmen ja dann vielleicht einmal entscheiden könnten.
Sie weist darauf hin dass es zu spät sein könnte irgendwann wenn man nicht rechtzeitig reagiert und sagt Bis hierhin und nicht weiter.
Was mir auffällt wenn diese Argumentation kommt ist sie ja immer gleich der Roboter entscheidet.
Ist sie immer gleich der Roboter entscheidet. Aber in dieser Einführung steckt er auch dass man überhaupt erst ermöglicht dass man neu darüber entscheiden kann.
In dieser Einführung dieser Technologie steckt ja auch das Phänomen dass man überhaupt erst ermöglicht dass man neu darüber entscheiden kann wer denn getötet werden könnte.
Wir werden.
Also es gibt plötzlich Möglichkeiten die es vorher nicht gab und das ist auch bei diesem Fall so eine Drohne fliegt gleich dahin.
Ja auch bald eine Drohne fliegt gleich dahin.
Klar die wird in dem Fall noch von einem Piloten gesteuert und er drückt ab und so weiter.
Ab und bei der Drohne als Akteur möglich da die vorher nicht OA sozusagen die Autonomie gerät von Gerät selbst.
Aber allein die Drohne als Technik als Akteur ermöglichte Tötung die vorher nicht möglich war.
Also noch bevor sozusagen die Autonomie ins Gerät kommt ist das Gerät selbst schon so würde ich allein dadurch dass es diesen möglich und Handlungsbereitschaft des Krieges so weit verschiebt.
Würde ich allein dadurch dass möglich und Handlungsbereitschaft soweit,
die Dame von der CDU Mandala die sieht das jetzt anders. Erwartungsgemäß Wir hören uns das mal an.
Die Dame von der CDU hat das jetzt anders.
Die der CDU CSU-Fraktion.
Sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe Kollegen und Kolleginnen den Kern der heutigen Debatte bildet die Frage ob wir uns den technologischen Fortschritt im Bereich der Wehrtechnik kategorisch verschließen wollen oder nicht.
Ja vielleicht mal bis dahin. Man möchte sich ins Bett legen und nicht mehr aufstehen automatisch eine.
Ärgert es Sie,
wenn wir die automatische Drohne abschaffen das hieße ja auch dass wir die elektronische Kasse am Supermarkt abschaffen weil sie ja beides Technologie.
Argumentation die immer wiederkehren. Ich habe die nicht immer reingebracht. Ich wollte nicht dass wir zu viele doppelte Argumente haben aber auch andere so argumentieren Kühlschrank und.
Allerdings.
Allerdings Sie schließt damit an ein discours Geschichte an die in der Friedensbewegung tatsächlich sehr auf Technikfeindlichkeit basierte.
Grundsätzlich kann es auch von der anderen Seite eine Technik grundsätzlich ab weil man sie eben auch für Krieg benutzen kann da es in Deutschland sehr viel schiefgelaufen.
Wir als Union haben hierzu eine klare Haltung Wir stehen zu einem verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit neuen militärischen Technologien im Rahmen des geltenden humanitären Völkerrechts.
Selbst wenn wir der möglichen Anwendung bestimmter bereits vorhandener oder künftiger Technologien kritisch gegenüberstehen so müssen wir doch in der Lage sein diese zu beherrschen.
Und dies betrifft sowohl den Bereich der Künstlichen Intelligenz als auch den der autonomen Waffensysteme.
Man muss auch wenn man nicht dafür ist wenn man das nicht macht wegen Völkerrecht Menschenrechte und so weiter sie dennoch beherrschen können.
Man muss auch wenn man nicht dafür ist nicht.
Weiter die dennoch,
kann man natürlich politisch ausbauen das Argument das was die Russen und die Sowjets die Sowjets und die Chinesen da aufbauen das müssen wir doch auch beherrschen können auch wenn wir es selbst ablehne.
Ja wir bauen das alles hier auf Wir könnten es dann auch machen aber wir lassen es dann abgeschaltet.
Wir müssen ja verstehen womit wir es nicht zu tun haben.
Die Forschung zu zivilen wie zu militärischen Zwecken sollte nicht gesondert betrachtet werden sondern gemeinsam und als Einheit.
Grün oder links. Lesen Sie mal die Physiker,
von Friedrich Dürrenmatt handelt davon dass dort drei Physiker in der Irrenanstalt sind die haben die Weltformel,
Weltformel aber das ist ein Symbol dafür wie man die Welt vernichten kann oder total beherrschen kann es geht,
um die Atombombe.
Physiker ist das die Weltformel in der Irrenanstalt bleibt und nicht nach draußen dringt.
Und sie versuchen mit allen Mitteln.
Diese an sich reißt und damit die Physiker in der Irrenanstalt sodass die Weltformel hinausgeht.
Es ist aus Einstein. Die Welt ist in die Hände einer verrückten ärztin gefallen.
Moebius was einmal gedacht wurde kann nicht mehr zurückgenommen werden.
Diese Idee wird ganz kurz.
Vor allem wenn man an Technik denkt dann hat man dieses dual use Argument.
Was sie da irgendwie ansprach Wir können ja nicht eine Grenze ziehen und sagen Das ist mal nicht weiter so. Und,
dann hat man es halt entweder mit einer unbegrenzten Quelle für Energie zu tun oder hat mit der Zerstörung der ganzen Welt oder vielleicht mit einem Unfall und dann hat die gute Technologie trotzdem alle halb Tokio zerstört.
Zum Schluss. Letztendlich geht es immer um den Schutz unserer Soldaten und Soldatinnen. Herzlichen Dank.
Ein Argument das wir von den Drohnenkrieg.
Das ist ein Argument das sehr gut analysiert wird von einem Autor dem wir heute schon mal erwähnt haben und zwar,
nicht nur über den autoritären Liberalismus geschrieben sondern eine Theorie der Drohne entwickelt.
Das Buch heißt ferngesteuerte Gewalt ist im Passagen Verlag erschienen.
Und da kommt er auf diese Argumentation zu sprechen und dann sagt er die,
Risikoaversion eine Vielzahl solcher Ausdrücke tauchte Ende der 1990er Jahre in den Vereinigten Staaten gehäuft auf um dieselbe Idee zu bezeichnen jene einer tendenziellen Unterordnung,
der Anwendung militärischer Gewalt unter einen politischen Imperativ der Erhaltung nationaler Soldatenleben.
Das Spezifikum der zeitgenössischen imperialen Gewalt ist weniger die Asymmetrie der Kräfte und die ungleiche Verteilung der Verwundbarkeit die sich daraus ergibt. Ein klassisches Merkmal aller.
Art von Normen die nunmehr die Bedingungen ihrer Ausübung für die in Anführungszeichen demokratischen westlichen Großmächte bilden wenn es eine Neuerung gibt dann ist sie hier zu suchen,
die praktische quasi Unverwundbarkeit des dominierenden Lagers gegen Ende des 20.
Jahrhunderts an und für sich als herrschende ethisch politische Norm etabliert wird das Soldatenleben ist das was letztendlich,
die Sicherheit der Soldaten das wichtigste wo man ja sagen kann.
Eigentlich sind ja Soldaten nicht Zivilisten in einen Krieg involviert sind sondern Soldaten kämpfen gegen Soldaten.
Wir haben jetzt eine Technik die dafür sorgt dass wir unglaublich viele tote Zivilisten haben.
Das nimmt man billigend als Kollateralschaden in Kauf weil man argumentiert immer noch besser als wenn ein Soldatenleben dadurch zu Schaden kommen könnte.
Da steckt ja auch so paradox drin. Zu sagen Wir ziehen jetzt in den Krieg und die Aufgabe dort ist dann die eigenen Soldaten zu schützen.
Der beste Schutz wäre es gar nicht den Krieg zu gehen ja auch diese deutsche Argumentation warum sind wir in Afghanistan um Ausbildungsmission zu finden aber an unserem Stützpunkt statt um unsere Soldaten auf unserem Stützpunkt zu schützen sind wir an diesem Krieg beteiligt.
In der Soziologie gibt's ja auch immer dieses Argument wenn wir vom Krieg reden ist das ja die Vorstufe ist ja der Konflikt irgendwie und Konflikte generalisieren übernehmen ja so plötzlich alles.
Und in diesen wissenschaftlichen Aufarbeitung des Zweiten Weltkriegs aber vor allem auch so Korea-Krieg und so weiter.
Aber die Frage Warum hat Amerika das so lange mitgemacht wohl wissend dass es irgendwie politisch verloren nichts zu gewinnen Heimatfront ist vorbei. Die muss man belügen damit es noch gut ausgeht.
Und dann kam eben diese funktionale Analyse die einfach ganz klar gesagt hat naja solange die Soldaten noch im Zug sind hinfahren gehts ums Vaterland aber sobald der erste Schuss gefallen ist will man nur seine Kameraden rächen. Und dann entscheidet,
die Situation auf dem Platz selbst darüber und diese Kameradschaft die da so eine Rolle spielt die schlägt sich dann halt auch wieder so eine Argumentation im Bundestag wieder wo ich denke da gehört sie aber eigentlich nicht.
Wenn wir Menschen in den Krieg schicken oder wenn Schlecker Geld investiert müssen sie damit rechnen dass das Risiko aktualisiert wird und das kein Return on Investment ist und dass dort Soldaten sterben.
Soldaten damit rechnen müssen dass sie sterben können. Im Gefecht ist das ein besonderer Beruf. Nicht nur.
Genau. Deswegen ist das ein besonderer Beruf und deswegen sind das eben nicht nur Zivilisten in Uniform auch wenn man sich das politisch wünscht das ist eine besondere Berufswahl dass man es so salopp allerdings in den Bundestag dann hört finde ich dann wieder.
Dass man hört dann wieder.
Dafür ist einfach zu. Dafür erwarte ich einfach zuviel soziologische Aufklärung grundsätzlich als dass ich das in so einer Debatte so durchgehen lassen würde.
Dafür ist einfach zu. Dafür erwarte ich einfach umzusetzen.
Ja ja wir machen weiter.
Aber die Soldaten die in diesen Streitkräften dienen und Deutschland mit ihrem Leben verteidigen die stehen doch vor allem deshalb dazu bereit weil Deutschland ein Land ist für dessen Ideale und Werte es sich zu kämpfen lohnt.
Ich glaube das ist ein Diskurs der hier reinkommt wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr glaubt.
Es gibt ja solche Umfragen. Ein Bekannter erzählte bei der Bundeswehr dass man in solchen Teams immer mal wieder bei solchen Seminaren Fragebögen hat wofür man bereit ist zu sterben.
Es sei wirklich eine verschwindend geringe manchmal gegen Null tendieren der Anzahl von Leuten die für ihr Land. Und dann kommt eigentlich nur noch aus dem Umkreis.
Für die Kameraden kommt es dann meistens für die Familie für meine Freundin oder sowas.
Ist etwas was hier eingeführt wird was ein alter Patriotismus ist der funktioniert.
Sobald der Krieg läuft,
finde ich ganz okay einen Typ aber sobald der Krieg läuft ist halt anders. Was auch immer wieder auffällt.
Wir haben das letzte Mal beim Auto dieses lange Stück Freudscher gegen Merz Vielleicht hängen wir heute als Auto einfach mal fünf oder sechs Minuten.
Frank-Walter Steinmeier der bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz hintendran denn er macht dieses Argument.
Wir Deutsche haben uns lange genug darauf ausgeruht ein besonderes Land zu sein.
Besonders Verteidigung Werte zu haben immer recht zu haben. Am meisten aus Auschwitz gelernt zu haben und so weiter.
Es ist aber nicht so stellte er als Bundespräsident einfach mal in den Raum vor allem an die Deutschen adressiert aber mit internationalen Publikum. Es ist nicht so wenn jemand Verantwortung sagt heißt das nicht gleich Krieg sondern es ist eine Vorstufe der Diplomatie.
Und da braucht es einfach ein neues Gefühl und ich fand es sehr auf der Höhe der Zeit passt vielleicht ganz gut weil das widerspricht eben dieser Idee die wir hier von der AfD gehört haben fundamental dass man einfach sagt Der Krieg muss sein.
Und wenn dann doch machen wir guten deutschen weil da irgendwie am meisten herumkommt.
Aber er hat seine Probleme mit den Drogen. Denn das ist selbstverständlich nicht vereinbar mit einem solch heroischen Patriotismus.
Und damit das so bleibt dürfen wir niemals zulassen dass Maschinen in unserem Namen Menschenleben auf Datensätze reduzieren und dann über deren Auslöschung entscheiden selbstständig agierende Killer Roboter lehnen wir ganz klar.
Aber die vorliegenden Anträge werden auch der Komplexität der Lage nicht gerecht.
Denn zunächst mal ich habe es schon angedeutet ist ja gar nicht klar was die verschiedenen Antragsteller den unter autonomen Waffensystemen eigentlich versteht.
Immer wieder mal vorgeworfen dass entsprechende was,
entsprechende der Entschluss die Waffe zu bedienen zu schießen.
Der Sucher arbeitet autonom also wie bei einer Kamera auch die Kamera fotografiert fokussiert automatisch,
ein Foto zu machen. Das gilt auch für Waffen.
Als hätte er selbst in der Bundeswehr Karriere.
Ja ich glaube schon. Ich glaube schon.
Der Kollege Dr. Karl-Heinz Brunner SPD-Fraktion.
Es muss uns gelingen diese Waffen zu ächten und zwar schon bevor sie eingesetzt werden.
Außenpolitik heißt meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen sich mit anderen Menschen wieder anderen Ländern mit anderen Vorstellungen auseinanderzusetzen.
Es ist schlimm wie viel wie viel Nationalismus wie viel Egoismus und Kurzsichtigkeit hier in der Zwischenzeit herrscht.
Umso trauriger ist es dass ausgerechnet Grüne und Linke uns offensichtlich in der gleichen Rolle sehen wollen Sie fordern dass wir ohne Einbeziehung unserer Verbündeten ohne unseren langjährigen Partnern eigenmächtig voran Bretten so quasi German führst.
Auf europäischer Ebene sondern auf weltweiter Ebene.
Eine Vorreiterrolle in ethischen Standards.
Wie kompliziert.
Man könnte ja,
nur weil man,
gewisse Dinge.
Auf.
Der ganzen Welt.
Im Koalitionsvertrag gemacht hat.
Was ich aber ganz gut finde ist zu sagen wenn wir uns der Technik nicht ganz verweigern wollen weil wir irgendwie eine Ahnung davon haben dass es sowieso nicht gelingt.
Dann überlassen wir doch wenigstens nicht dem Nationalstaat sondern binden irgendwie was weiß ich.
Nato oder je nachdem was Europa da noch,
für eine Idee hat wie man so eine Verteidigung regelt dann bitten wir es wenigstens dahin weiter dass man eine Union damit wir nicht gegenseitig einen Krieg machen wir die Kriegstechnik voneinander abhängig irgendwie und wer weiß.
Dr. Magistrale SP-Fraktion.
Ich möchte mich deshalb schnell auf ein Thema konzentrieren zu dem sie ja auch drei Anträge gestellt haben nämlich der Autonomie in Waffensystems seit den 80er Jahren beispielsweise bei der Luftverteidigung.
Das ist in der Lage autonom fliegende Raketen abzuschießen.
Es schützt damit unser Land schützt auch uns Soldaten im Einsatz. Das möchte ich nicht ächten. Das möchte ich auch nicht verbieten.
Das ist sehr sinnvoll und das möchte ich erhalten.
Und es werden zusätzlich weitere Waffen im Zuge der Digitalisierung selbstständiger autonomer werden.
Das hat Technik heutzutage so an sich das gilt auch für den Kühlschrank der in Zukunft Lebensmittel bestellen kann.
Das gilt auch für einen Fernseher der heute andere Funktionen hat als vor 20 Jahren.
Das wird auch für Waffen gelten. Wichtig ist hier deswegen dass wir Autonomie nicht per se verteufeln sondern dass wir sagen Was darf denn nicht autonom sein,
Ziel Auswahl darf nicht autonom sein Ziel Bekämpfung darf nicht autonom sein.
Herumdrehen das Argument hier schreibt keine Wunschliste Wir schreiben die Wunschliste.
Autonom agierende Kühlschränke mehr gebaut werden.
Besser vorbereitet.
Cathrin.
Dürfen wir die Entscheidung über Leben und Tod einer Maschine einem Algorithmus anvertrauen.
Ich sage dazu Nein.
Der Schriftsteller hat schon 1942 erkannt dass es künstliche Intelligenz eine eigene Ethik braucht.
Sein erstes Roboter Gesetz lautete das zitiere ich Ein Roboter darf kein menschliches Wesen verletzen oder durch Untätigkeit zulassen dass einem menschlichen Wesen Schaden zugefügt wird.
Aber heute werden Killer Roboter entwickelt deren eigentlicher Zweck es ist menschlichen Wesen Schaden zuzufügen.
In den USA in Russland in China in Großbritannien in Israel und in Südkorea.
Der Rüstungswettlauf ist schon in vollem Gange. Und da müssen wir doch handeln.
Diese unheilvolle Entwicklung kann nur gestoppt werden durch ein Verbot.
Und das ist die Meinung von 160 internationalen Nichtregierungsorganisationen in der Kampagne für das Verbot von Killer Robotern.
Über 60 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung unterstützen diese Forderung Mehr als 4500 Experten unterstützen ein völlig völkerrechtlich Verbindendes bin und völkerrechtlich bindendes Verbot.
Und auch die Bundesregierung unterstützt das ja eigentlich nur Australien Israel Russland Südkorea und die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika blockieren jeden Schritt hin zu einer Beschränkung dieser Hochtechnologie.
Asimov Roboter Asimov Roboter beinhaltet neun Erzählungen die er in den 40er Jahren geschrieben hat.
Da geht es um die Ethik von künstlichen Intelligenzen und ich habe diese Gesetze mal mitgebracht.
Ein Roboter darf keinen Menschen verletzen oder durch Untätigkeit zu Schaden kommen lassen.
Ein Roboter muss ein Roboter muss den Befehlen der Menschen.
Es sei denn solche Befehle stehen im Widerspruch zum ersten Gesetz.
Ein Roboter muss seine eigene Existenz schützen solange sein Handeln nicht dem Gesetz widerspricht.
Dass er keinen Menschen verletzt und nicht durch Untätigkeit jemandem zu schaden kommen lassen kann,
einen Menschen keinen Menschen lautet folgendermaßen Ein Roboter darf die Menschheit nicht verletzen oder durch Passivität zulassen dass die Menschheit zu Schaden kommt.
Hier haben wir jetzt einen Konflikt der uns wahrscheinlich begleiten wird.
Man sagt ja das stimmt,
aber wenn man das anwendet auf Ciller Roboter dann sagt man Ja wir retten die Menschheit zum Beispiel vor den bösen Terroristen,
Roboter töten,
Zivilisten darunter. Aber wir tun alles im Namen der Menschheit.
Wer hat nochmal gesagt Wer Menschheit sagt lügt.
Carl Schmitt.
Also Wer Menschheit sagt lügt Menschheit ist halt eine Chiffre.
Vollzeitbeschäftigte. Ja genau. Wir haben ja auch.
Wir wissen nicht genau wie. Wir haben ja auch diese komische Formulierung Menschlichkeit ja Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit wo es eigentlich gegen die Menschheit gemeint ist.
In der Hinsicht ist es ja wenn es das Null der Gesetze ist dann sind natürlich alle anderen so ein bisschen schlampig schwammig und schlampig denn wer entscheidet darüber wo Menschen Menschheit aufhört und endet.
Wie,
alle anderen,
entscheidet darüber Ende.
In welchen Kategorien wir Menschheit und Menschen unterscheiden. Richtig.
Und wer sie gerade vertritt. Sind es dann die die die gerade die Killer Roboter haben oder die die sie nicht haben.
Yuval Harari herausholte. Ein schönes Zitat wie er sagt Ich habe jetzt keine Angst vor Robotern die selbstständig entscheiden.
Ich habe Angst vor Räubern die dem Menschen gehorchen.
Er dreht das genau um. Da will ich auch sagen Solange wir Roboter haben die autonom entscheiden also klar autonom und wir wissen nicht genau selbst lernen was genau funktioniert.
So ein Schalter ist doch irgendwie dabei und man kann so ein bisschen damit.
Aber sobald man einen Algorithmus hat der extern nochmal so und das ist die Menschheit und das ist ein Mensch und jetzt mache ich mal eine Abwägung von außen mitbekommen da hat man eben genau dieses Dilemma,
das man in so einer unkontrollierten Sphäre plötzlich hat.
Aber wir sehen hier. Man beruft sich auf Science-Fiction-Literatur um das deutlich zu machen.
Aber ich hätte mir gewünscht dass sie das im Bundestag ein bisschen ausführt also solche Dilemmas statt da so weinerlich sage ich jetzt mal so Ich habe ja auch die 99 lungert gesagt.
Ja ja ja ja man muss es so sagen ja,
ja ja genau.
Es gibt so gute funktionale Argumente mit denen man das halt wirklich herunterbrechen kann.
Ja
Sie hätte besser die Gesetze also die drei plus erläutert.
Warum nicht. Warum nicht.
Das wäre ganz schön. Wir hören uns noch zwei kurze Ausschnitte an.
Redner ist der Kollege Nicolas Löwl ECDC.
Wenn wir uns ehrlich machen dann ist klar dass wir Weiterentwicklung Innovation auch im Bereich der Sicherheitsarchitektur nicht ausschließen können schon alleine wegen demografischen Gründen auch in unserer Bundeswehr. Aber.
Ehrlich machen.
Das Argument dass wir natürlich extra für dich reingebracht habe wie wir das denn er sagt mehr dazu nicht das ist wirklich dieser Halbsatz den er fast verschluckt.
Auch wegen der demografischen Gründe in der Bundeswehr heißt das,
Die demografische Entwicklung in Deutschland ist so dass wir bald nicht mehr vitale Soldatinnen und Soldaten vorfinden die überhaupt in Einsätze marschieren können und deswegen müssen wir die Roboter machen während wir wie,
in so einem Sessel sitzen der auf der,
Las Vegas Messe vorgestellt wurde da hat es uns ja den Austritt gebracht. Ist das Argument.
Ich war total. Ich hab gedacht habe ich das gerade gehört. Nachwuchssorgen bedingen dass wir die Roboter brauchen.
Da muss man echt mal sagen Die Nachwuchssorgen der Bundeswehr sind nicht dass wir zu wenig Kämpfer haben sondern wir haben zu wenig Ausbilder Brunnenbau und so weiter Leute die irgendwas absichern. Es ist nicht der Kampf.
Das sind allerdings Aufgaben. Da geht es um Arbeit am Klienten nämlich dem Auszubildenden und so weiter und dem Lehrer die kann man gar nicht an eine Maschine auslagern.
Jedenfalls würden wir das hier auch nicht in einer deutschen Schule oder so machen.
Da fällt dieses ganze Argument schon mal grundsätzlich flach. Wofür brauchen wir eigentlich Soldaten für den Kampf.
Das ist bei der Bundeswehr nun wirklich ein verschwindend geringer Teil des Bundeswehrsoldaten Mein Kampf ist so ein Roboter wieder dazu ein mehr zu machen weil man es kann.
Aber die Demografie ist natürlich auch interessant in dem Maße wie wir noch Soldaten haben die allerdings in der Leitungsebene aufstiegen aufsteigen,
sodass wir auch ein demografisches Problem Wir haben sehr wenig Kinder und von den wenigen machen aber unglaublich viele Abitur und sind nicht bereit für die üblichen Handwerks arbeiten wo er wirklich mal Material von A nach B getragen werden muss und sowas.
Und das schlägt sich natürlich in der Bundeswehr auch wieder wenn nun nur noch Offiziere hast aber keinen Nachwuchs mehr.
Dann fällt halt das ganze Ding auseinander Ja die werden immer beauftragt mit irgendwelchen Sachen und schieben sich aber selber Rest Soldaten hin und her.
Auf der anderen Seite. Ich finde es absolut richtig dass er das so betonen denn jedes Mal wenn wir jetzt Beispiel hören wir haben Pfleger mangelt es 8 000 Pfleger muss man überlegen.
Reicht es diesen Beruf attraktiver zu machen oder haben wir grundsätzlich nicht das Problem dass es noch sehr viel andere Berufe gibt bevor man sich entscheidet Pflegeberuf zu machen werden die anderen doch auch aufwachen und ihre Berufe attraktiver machen.
Also wir haben sie ja mit einem Nachwuchssorgen Problem zu haben wo die Demografie einfach jede politische Anstrengung schlägt.
Es wird diese Soldaten einfach nie geben genau wie es diese Pfleger in 100 Jahren wo sie gebraucht werden. Die wird es niemals geben.
Du glaubst doch nicht mit sehr viel höheren Löhnen gibts ja ganz konkrete Forderungen von Alexander Jordan der ja da Vorstellungen hat wie der Pflegeberuf aussehen könnte.
Denn seine Argumentation ist ja auch dass er grundsätzlich schon attraktiv ist.
Es ist nicht so dass Leute ja nichts anderes wissen was sie machen sollen oder nichts finden,
werden sondern es gibt schon welche die sehr bewusst und mit Freuden eigentlich entscheiden aber dann so schlechte Bedingungen vorziehen dass sie eher einen Job annehmen,
ihnen weniger Freude bringt oder weniger Erfüllung bringt aber dafür dann eben ein Einkommen und auch eine sonstige berufliche Situation,
die angenehmer lebenswerter ist.
Ja sagt zum einen die Arbeitsbedingungen bis hin zur Bezahlung müssen besser sein.
Aber auch dieser Beruf muss professionalisiert werden. Wir werden künftig mehr Pflegestufen bekommen derzeit sind es ja hauptsächlich körperliche Leiden.
Kommt er dann demnächst auch wirklich geistiges leiden dazu. Demenz das steht ja alles an.
Und das ist einfach grundsätzlich das Problem. Wenn du diesen Ausbildungsberuf. Sagen wir mal universitär gestaltet,
hat man beispielsweise in Jena damals die Erfahrung gemacht Wenn die Medizinstudenten die so gerne am Menschen arbeiten und so weiter helfen wollen mit ihrem Medizinstudium beginnen machen sie erst einmal vier Semester lang irgendwelche Theorie und so.
Und dann im fünften Semester gehen die an die Leichen und dann fehlen einfach 25 Prozent weil sie einfach sagen Ach so Methoden keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht ist mir doch zu viel koerper. Ich wusste nicht dass ich so viel mit Toten zu tun habe und dieses Problem das sozusagen über den Ausbildungsweg,
offenbar ist was das eigentlich für ein Beruf ist und mit welchen Problemlagen zu tun ist wird auch sehr viele Leute abschrecken.
Also umso mehr das professionalisiert wird um so weniger durchlaufe hast du von Leuten die du einfach ein Jahr lang in diesem Beruf hast als Einstieg und die dann.
Ausgebrannt hätte aussteigen sollen die Leute kommen gar nicht erst in den Beruf Sie sind schon in der Ausbildung sozusagen abgeschreckt und es droht in der Pflege eben auch weil diese Geschichten nun wirklich gruselig.
In Deutschland findet ja 80 Prozent der Pfleger privat statt und das heißt sehr oft dass irgendwelche Schwiegertöchter alte Männer pflegen zu denen sie gar nicht so die emotionale Bindung haben aber die haben plötzlich Demenz schreien die an die schreien zurück.
Es entsteht Hass. Dieser Hass schlägt sich nieder auf die ganze Familie. Eine totale Zerrüttung.
Diese Pflege Pflicht die du dann da halt wirklich nicht drum rum kommst und in Japan gibts jetzt die Bemühungen da.
Ich dann Rentner Republique auch ausfiele Ich schreibe weil das wirklich schlimm ist.
In Japan gibts mittlerweile Richter die sich nur um die Fälle kümmern wenn Kinder ihre Eltern töten um dieses Leiden loszuwerden weil da sehr viel mehr juristische Gnade.
Mittlerweile kann sich alle Leute einfach ins Gefängnis stecken da finden einfach so viele Mordfälle in dem Sinne die unter Erlösung Gesichtspunkt behandelt werden müssen statt dass da wirklich ein anderes Gefüge insgesamt hast.
Man muss halt einfach sagen bei solchen Sachen Soldaten Pflegeberuf und so weiter.
Diese Nachwuchssorgen werden niemals befriedigt. Die kann man politisch formulieren Man kann Forderungen stellen Man kann Programme schreiben wie man das regeln will aber dieses Problem wird niemals lösbar sein.
Eine massive Einwanderung.
Ja
Pflegeberufen.
Aber auch dafür.
Brauchst du ein attraktives Land erst mal grundsätzlich das du einmal einen willst und da Deutschland gar nicht so attraktiv wie die alle glauben und das verschlimmert sich.
Es ist für uns als CDU CSU klar es gibt Grenzen und es muss Grenzen des Einsatzes von Krieg geben.
Ich bin sehr dankbar dass er darauf hingewiesen hat dass es wichtig ist zu definieren wo wir keinen Einsatz von KTI wollen.
Es bringt uns nicht pauschal die Debatte und die Forschung und die Entwicklung zu verbieten sondern wir müssen wissen was möglich ist um dann zu sagen wo wir es nicht eingesetzt haben wollen.
Aber klar ist Auch wer wissen will welche Innovation welche technologischen Erneuerungen möglich sind der muss selbst forschen der muss entwickeln der muss mit dem gewonnenen Wissen Wissen wie man Missbrauch verhindern.
Darum dass man forschen muss um das zu wissen Das ist ja auch ein Argument gewesen als man die Atomkraftwerke vom Netz nahm.
Wenn wir jetzt keine Forschung mehr in dieser Hinsicht haben wissen wir gar nicht ob es vielleicht noch andere Möglichkeiten gäbe der Energienutzung die da durchaus entstehen könnte.
Andererseits wird aber schon gesagt Wir müssen die auch entwickeln.
Das heißt Wir entwickeln Waffen um dann sagen zu können wo die Grenzen sind und wir haben aber auch schon einmal festgestellt wie wir das auch bei der Gesichtserkennung schon mal gesagt haben.
Es gibt Dinge die entwickelt sind die sind dann an sich schlecht da braucht man die braucht man auch nicht dafür extra nochmal entwickeln.
Das ist jetzt unsinnig das wäre ich kauf mir auch nicht zu Hause Waffen in den Schrank damit ich mal weiß was ich nicht verwenden will.
Ja das ist so. Dieses Argument von vielen Mask was weshalb er mit Mark Zuckerberg zusammen eine künstliche Intelligenz Forschung unternimmt um zu verstehen wann es vorbei ist um in der ersten Reihe zu sitzen. Es dann passieren.
Ich denke aber man kann das sehr gut theoretisch durchspielen und kann ja auch weiterhin Think-Tanks betreiben.
Man.
Ohne dass man,
sie nicht verwenden. Das ist eine eigenartige Argumentation Man muss bedenken hier es eine mächtige Lobby die auch in Deutschland gut produzieren wir haben ja auf dem Feld.
Auf der.
Gut aufgestellte Unternehmen verknüpft mit der,
schwächelnden Rüstungsindustrie gerade weil man doch irgendwie.
Mehr nach Saudi-Arabien exportiert.
So Sachen machen darf. Wer weiß.
Aber es gibt weil er meinte wir können es ja eh nicht verhindern und so,
steckt er auch mal so drin sondern das ganze militärische arbeiten ist ja sowieso hochgradig automatisiert das hat man ja wieder gesehen an diesem Abschuss eines Passagierflugzeugs im Iran.
Das sind ja einfach so Ereignisse überhaupt noch menschliche Intelligenz im Spiel oder sind das alles nur noch Skripte die einfach durchlaufen.
Hofstätter Ich finde es jetzt nicht in meinem Regal das ähnlich so viele Bücher in sich hat aber immerhin Hofstätter hatte damals von Schirrmacher inspiriert ein Buch geschrieben sie wissen alles und es beginnt genau mit so einer Anekdote.
Ein amerikanisches U-Boot fährt so rum sieht irgendwas Radar und dann sind es die Menschen die da einfach entscheiden wir schießen jetzt mal ein Flugzeug ab und an Wahrheiten Passagierflugzeuge. Also so was.
Diese Automatismen passieren sowieso die ganze Zeit die Frage ist nur inwieweit man sie noch in Technik überträgt.
Aber eigentlich müsste man auch mal über diese Automatismen diskutieren was dann auch dazu führen würde dass man in solchen Debatten auch mal fragt die UN und die Nato und überhaupt was wie gehen wir.
Also was machen wir aus diesen Gremien welche Potenziale müssen wir denn auf diese Gremien einfach mal wieder entscheidungsfähig zu sein ist gar nicht erst soweit kommen zu lassen dass nur noch so ein Automatismus wie im Kalten Krieg abläuft.
Da war es ja dann Abschreckung als wenn ihr schießt Wir schießen auf jeden Fall weil wir können es gar nicht verhindern so krass haben wir uns Autobatterien gebaut.
Dann ist es zu spät wenn man einer Entwicklung entgegensteht bei der man sagt kann man gar nicht verhindern. Es wird darauf hinauslaufen dass es so kommt.
Entscheidung ist ein gutes Stichwort Wir werden jetzt nach Dürrenmatt und Asimov noch einmal literarisch und zwar bei dem letzten Redner.
Wir kommen zum Schluss dass die CDU CSU-Fraktion.
Ein Soldat des Ersten Weltkrieges hat seine Vorstellung von Ethos in der Schlacht wie folgt formuliert Ich darf zitieren mit Genehmigung des Präsidenten,
Zitat Es ist im Kriege immer mein Ideal gewesen den Gegner unter Ausschaltung des Hassgefühle nur im Kampfe als solchen zu betrachten und ihn als man seinem Mute entsprechend zu werten.
So beschreibt Ernst Jünger in seinen Stahlgewittern in einer akkadischen Vorstellung des Kampfes Mann gegen Mann.
Das ist spätestens seit der Nutzung der Artillerie so nicht mehr möglich ist zwar nicht autonom aber sie ist so weit entfernt dass natürlich dieses Ethos nicht ausreicht.
Wir brauchen ein anderes ein stärkeres Ethos.
Der Begriff Ethos ist das ist es ja so ist das Ernst Jünger als Ethos verstanden. Ob sie es mögen oder nicht.
Die Linke.
Sei,
Stahlhelm Romantik schreibt.
Das ist selbstverständlich Unsinn was Ernst Jünger hier beschreibt ist das sind zwischenstaatliche Kriege von diesem,
Paradigma eines gerechten Krieges ausgehen. Wir haben mit dem Westfälischen Frieden nicht nur eine Friedensordnung sondern zwischenstaatliche Kriege.
Diese sind Freund und Feind je nachdem auf welcher Seite man.
Am Ende auch wieder dazu dass es einen Friedensvertrag geben kann.
Das heißt wir haben nicht eine absolute Feindschaft Es wäre jetzt beispielsweise undenkbar mit Terroristen einen Friedensvertrag zu schließen und zu sagen Na ja,
wir haben euch in diesem Krieg darum geht es ja und jetzt können wir einen Friedensvertrag sondern wir haben dort eine absolute Feindschaft und absolute Vernichtung des Gegners und nicht mehr die Anerkennung,
diese zwischenstaatlichen Kriege.
Am Ende dann auch dazu führen dass man den Gegner erblickt aber nicht,
Subjekt sondern dass es eigentlich eine Begegnung auf Augenhöhe Mann gegen Mann stehen sich gegenüber und.
Am besten,
in der Schlacht der Gewinner. Aber das heißt nicht dass man dadurch den Feind diskriminieren soll Antidiskriminierung war ein ganz entscheidender,
ist heute tatsächlich nicht mehr so präsent da wir diese Art der zwischenstaatlichen Kriege immer weniger haben.
Stattdessen haben wir es mit asymmetrischen Kriegen zu tun mit totalen Kriegen insofern als überall herumschwirren können überall können Micro Einsätze stattfinden.
Das führt dann dazu dass es ein solches Ethos nicht mehr geben kann und lässt dann leider der Redner so etwas aussehen könnte müsste.
Aber es ist ein ganz großes Problem diese,
Konstellation. Das war etwas ziemlich Humanes. Diese Art der Betrachtung.
Aber man kann wenn man so einen Eindruck davon gewinnen will wie so eine Begegnung stattgefunden hat. In pointierter Form.
Da gibt es auch einen Krieg. Dort sind die beiden Armeen die sich gegenüberstehen geradezu leidenschaftslose aufeinander zu bekämpfen sich und manche bleiben.
Aber in gewissen Sinne ist es ja dann doch nicht verkehrt ja romantisch rein zu rufen wenn auch nicht Stahlhelme aber so.
Aber es hatte einen rechtlichen Rahmen der dies zuließ.
Im Sinne von Vergleichswerten wie heute Krieg geführt wird.
Man macht erst mal eine klandestine digitale Aktion in der Hoffnung viel auszuschalten und dann überfällt man nachts mit irgendwelchen Roper dann ferngesteuert vom anderen Ende der Welt.
Ernst Jünger doch noch da muss man ja mit dem Begriff Romantik nicht übertreiben aber es ist doch irgendwie so eine gewisse Romantik steckt schon drin.
Krieg Krieg Krieg anders als Krieg gibt's ja noch die Werbebranche.
Da wird das gleiche Targeting verwendet nur danach anders geschossen.
Ich war ein bisschen überrascht wie wir alle wissen Der Thinktank ab 2019 in China einen digitalen Werbe Marktanteil von 22 Prozent erreicht.
Das heißt da ging tatsächlich eine Losung aus einfach mal eine Milliarde in Werbung für das eigene Produkt zu stecken um dann damit Werbung zu machen.
Ausgangslage waren 40 Prozent 2017. Die haben da ordentlich aufgeholt und den anderen Vereinen Baidu also dem chinesischen Google ordentlich Marktanteil abgegrast.
Und es sind tatsächlich bisher erst 80 Milliarden die überhaupt in Dollar jetzt in chinesischer Währung.
Der chinesische digitale Werbemarkt groß und hält jetzt 22 Prozent davon.
Es gibt aber maßgebliche fand ich ganz überrascht.
Facebook schiebt den Start seiner Dating-App oder Dating Sache in der Facebook-App in Europa nach hinten.
Wieso interessieren sich Wolfgang Stefan dafür stellt sich heraus Es ist das allererste Mal dass eine App oder ein Aspekt einer App wegen drohender Regulierung oder Angst vor Regulierung zurückgehalten wurde.
Bisher ist das Silicon Valley gesagt Wir digitalisieren auch Bibliotheken und dann gucken wir rechtliche Rahmen so aussieht genau.
Fangen wir mit den Google-Auto.
Dieses Dating Dating ist jetzt das erste Mal dass da ein Matching nicht ganz funktioniert hat.
Ich bin ja erstaunt darüber wie spät Facebook damit generell dran ist wenn man bedenkt wie viel Dating-App,
Tinder genutzt wird obwohl man mir sagte Eigentlich ist die vornehmes Dating-App wenn man so möchte Instagram.
Man schreibt sich ja dann auch schon viel voneinander gesehen und schreibt sich so voll inspirierende Storys darüber ergeben sich dann auf ganz neue Art Matches.
Wie Instagram die Seele auffrisst lesen wir gleich im Salon nächste Woche.
Wenn es nicht so gut funktioniert wenn du bleibst und zu Hause bist und auf Snapchat Angst Depressionen Stress Trauer Suizid oder Bulldoggen oder irgendwas anderes suchst.
Alleine bleibt aus Angst Depression aus.
Dann reagiert die App wie ein Freund mit einer neuen Funktion.
Die.
So wie man die Zeit zu Hause verbringt und sich denkt Ich nehme lieber an den Freundschaften der anderen teil.
Aus.
Freundschaft.
Als Zuschauer springt dann die App selbst in die Bresche wenn man das ein bisschen zu deutlich zeigt dass man hier einsam ist und dann.
Dann.
Auch schon in dem Buch.
All diese Dinge anbelangt sondern auch solche Apps Gesundheits-Apps werden immer wichtiger.
Auf den Gemütszustand. Snapchat bietet dir dann Kontakt zur Hilfseinrichtungen in deiner Nähe.
Also gar nicht so schlecht. Eine groß angelegte Studie Stanford 60 Seiten lang von Bloomberg fasst zusammen Leute sind,
bereit für 1000 Dollar im Median und für 180 Dollar im Durchschnitt auf Facebook zu verzichten was eine Hochrechnung ist eine volkswirtschaftliche Hochrechnung.
Das werde ich dann im Salon ein bisschen noch ausführlicher verlinken wenn man den volkswirtschaftlichen Wert von Facebook danach berechnet wieviel Leute bereit sind auf Facebook zu verzichten.
Welche finanzielle Kompensation sie haben wollen dann kommt man auf einen finanziellen Mehrwert von Facebook von ungefähr eine Milliarde pro Tag,
also wenn man die Leute aus Facebook herauskaufen wollte müsste man ungefähr eine Milliarde am Tag mobilisieren.
Dann wären die Leute bereit freiwillig zu verzichten.
Investitionsprogramms.
Das ist gar nicht so interessant irgendwie gerade fanden am 12.
Bis 14. Februar die ersten Verhandlungstage statt Google steht ja vor Gericht.
Haben Sie selbst sich ausgesucht weil sie Vestager widersprochen haben die meinte ihr bezahlt jetzt mal schön hier neun Milliarden für euer ausnutzen aber das letzte Mal darüber gesprochen dass ihr gleichzeitig der Marktplatz für Suchergebnisse und eure Produkte über euer Shopping,
verkauft. Da gab es ja großen Widerstand.
Nachdem Google schon gar nicht mehr hatte im Angebot aber dann gab es die Strafe dahinter und diese ersten 2,4 Milliarden die werden jetzt vor Gericht verhandelt und insgesamt geht es um neun Milliarden und da gucken natürlich viele drauf.
Vor allem neue Personalia in Frankreich hat ja Macron seine ehemalige Ministerin durchbekommen als EU-Kommissarin.
Jetzt ist ja Thierry Breton da der Kaufhäuser geleitet hat und auch französische.
Mobilfunkkonzern. Er ist ja als Verteidigungs Binnenmarkt Industrie und Verteidigungs Verteidigung Kommissar und springt jetzt auch Vestager.
Die beiden haben sich offiziell verbündet.
Wahrscheinlich so meine Vermutung weil Macron doch noch ein Hühnchen im Silicon Valley nachdem Trump da rein ging und meinte Ihr dürft ja keine Steuern erheben es ist ja unser Geld das ihr da einsammeln wollen.
Also nicht schlecht und YouTube alle erst einmal Zahlen veröffentlicht.
Ja und die sind viel größer als gedacht.
Größer als die amerikanischen Fernsehsender zusammengenommen.
Und die sind auch für das Unternehmen wichtiger als gedacht für Google wichtiger als gedacht.
Gerade zehn Prozent von Google Youtube. Es geht hier um fünf Milliarden Quartalsumsatz.
Damit könnte man auch die Fernsehlandschaft bespielen in Amerika könnte man sozusagen eins zu eins austauschen.
Die Sender schließen das Ganze Werbegeld für den Wahlkampf sowieso gleich umleiten und dann gab es eine Veranstaltung.
Mark Zuckerberg hat sich öffentlich gezeigt und ich war ein bisschen überrascht wie sehr Mark Zuckerberg jetzt doch geht da gar keine.
Man dachte ja irgendwie vielleicht hätte ich noch irgendwas zurück oder so ein bisschen Zurückhaltung wäre nicht schlecht aber nein er war bei einem Taki treffen nämlich dem Silicon Slope in Utah.
Ich bin nicht vom Stuhl gefallen. Es beginnt mit einer Diskussion zum Thema Free Speech,
jetzt im Wahlkampf ist ja vielleicht nicht ganz unbedeutend auf der anderen Seite die Zahl genannt der Börsenwert von Facebook hat sich verdoppelt mehr als verdoppelt seit Trumps Amtsantritt.
Da gibt's einen Profiteur der davon Nutzen ziehen kann dass einfach mehr Mosbach und Breakbeats anders bewertet wird als in der allgemeinen Diskussion.
Hipstern,
Growing.
B
Pessach.
Jubeln im Saal.
Kommentare,
zu
Facebook,
längst nicht mehr,
melden sich immer weniger an.
Alles wunderbar subsumieren kann.
Man.
Schon mal mit Blick auf den US-Wahlkampf mit welch harten Bandagen gekämpft wird,
auf der sicheren Seite.
Aber wie kämpferisch war eine.
In einem ganz anderen Modus.
Geht zu weit und das wird auch Leute verärgern. Egal wir haben schon immer Leute verärgert die gerade unter dieser Trump Wahlkampf Geschichte doch erstaunlich,
wenig diplomatisch stellt sich eine grundsätzliche Frage Wie viel Einfluss hat er jetzt eigentlich ja wenn er sagt Breakbeats keine Ahnung alle sollen hier,
hat man doch Eingriffsmöglichkeiten juristischer Natur irgendwie irgendwo müssen auch mal Grenzen sein.
Und es stellt sich die Frage so als nicht juristischer Herr sondern Herr über die Technik von Facebook Welche Möglichkeiten stehen ihm eigentlich zur Verfügung um dieses Freds Beatsteaks zu lenken.
Es ist ja durchaus die Frage Facebook hat ja damals diesen Button gemacht wo man seinen Freunden sagen könnte Ich habe gewählt und daraufhin ist die Wahlbeteiligung bei denen die das gelesen haben 1,7 Prozent nach oben gegangen und dann kamen gleich die ersten Parteien um,
Einfluss auf die Wahlbeteiligung kannst das vielleicht in unserem Sinne nutzbar machen und so was würde das kosten.
Und in welchem Rahmen er mittlerweile eingreifen kann jetzt durch technische Unterstützung.
Ist wirklich besorgniserregend das hier so salopp inhaltlichen Fall ist wo wir erst mal alle sagen aber ganz toll aber trotzdem.
Kapriziös Changes.
In Facebook und Instagram.
Generöse.
An
Fifties.
Multimedia Products Towers Herring von Facebook.
So
einfach.
Vom Tisch geräumt weil er so viel virale Videos ohne Sinn und Verstand so tickt hobbymäßig über einbrechen.
Fühlen Sie sich nicht so gut wenn sie dann sehen Es sind drei Stunden vergangen.
Einfach mal rausgenommen aus dem Spiel.
Und damit ist auch möglich dass man anderes reinbringt. Das klingt ja auch wieder so gut schön dass er sich darum sorgt dass die Leute nicht so viel Zeit mit viralen Videos verbummelt.
Aber man kann auch sagen man nimmt einfach mal raus die Artikel in denen das Wort Capitalism vorkommt.
Aber.
Da sitzt ein Wahlkämpfer da wie Blumberg die einfach sagen Geld Geld Geld mir egal ich will einfach nur Return on Investment. Ich hab hundert Millionen im Monat und natürlich bei Facebook.
Ja
Ja ja.
Wie viele Stunden können wir jetzt herauskaufen bei euch ja auch mal eine neue Idee von Wahlkampf nicht nur das eigene rein sondern das andere herauskaufen im Sinne von wieviel müssen wir jetzt in dieses Video publizieren damit das Sende Stunden für anderes wegnimmt.
Jetzt wo der andere.
Also ich einfach mal so sagt vier Stunden rausgehen Prozedere.
Das hier einfach mal so sagt Wir haben 50 Millionen Stunden rausgenommen aus dem Prozedere. Das ist schon erschreckend. Aber inhaltlich zeigt.
Und Inhalt.
Je nachdem welche Fragestellung kommt könnten wir eigentlich entsprechend.
Je nachdem welche Fragestellung kommt. Ein.
Nein,
nein nein.
Sie sind Hause.
Auch ein gutes Argument Sie wollen das Blumberg Video macht dann soll das nach einer Stunde gelöscht werden oder schon nach einer Minute oder.
Sie wollen dass Herr Blumberg wenn wir jetzt ein Video machen soll das nach einer Stunde gelöscht werden oder schon nach einer Minute oder.
Gar nicht. Das ist einfach alles nur Variablen sind ja,
eine Variable.
Man muss ja man muss sich ja nur mal auf gewisse Sprachkursus einigen die nicht vorkommen sollen und da kann man ganz schnell auch Wörter raussuchen die vielleicht Bernie Sanders ganz oft verwendet.
Auf Wörter raus.
Ganz oft verwendet. Das kann was ganz anderes sein. Jetzt ganz oft.
Das kann etwas ganz Harmloses sein wenn er jetzt so oft sagt dann kann man.
Weiß man dass das mal ein bisschen mehr. Das hat das.
Versuchen das mal ein bisschen mehr zu wissen dass der andere eine Marotte hat und das soll darauf reagieren dass es eher stärker diese Beiträge sind.
Beispiel gegeben.
Man kann sehr subtil vorgehen Man muss da gar nicht so tun als sei man der große Zensor.
Die rechnenden finde ich ja eh Chateaubriand überall sie so illegitim rausgenommen werden.
Da gibts ja auch schon Ideen wie man sie in China Halt macht das man einfach statt den Begriff zu benutzen den man eigentlich benutzen will so eine Chiffre verwendet.
Man spricht von anderen Daten oder sowas Man nimmt ein anderes Datum aber meint dann eigentlich das vom Tiananmen-Platz oder so. Und.
Aber.
Dass man das man so verschleiert denn genau sowas.
Winnie Puuh wird ja beispielsweise in China nicht sofort gelöscht weil sich das auf Praesident.
Diese Gleichstellung greift ein und zeigt dass er da mächtig ist und man sich so ein bisschen aber Social-Media führt doch zur Polarisierung wenigstens bei der Debatte mit dabei oder jetzt.
Der Tag der Social Media Leads.
Research Kamener News ergänzt.
Jan,
schwierigstes die für die Hadorn Facts von Country in der Finding Polarisation,
nie was an,
countries Höfle Men Driving,
the voice,
überfragt Exons.
The same wie es kein Mainstream passt.
Irgendwo wird vielleicht demnächst ganzen großen Argumenten ein bisschen Luft rausnehmen.
Ansonsten gibt es verschiedene Einflüsse aus.
Er redet sich um Kopf und Kragen denn es gibt ja die Argumentation dass es in Ländern wie Myanmar oder so oder Indien so große,
wie man sie Selbstjustiz Ansammlungen Happenings gibt irgendwie und sein Argument dagegen ist.
Naja man sieht ja Polarisierungen so ein bisschen zurückgehen und es wäre nicht denkbar dass es in einem Land so funktioniert in anderen anders oder doch überall dasselbe.
Irgendwie ist das schon ziemlich Banane.
Jetzt stelle man sich die Frage aber eigentlich will sie doch König sein oder so viel Macht und in welchem Land können sie den vorstellen König zu sein.
Und da kommt er jetzt mit seiner virtuellen Realität.
Alle haben hier eine via,
Experience.
Setzte und auf Präsenz.
Ping-Pong,
Döhring.
Interview.
An
Den Wahlen.
Adams.
Grad gut fürs Klima. Virtuelle Realität.
Natürlich ist schön dass das auch noch was ist das eigentlich immer für einen vollkommen bescheuertes Publikum das dann immer bei jedem Satz jubelt es ist ja grässlich.
Also verliert man hier wirklich den Glauben.
Ein bisschen ironisch dass er die Frage stellt während er über virtuelle Realität spricht weil ist natürlich die Anwesenheit die dazu führt während er darüber spricht.
Ja genau. Ha ha ha ha.
Ich hatte mal König im virtuellen.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Raum. Naja jedenfalls wirklich. Oder er sieht sich wirklich als König der Welt.
Skinners Talking Heads.
Sollten wir hier nicht sagen dass dieser Mann viel gefährlicher ist als ein mächtiger gefährlicher und.
Mächtiger und gefährlicher.
Je mehr freiwillig ausgeliefert. Genau das ist ja Freiheit.
Noch.
Viel erschreckender Wahlkampf oder so. Aber vermutlich ist das hier wirklich entscheidend.
Im Prinzip kann er ja sagen.
Ist mir wurscht wer jetzt gerade Präsident wird global agiert ist für ihn ja auch die Wahl am Ende genauso wichtig wie die Wahl ob er wiedergewählt wird oder ob die.
Demokratischen Kandidaten vergessen haben alle Ministerpräsidenten werden wir uns nicht mehr erinnern können.
Aber wir werden sehr wahrscheinlich über diese neue Herrschaft vielleicht auch gar keine politische oder parlamentarische Legitimation.
Mein Sohn erkennt noch irgendwelche Haltepunkte. Er hat noch jemand über sich irgendwo angebunden oder schwebt da wirklich über dieser Welt. Wie.
Irgendwo schwebt er wirklich über. Ich glaube ich habe nicht den Eindruck.
Ja
Bei der zam.
Aber.
Seeberg Redding Menschen.
Werden,
samtweich.
Die Antwort ist egal. Der Typ stellt fest mein Gesprächspartner der mächtigste Mann der Welt akzeptiert im Grunde nur noch Gott über sich Orientierung zu finden.
Das aber großartig weil wir sind ja gut dass wir da gleich sind und die nächste Frage der dann von seinem Zettel abliest ist,
Wie richtet man jetzt den Zwang in seinem Unternehmen richtig aus wenn man so ein Herrscher ist wie du freier Herrscher. Es fällt überhaupt nicht auf.
Das ist im Quadrat gruselig zu sehen.
Wenigstens noch zu dass er so Paar Berater hat oder so. Aber das hier ist ja das.
Das ist wirklich schlimm. Naja das virtuelle gut da kann man natürlich König sein.
Müssen wir auch nochmal deutlich machen das haben wir aber ich muss es auch sagen. Das müsste eigentlich in der Tagesschau das Topthema sein.
Würde ich außer Acht.
Auf allen Titelseiten stehen. Das wäre entscheidend.
Lassen wäre ich.
Nachfolgefrage Merkel noch unklar.
Ich habe die Rede ist mir durch nichts rein gespielt worden ich habe tatsächlich bei youtube einfach gesucht.
Mark Zuckerberg Video länger als 20 Minuten ein Monat alt.
Nirgendwo wird jetzt nirgendwo ich es irgendwie Ich habe es nicht einmal danach gesucht aber ich habe jetzt über diese Kanäle nie gefunden.
Es war einfach nur elementarer was sagt Mark Zuckerberg eigentlich gerade. Das ist dann das Resultat,
dieses Finale hier in seinem Gespräch Wir hören einfach mal zu und wir hören zwischen den Zeilen oder auch ein bisschen expliziter so sein Grundverständnis.
Seine Aufgabe im Besonderen dass er sie sich selbst gestellt hat weil er keine Aufgaben mehr von irgendwem Er kann sich ja selber aussuchen was er macht.
Jüdisch denken in.
Dieses Prinzip Börse Round swingende virtuos.
Wo ich wo zu Hause Pippo Heising ein.
Huan.
Geringster.
Ein Mann des Volkes der dafür sorgt dass der kleine Mann eine Stimme bekommt aber durch seine algorithmischen Bahnen laufen muss und sie werberelevante.
Er macht das Leaving playing field. Das ist ja im Grunde braucht ein Recht aber es muss für alle gleich sein.
Und dann kann man es auch so lassen und dann wissen alle worum es geht.
Und er möchte dann die powern weil die Schiiten gegen Schiiten sind ja nicht so gut.
Es ist zwar gerade mal Blumberg irgendwie aber egal.
Diese ganze Idee von dieser Freiheit steckte wieder drin.
Der Einzelne der Superfrau so wie er immer sagt Ich baue hier Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft mit selbstverständlich.
Diese Worte.
Kann man wieder sehen warum man dieses wie Obama sagte in hohem Maße partizipative Gespräche über Politik braucht und nicht nur so,
dahin legt seine Vision dar und geht wie keiner denkt darüber nach weil wir wirklich alle in dieser Facebook Welt einfach,
die Freiheiten zuordnet dass alle irgendwie.
Von hinten bis vorne verlogen so wie bei Heike hat nur Bücher geschrieben.
Der schreibt halt wirklich die Software als Betriebssystem für die halbe Welt irgendwie ist das schon sehr besorgniserregend.
Blödesten Moderator der Welt gegenüber.
Ein bisschen Glück gehabt.
Ein bisschen traurig aber so ist es manchmal. Wir werden das aber im Auge behalten.
Aber erstmal frohe Botschaften aus dem Silicon Valley.
Da muss man schon sehr optimistisch sein. Aber vielleicht im Salon.
Was können wir eigentlich,
noch sehen. Die vielen Satelliten die da oben sind aber auch.
Astronomische,
Satelliten. Es geht aber auch um das Klima,
dieses 2-Grad-Ziel und Klima Klimapolitik. Wie ist es eigentlich mit Umweltpolitik wie ist das eigentlich miteinander zu verbinden. Wie schließt sich das aus.
Ein sehr interessanter Beitrag der sagt Wir müssen eigentlich,
ganz andere Dinge in den Fokus rücken. Jemand der von der Klimapolitik und Umweltpolitik spricht aber doch diese starke Fokussierung,
kritisiert wird auch noch darum gehen wie China eigentlich den,
Westen in Europa. Die Frage ob wir uns.
Ich lese für euch ungefähr 250 Seiten der fünfhundert Seiten der Journalisten Philipp Rucker und Carrel E-Learning oder E-Learning.
Wir haben nämlich ein ziemlich stabil ist einfach genial der Typ sagt Okay wir überprüfen das jetzt mal kurz und schreiben mal ein Buch darüber einfach nochmal aufschlüsseln.
Wie stabil ist eigentlich das Guiness Trump und es ist ganz interessant vermarktet weil du dann drei Bücher dafür und dann kannst du da ordentlich nochmal nachlesen.
Da wird er richtig in Grund und Boden geschrieben Seid gespannt danach.
Wir haben uns über heiliggesprochen Zuckerberg sozusagen praktische Umsetzung.
Aber es gibt in Großbritannien ein Regierungsberater Dominic Cummings kennen wir von Cumberbatch gespielt und es gibt einen Guardian Journalisten der sich zu Neujahrsvorsätze genommen hat.
Ich lese jetzt mal kommen Dominic Cummings Blog zurück bis 2013 Was steckt da eigentlich drin.
Und wenn ihr euch bisher noch nicht gefürchtet habt vor Zuckerberg oder Hayek dann kommt nicht in den Salon der da wird es gruselig.
Und dann seid The World in.
Tausend ein hundert Jahre alter Text in dem mal voraus geschaut wurde und man hat die eine oder andere falsche Vorhersage zum Thema Energieversorgung der Welt gemacht.
Man hat ganz besondere ängste dass rückblickend nochmal zu lesen ist.
Ein bisschen ist so skurril dass ich dachte ich Salar da noch einmal vor. Heute dann nächste Woche Seid gespannt.
Und dass es dann mit der Paywall Das heißt Man kommt rein wenn man über die ganze Nacht auf der Seite.
Mit harter Paywall.
Ihr seht auf der Seite einen Button der ist gelb und leuchtet und da steht Salone drauf und da kommt ihr dann zu.
Auf.
Schnell das Paket und da kriegt er dann einen eigenen Sweat der ist ganz hoch individuell euer eigener.
Eigenen.
Und wenn er den abonniert bekommt die den Salon wie jeden anderen Podcast.
Wir versuchen.
Wir versuchen ja nicht mal harte Paywall weil ich denke es ist Zeit warum nicht.
Und wir bereiten uns gut vor haben viel gelesen.
Wenn ich glaube ich habe noch so Instagram Texte aus dem Magazin n+1 kannte ich vorher gar nicht.
Insgesamt 50000 Zeichen lang. Der ist noch länger als.
Länger als ein Jahr länger als.
Merkur Text Text Texte sind ja dann doch bei 30000 Euro gedeckelt aber hier wird noch mal richtig in Instagram und Instagram die Seele auffrisst.
Im Salon nächste Woche,
Sharknado.
Intro